thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the pro chess league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
Katrina luck no super strong player but
way Yi is Unstoppable in the protest
League welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives oh my gosh that was another
sick tactic by Arjun Eric icy he sees
everything
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion wait a second uh-oh is
super unhappy my friends it's the 2023
Pro chess League which team can Rise
Above the Rest they won't be able to do
it alone
foreign
it's Friday it's the final day of week
two of the pro chess League season I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me my
good buddy great I'll say GM GM panty PJ
Master James Kane the third James good
of you to join me how you feeling about
your Garden State passers and the PCL oh
man well first off I'm a high energy
chat okay it's Friday right we have
another PCL match I'm here with you
can't play or do no type of Chess
without Hess the big man himself and I'm
here with the chat and I'm hyping of
course my pastors are right in there you
know all we need is two more ways to
make it to a playoffs here so we're
feeling good how about you bro
I'm feeling great and so are the
Shanghai Tigers because yesterday we had
two results two wins one match win by
the Shanghai Tigers 10 and a half five
and a half over the Blitz and then MGD
won they take down the St Louis
archbishops nine out of six now so James
you're seeing those results from
yesterday's action what do you make of
the Tigris from Shanghai well you know
the tigers are tigers okay it's a tiger
for a reason it's not a lion but it also
is very scary as the tiger gang right in
the chat I see tiger gang right it's
very scary these guys are very very very
very strong right as you see the score
there is 2-0 not a lot of people with
2-0 right now around
and how surprising you to see the St
Louis archbishops drop to oh and two we
know they got Fabiano they got Dominguez
they got all stars in that lineup but
they've lost both their matches yeah it
actually looks like a typo there like yo
hey can you get a the backhand it's
supposed to be too old there it's the
archbishops what is the old I mean a 2-0
right why is there a O2 here I don't
understand right it doesn't look right
because we know how strong we actually
really are
they're almost as strong as you James we
know you flexing out there St Louis they
need to get on that workout grind but uh
let's look at the standing to see some
of the teams that have had early season
success uh because when I look from the
top there the Indian yogis the levitov
chest Wizards the Shanghai Tigers I mean
James those are three of the best teams
in the league and of course we'll see
who reaches those Heights between the
California unicorns and the Gotham
Knights later absolutely of course yeah
they have you see these one and one
there then you got the bottoms one and
one and one and one oh um so yeah this
is a crucial match I mean of course
whoever loses like a you know you could
lose again and then be out of the PCO
indefinitely right so it's really tough
here this is a lot on the line today
especially if you're trying you know to
make it in advance to the playoffs here
for sure and on the other side of things
are with all winners they're unfortunate
are losers in competition and we see the
bottom of the standings St Louis we just
talked about how surprising is to see
them there but James the Charlotte
cobras Daniel nairdiski's on that Squad
they're on the brink of elimination
they are in fact that Venom is uh it's
not as potent as we think we thought it
was no but at the same time Charlotte
covers is a monster Team all these teams
are monstrous is really is about who is
actually you know better that day you
know because they can all beat each
other and you know we we've even seen
some um some upsets I'm just saying
there's lots of those even the one where
uh you know nikaru Lost first round
first game PCL hecaro goes down right
you know that's crazy like who thinks of
that kind of thing but you never know I
mean this is a such a hard format and
such strong teams of course um we'll see
what happens today and what do you think
about the second team listed on the back
half of the Saints the Garden State
passers uh yeah I'm sure you have a
thing or two to say look uh we are two
wins away all we one day at a time one
game at a time one match at a time we
are two away from the playoffs right now
so we are real hype right now about that
but we are not hyped about who we gonna
play obviously because it's going to be
somebody strong we will see uh both
about the matchups and see how
everybody's doing you know probably
later but yeah we're feeling good Garden
State passes we got a great team should
be feeling good and the loser of the
upcoming match in the Croatia Bulldogs
and the Berlin Bears they won't be
feeling so good because not only will
they drop their second match in a row
they'll have to play the St Louis
Archbishop so James as we get into
today's action starting with Berlin and
Croatia I mean they really want to avoid
St Louis at all costs as you said it
looks like a typo to see St Louis at the
bottom of the standings yeah absolutely
you see there at 0101 okay that's fine
and you got 1010 there later on we got
some big matches too but all these
matches are huge here but hey taking
that L and then you gotta go face you
know like you you lose to one GM and
then you go face another strong GM right
after right so that's really one of
these situations where we lose if you
whoever loses here you got to face those
Bishops probably most likely you're
going to face the Bishops on one team
but that's not going to be a bishop
you're trying to face any time of the
day
and what about the Gotham Knights and
the California unicorns we know Hikaru
Nakamura and the big fish are playing
for the Gotham Knights but for the
unicorns we got Big Sam Shanklin and Ray
Robson so that's a heavyweight matchup
between those two teams later today yeah
that's gonna be a swing fast guys you're
gonna have some of the best obviously
you have Hikaru here to streamer himself
you know you can have fun with that one
right and then you got Sam shakeling big
Sammy and that's the other Sam I am
right you got Sam I am on my team and
you got the other Sam I am so but it's
big shank land over there so take him to
shankland that's what we'll be saying
with Sam so it's pretty nice though and
now you also have Ray the puzzle machine
right oh my goodness I always say rehab
big Ray and have a nice day right it's
really he's that strong you know what I
mean like his puzzles our next level we
know this right so that's gonna be a
very Wicked matchup and we can see that
one too yeah I can't wait either but we
will have to wait because we will start
with the Berlin Bears and the Croatia
Bulldogs let's start with the Bears they
have a very strong lineup they would
like to bounce back from their loss last
week and they've got the likes of blue
Baum Rasmus spani Dimitri color so you
see this lineup James and Josephine
heinemann down there second from the
bottom in terms of ratings heading into
this season she beat Hikaru so if she
can do that again upset the top boards I
think the Berlin Bears have a chance
that's actually a scary you know scary
like oh yeah Joseph oh yeah she's the WG
I mean that should be fine right on any
board especially facing you know on the
the opposing team right I'm actually
like hey you know Josephine is no one
until you see that she be Hikaru right
and then you're like oh my goodness wait
what is this team really about she's
very underrated to say the least she be
Hikaru the first game that Hikaru played
in the PCL he lost to Josephine right
that's a statement it definitely is and
what do you make of the brothers funny
you know it's nice to see a family
affair on this Berlin bear Squad
absolutely of course they're very very
strong right there was actually uh ready
uh um back-end stuff today about a
little
brothers and there was one other one in
there too but oh donchenko I was like
wow that's insane it was a four you know
four-man Squad since they were kids to
become GM's like that's so nice so they
have a very nice camaraderie there I
think team camaraderie is very important
so being around the team knowing what my
team is capable of doing just like in
any other sport here you know it can
boost the morale that could boost you
know how you play that day yeah this is
a you know German team with some
exceptions but they're going to face off
against the Croatia Bulldogs in this
match and the Bulldogs we know they've
got some serious bite they also have a
kind of an international Flair to this
squad because they do have a number of
the best Croatian players but at the top
they're led by bogdon Daniel dayat's
2700 then they've got the likes of
indich and Mustafa ilmaz who did so well
in the title sales challenges event so
uh James you know Paulina shuvalova
quite well you've matched up against her
before but what do you make of this
roster from Croatia honestly it's a uh
it's it's more of like a intro obviously
interesting because there are teams
there's like so many flags there you see
the the diversity there of like all
these players from all over the world
are really here a lot of Croatia too as
well but you know it's just it's a they
put the team together pretty nicely here
so you have to see how they work well
together I think it looks great well on
paper 27 honey I got a 2-7 on the squad
then you got 26 30 26 26 25 this team is
very high rated I mean the lowest here
is 23.63 like she's you know it's really
tough everybody out here can swing right
so it's going to be a I think a very
interesting matchup today
for sure we know now know who the teams
can't choose but they have to have a
certain selection process to pick their
lineups each and every week because
there are regulations and that includes
a 2550 average rating cap that teams
must have at least one female player
participating each week players above
2700 they count as 2700 and women over
23.50 count as 20 through 50. that
encourages teams to have the best each
and every week and also James that under
2200 rated counting is 200 I think it's
important because it forces teams to
have a more balanced roster you can't
just stack it with all the super GMS and
then have like a you know 1200 on the
button board I know some people chat
wishes they could team up with uh Magnus
and Anish and dingly ren but that's not
how it's going to work here oh of course
not chat right we can't just put all
2700s on the team and just run it every
week right that'd just be a four-man
roster that's it just four people that's
it and just stacking when we run them
every single week we train together we
do everything together making it more
balance is going to be more tough for
everyone even the teams that may seem
like they're a favorite on paper
for sure well we know now who you can
choose and what the selection process is
like but let's actually look at today's
lineups because sometimes you tried out
the same lineup as the previous week but
I see new names new faces on the board
the top board for the Croatia Bulldogs
is that super gym focused on Daniel
Deutsch against Matthias bluebound so
that is a heavyweight on the top one
there and then we got kolars and Mustafa
ilma so James that's kind of my X Factor
is board two there I feel like both of
these players a bit underrated when you
think of their rapid skills absolutely
in fact I remember Mostafa yield fast
and I think I don't remember where it
maybe was that qualifier there but I
remember doing commentary and I just
kept saying Yeah Mustafa is here okay he
is making a statement and he was running
and I remember him very very well I just
can't remember what event it was but I
know Mustafa is very very strong and
underrated
yeah he did really it was tough to steal
Challenger's event he almost took that
down but donchenko another German player
was too strong but Josephine heinemann
James we've been talking about her she
beat Hikaru Nakamura in week one and
Aileen robers for the Croatia Bulldog
she's had some great performances to her
name she would like to do the same she's
saying don't just talk about Josephine
I'm here too right of course you know
the ladies are very very uh fierce in
chess I mean in every sport right the
ladies are the ones really especially if
you see the women's chest and you watch
like even a Grand Prix when it just just
passed every game almost everyone was
like decisive or there were chances for
a lot of decisiveness right on the board
so they played to kill right so that's
not going to be you know a light matchup
at all there are no free points in the
Pro chess league and we do start in our
first round of action with the most
lopsided pairings with board one for one
team Plus board four for the other which
is as we dive into the specifics here
the Croatia Bulldogs on board four Ellen
Roberts she gets the white pieces
against bluebaum and bardia dinesha we
actually haven't highlighted him yet a
strong Iranian International master and
I am for now he'll be a GM tomorrow he's
already at 2500. so what do you make of
this who do you think has the advantage
with their lower boys getting the white
pieces do you like Berlin or Croatia in
the first round you know I actually like
Croatian in the first round here I think
they have some things to prove here um
especially like we know you know
um that uh the bears actually in fact
Josephine was able to take down
um Hikaru and they have a very strong
line they got good camaraderie a lot of
German players there too as well I think
they have some things to prove
especially
um you know bardia too as well being a
young International master or about to
be GM very soon he's about to you know
play kolars this round uh strong GM
there he wants something to prove I
think they're hungry I think it's a lot
about you know that hunger right now
yeah and I I really love these
first-time matchups because we saw
Alexander castenyuk and your bella
coaching us really take down the board
one for the opposing team it happens
obsessed in chess certainly happened in
a long match the higher rate of player
will almost certainly win but in short
spurts in a single game of course these
upsets can happen so we will start with
Aline robbers and Matthias bluebaum uh
just a reminder to everybody of how this
match format works because you may be
hearing us talk about names and
different boards and what's the
importance of each board in this event
all four players play all four from the
other team so as you see it's an all
play all format with 10 minute and two
second increment time control up to four
rounds because if a team breaches that
eight and a half Point score after three
rounds you don't play the fourth it's
all over there uh but James we love tie
breaks we haven't had them this week so
we've been deprived of the 8-8 score
with a blitz tie break but we know all
the fans want to see that absolutely the
fans do want to see the tie breaks
there's just more chess it's more energy
and more uh more to lie honestly say the
least but eight and a half is as
clinching the match we've seen a lot of
that we've seen some blowouts but we
also have not you know we've seen some
very close matches as well that 10 plus
two is really really important that you
uh you're good with your time here and
of course if you start getting along
time it can be very problematic because
that two seconds is not a lot of time
not a lot that's true you got to be
quick out of the gates and we are going
to start with the board 4 for the
Croatia Bulldogs Ellen robbers taking on
Matthias blue bumps so it's going to
start in a minute she has the white
pieces James he's the higher rated
player you're a team captain so when you
see these kind of mismatches on paper do
you encourage the low rate of player to
try to force and draw if it's available
or do you really truly encourage them
just to play their game should she just
say you know what I've beaten Irvin La
me in the Challenger Tournament talk to
steal I could take down blue bomb as
well that's exactly how you go into it
with the right mindset it starts in the
mind right there and of course she just
got to go out here and swing that's what
I'm telling my my team members yo just
swing just go out there play a game
right of course don't act like you're
playing someone that you know you don't
know who you're playing or like you uh
you look at your pairing hey what board
am I at I'm gonna go sit down I'm gonna
just play the game right and and play my
opportunities right in front of me so
she's in the zone you can see right hand
on the head they're ready to go like no
move she's just already calculating
calculating what
everything you see the see the library I
see so many books behind her it's like a
one of the most impressive studies I've
seen wow that's actually a really nice
Library here let's look at that wall
books everywhere yeah all of them trust
books too Chad look at that yeah that's
the devaresky over there you she's
looking at listening to the stream yeah
yeah
I see
I see some kaspar migrant predecessors
somewhere as well you know it's it's
everywhere there but she is improving
she's just a teenager getting stronger
every single event and we'll see if the
protest league is to her liking she's
International Master she is taking on
Blue bomb here she did really well in
the Olympiad I think she had the high
score along with Pia Kremlin in terms of
top performance rating I think the exact
same performance rating so she has taken
down some big names in the Chess World
oh that's actually huge especially uh
being a legendary um yet Legendary
player so senior legendary women's
player as well I'm sure she's uh feels
great about that
and ready to play today you know blue
bomb in his own looks he looks calm
comfortable that's how you gotta be yeah
yeah well you mentioned uh you know he
was one of the the four princes of
German chess they all four of them
became Grand Masters uh when he was just
12 years old there was a lot of Buzz
around him and he has succeeded and he
actually was in the Fisher random uh
finals I mean he didn't make it all the
way to the top match but he was one of
the eight players to play live from
Reykjavik Iceland so he's showing that
he can do it in classical he can do it
in Rapid chess he can do in Fisher
random so what can't he do is the
question and I think the uh Bulldogs
would say well he can't beat us in this
match right can't beat us says the
Bulldogs right bulldogs and bears I know
Vic was talking about that earlier with
like uh you know well a bulldog and a
bear so Chad of course we put this to
you who wins the fight the Bulldogs or
the Bears chat we're gonna put it up to
you now it is on you predictions as we
wait for the games to start here yeah
actually I'm very curious what the chat
will predict because this is one of
those matchup shapes I feel like it's
very balanced neither side has kind of
like that eye-popping name like a Hikaru
yes Bogan
he's super strong but his bluebound has
competed with the best of them but you
know it's one of those matches where it
feels like the middle boards truly will
decide absolutely yeah that's that
that's a great great statement there
maybe middle boards definitely decide
there it really is about who's playing
great today anything can really happen
um because I think it's very balanced
but we have a French to start it up
I don't know about you James not the
biggest fan of the French defense but I
will say for elite Rover it's probably
just the opening you want to see easy
development after a series of Trades
it's not like black has easy counter
play and oh what do you think about this
move Queen D3 she's not hiding her
intentions actually I'm not a big fan of
that one I'm not even gonna lie recent I
mean of course casting queen size is the
way we want to go but in attacking chess
101 um that uh grandfather's grandfather
tal talks about all the time we need to
get this bishop out to D3 Queen E2 and
Castle queen size so yeah the two moves
here it feels like I guess we kind of
wasted some time but maybe now I guess
the queen is nicely placed there I do
want Bishop D3 but Knight B4 is coming
so there's C3 now okay I'm liking it now
I'm liking it Bishop come out to D3 and
we go we just start swinging at him
literally Bishop D3 Castle Queen side
launched everything I have every piece
on the king side is going to be pushed
on that side of the board oh I like it
James you are saying hold nothing back
and well I she could play 95 right that
comes with a Tempo against this bishop I
I do like the way bluebaum has just
played Knight C6 97 I'm actually not
sure where it's going it's going to D5
and F4 I feel like he's causing me to
look left and right and I feel like my
head's on a swivel oh yeah in fact
actually I like his plan after Bishop D3
to remind there's probably 95 Queen E4
maybe G6 but the idea obviously is just
like when the queen F4 we're just going
to try to trade uh when you cast a queen
side I just go Queen F4 and liquidate
all your hopes and dreams now of course
white actually is still like a little
bit better slightly but um you know I'm
just not a fan of that like I didn't
want a castle Queen side to go just to
go to an end game I would just put the
King on E2 or even you know centralize
the king a little bit more and then
instead of castling so blue bomb knows
what he's doing though very strong 26.50
so I think if you Castle here we are
running into a queen trade
yeah it's very likely with Knight D5
maybe Queen F4 things of that nature and
James in your style 95 Bishop takes Pawn
I'll give up this pawn and bring my Rook
to G1 that feels like a candy type of
idea of course absolutely I mean 952
Rook G1 and then where's the bishop go
first off there you go okay C6 right
then castles yeah I have an initiative
you do have G6 which blocks a lot let's
uh let's bring up an analysis board and
show what James is talking about James
like give you know take that pawn open
up your king and he's going this way and
he said I got an attack I got an attack
that's all we need right and it's just a
constant nagging attack especially in
these timer time controls that are very
quick like you want to make them make
them think here I have a knight G4 to H6
idea I got all kinds of doubling on the
road doubling Brooks on the G file
running the H Pawn up I mean there's a
lots of ideas here and it looks like we
have it on the board 95 and we live
she's all ready
I I'm very happy she did that because I
knew you were waiting for it I could
tell I know a James candy position when
I see one but it's one of these big
questions where you can take this Pawn
in fact the engine we just saw I said
Bishop takes you too it is one of those
positions that says black is maybe
slightly better but who cares what the
engine says it's about whose position is
easier to play and Matthias blue bump
says no no no not me not today I'm not
opening up that g file yeah he didn't
even want any any action there and you
know players like corsinoy or even the
Astro sirawan would take that pawn and
like say hey it's a pawn I'm a pawn
Grabber I'm gonna grab the pawn and hope
that you get it and hope you never get
it back right so but he didn't grab it
here so that's a win I think a little
bit for uh for a elite liner yeah well
well we'll see what she does next she'll
have to move her Queen but while she
thinks about where to put it let's go to
our bird's eye view because I just saw
in the bottom right we have a
Scandinavian defense from John Daniel
dayas you know he's taking one of John
Bartholomew's book that's still early
stages there there the top right James
that looks you know pretty level Knights
are being traded in the center and then
the bottom left I don't even know what
opening that is uh how did that Bishop
get to C7 from Mustafa right what the
heck is that many J bro what are they
just playing some stuff today some
Scandinavians and then some Randomness
over there Bishop D6 to C7 is like a
reverse like a copex system type thing
but interesting it's very strange yeah
let's uh go into that game between
Grandmaster Michael bisold and
Grandmaster Mustafa yomaz because how
this bishop like it really went around
the horn back to C7 so we're just gonna
show you how we got here very quickly it
wasn't English the bishop quickly came
out to B4 and the Knight came to E2 so
if you take this Knight on C3 the Knight
takes kind of like a rosalimo colors
reversed and James the bishop went all
the way back to C7 so it feels like
white has like four free moves like how
many pawns does white have out here both
Knights the bishop and yet Black's King
is castled whites King will take a
little bit longer to get away from the
center yeah there's a lot of space for
white white has a lot of space but the
problem I don't like about white is that
oh well with uh with the spaces there's
so there's a lot of options here and
there's a lot of things that can be
attacked so like you know obviously A5
just happened B5 D5 lots of Pawn breaks
it's flexibility for black too as well
so I mean it's a level as the engine
says to my Knights are Superfluous so
I'm not the biggest fan of where my
Knights are on ece2 and C3 but of course
we can't move them around it's still
Level I think I would actually take
white here obviously just because of the
space but black has this D5 E4 idea
because I'm probably going to Castle my
king 100 got to get my king out of the
center so this is exactly this bishop is
going to be very annoying if I'm able to
open it up I mean maybe even D5 right
now actually that should be fine no I I
like your instinct stream T5 looks like
the best move to me you when somebody's
King is in the center you want to open
up the board and rookie okay similar
intentions uh but for white no I mean I
have so many different questions about
this position 25 no if I could get this
I trap your Bishop on C7 I don't know if
it works but C5 is super tempting
because it's not that easy to stop B6
next that's actually correct C5 chain
Chad this is a strange opening don't try
this at home okay but this is definitely
one that is strange I actually like D5
from Y2 as well because I know you want
to play D5 Queen C2 is he got a castle
Queen side oh my gosh he's not doing it
he can't
yeah he might he might just bring the
Rook to D1 instead of casting all the
way there uh and Michael Bizzle by the
way so his classical rating is 2480. his
uh Blitz and Rapid rings are well above
2500 so uh he's a veteran Grand Master
he's been around the game a long time
not the first time he's seen crazy
positions and he also has a lead on the
clock so I think that there's maybe
sometimes the stigma against some of the
players uh who are a bit older like oh
they play Slowly he has a healthy minute
lead on the clock with a wild position
he is showing absolutely no fear it
doesn't matter how young his opponents
will be yeah you're actually right
that's kind of scary you know he's up on
time this position's quit it's it's
wacky right now and he's putting a tight
he's putting the pressure on Mustafa
right here in this position that is
really really Bonkers there's just so
many options here where's White gonna
put his King where is blacks developing
oh it isn't there right so like there's
nothing there you know right now there's
lots of moves to make something has to
be done and you got to do it in the
right amount of time before we take it
dangerously low one time on here for
sure so while D5 hasn't played and now
white has decided what trades do I do do
I play C5 I really want to trap this
bishop in I know after C5 black is of
course going to take on D4 to open up
space for this bishop uh but it's an
interesting position but all four games
in the Pro chess League uh they're of
equal importance so we have to look
around the horn and James to my eyes
well I mean a leaned Rover she casts a
king side in the top left actually like
what's happened there uh for her so her
King is perfectly safe and sound uh in
the top left board and then in the top
right board we haven't looked in on that
one between bardia dineshfar and Dimitri
kolars but it's starting to look a bit
messy so why don't we head on over to
that one because the I am from Iran he
has the white pieces last week he showed
some great technique and games against
Dario's spirits and other players but
I'm looking at the C6 Square James and
that looks awfully juicy oh that's a
very nice yeah very nice Square there
put the nine on C well first we have a
trade okay and queen takes again just
put in the 906 is stable stable
Advantage there and if you take it
obviously I have a pass Pawn with the
Bishops I can actually grab the bishop
pair too as well if you trade on G2 then
Knight C6 is just my Square yeah white
definitely for Choice here absolutely
even though engine is saying equal here
okay yeah but that's the best play here
B6 is weak Bishop B3 I could take I have
a weakness on A3 I do have to deal with
it but I mean I can give up just be a
three Pawn for the B I mean there's lots
of lots of ideas definitely playing for
white here for uh the advantages I mean
equal I mean takes D5 here yeah I think
that's you have to right otherwise you
move your knight back but we want to
move the knife forward so trade and
Knight C6 would like be the bullet move
but I don't think it's necessary just
yet you know you don't have to drop
there maybe at some point if Black's not
looking you go Knight D7 and hit this
opponent B6 which means E4 has to be
considered at some point the Knight C3
will hit multiple pawns so James just
one of these positions where you have to
be accurate if you are for the internet
because then if you're not your
advantage evaporates completely yeah
this is a looks like a I'm pretty uh
sure maybe not sure but this looks like
a Catalan for sure I'm not a Catalan
player myself but definitely look like
some type of Catalan happen here looking
for that Advantage here um just for the
whole game trying to add a small slight
plus and that's why it looks like we
have here but we do not have you know
anything that says besides the C6 square
and a pod on B5 that we're actually that
much better King maybe placed better I
think for in-game here if we could trade
The Rook song get the king closer to the
center we may have some choices and some
things here pushing the E and F pawns is
definitely possible too as well and of
course using our C6 Square which is
really nice but it is about timing like
how do we get it there what is the move
right now we still haven't even we you
know we got to move this bishop off to
back right which is also holding the
pawn on A3 so we have to be careful of
that too as well so lots of ideas so
yeah Knight C6 was played and the bishop
will have to move E4 being a critical
threat kicking the Knight away from its
defense of the bishop but I think the
good news for kolars is once he moves
his Bishop say to C5 the Knight can drop
back to E7 and he can get rid of this
pesky Knight over here on C6 and if
those pieces come off it's starting to
feel more and more equal good chances
for black to hold in this game but you
know white having slight maybe aesthetic
Advantage uh but it's going likely to
Peter out so why don't we hop away from
here I think we see a pretty level game
but I just saw the corner of my eye
Mustafa ilmazza in the bottom left he
now has a big advantage against Michael
bezel because that King on the bottom
left is on E1 is still in the center and
James just what you were calling for has
happened the position has been blown
open there's a king here the C file is
open this bishop isn't developed not
good you know this is one of those
things don't do this yourselves chat do
not play like this as white don't try
this at home if you can pick up the king
and put it on G one all right cool the
position is not that bad really but it's
on E1 that's a huge difference right and
it's going to take at least one two
three moves to get my king to G1 it's
gonna be a problem I may not survive
another three moves right so I need to
figure out what I need to do when I need
to do it right now in fact I was just
gonna say probably take the pawn and
just go for it I mean he did it he
definitely went for it but like it's not
this is not good no I mean you could
continue for example black and kick this
queen where is that going into the
corner somewhere over here
um you know if black doesn't prove
though that he has the quick initiative
and if the white king somehow can Castle
White did you steal a pawn in the center
of the board so I feel like
um you know black needs to be a bit
accurate here though it's clear that it
was worth the pawn look at how active
Black's pieces are all of them are
active and White's King and King side
not developed yeah this is a practical I
mean you have like maybe bishop G6
Knight E4 Tempo Tempo Tempo Tempo just
hitting you know Tempo after Tempo and
this could get really really bad here
now whoa is that Evol bar at first it
was not that high now it's like way up
there what's that eval bar say yeah it's
like I don't know minus four minus five
at this point five it doesn't feel game
over yet but it of course feels like
black is the one in charge and you're
just making all these good suggestions
just Bishop G6 94 Tempo after Tempo uh
White needs to move the knight move the
bishop and then castle and I'm not even
sure where you can move this knight uh
and if you'll have time to do so but
Mustafa UMass here he's really
calculating he wants to knock out his
opponent he doesn't want to just trade
pieces and hope that it works out
because just to show something let's say
we start trading everything thinking
okay I have that compensation there the
evaluation goes right back towards the
center so it would be a mistake to
Simply trade off the pieces uh that's
why Mustafa is trying to figure out
let's see what move order is necessary
do I have to take this Knight first or
do I play Bishop G6 first
um yeah is Knight takes F6 kind of a
threat with all these pins here the
answer is no because the queen on B1 is
under attack so if you take uh this
Knight on F6 the queen takes an even
more black pieces are entering the party
yeah um and by the way Bishop G6 is on
the board right now Bishop G6 is the
move he chose here hitting the queen of
course as we talked about before is the
tempo right it's very I was working with
a coach before
um a grand master coach rushed to it was
very strong he was he was like yeah I'm
a big fan and I believe in the tempo and
so a lot of times when you are lost in
positions or positions that are sharp
like this who really try to look for
that Tempo or Tempe multiple moves that
are tempo right so with Tempo with Tempo
Bishop G6 nice Knight F6 was Tempo but
Queen F6 counter tempos I'm hitting B2
I'm also hitting D1 right everything is
looking bad for White's position
yeah I'm not even sure what uh White can
do you can bring your queen somewhere in
the a file but this Knight joins the
party then goes to D3 or to E4 I just
feel like all of Black's pieces are
taking part and white is simply playing
without the right side of the board and
yeah I love the look of Knight C5 the E5
Bishop is already defended by this rook
and the queen so just go for the attack
just don't stop there's also Knight B3 I
wasn't even looking in that direction oh
man I forgot about that one
I was like oh yeah they see 593 then you
forgot I mean you just forget that yeah
when you have this many options you even
forget that the fork is there it's gonna
be a bad day in the office boys and
everything's like that Tangled down I
mean your development is not there
everything in Black's position right if
you think about just chess principles is
great my pieces are out my king is safe
I have no weaknesses it doesn't even
feel like I'm down a pawn but I am down
upon is black here and that that pawn
means nothing it's supposed to Knight C5
and we live oh my goodness this is yeah
few moves Robert this is a blowout I
mean this is really it's a one-sided
Affair a great play by Mustafa ilmaz who
never was afraid and just kept pushing
forward and so yikes okay there's got to
be a knockout here somewhere Knight E4
hitting the Rook ending this is rookie
two the best move please tell me that's
not the best move
because that would be so sad you're just
locking in your king side you know it's
like you're never gonna develop right
Rook e to yikes
um
C2 takes and queen F2 I mean bro
gonna come in too man like everything is
a problem right like you just can't stop
the vicious attacks left right and
Center so I think we trust mustafael Maz
here he is just in charge in this game
and that's great news for the Bulldogs
because if we look in the bottom left
that's the Emo's game he's uh winning in
the bottom right it looks like Bogdan
Daniel deach against Josephine heinemann
she beat Hikaru Nakamura but uh day out
just saying not me not today and the top
left though it looks like it's going
from bad to worse for alien Roberts she
had a good start you know it was a solid
opening but it looks like Matthias
bluebound is about to take home this
game he's just much more active so let's
tune into this one we'll get into the
heinemann dash game soon but James I
mean look at this activity for black all
the pieces and good squares yeah of
course the bad thing about you know the
French is uh is rougher black in the
beginning but middle games I find and in
games are actually a little bit games
are very tactical and then the end games
become like very good for black if you
are not you know if you haven't if you
are able to meet white you know I mean
or sorry if white isn't able to mate you
know the French player then these
in-games actually definitely favor you
know black here so that's the problem
she just was not able to mate which is
understandable lots of pieces came off
no weaknesses really for black I mean
everything's hitting F2 and uh you're
also playing a 2650 GM here who is can
play really anything it's pretty tough
and that Bishop is one of the worst
pieces this light Square Bishop just
completely dominated has no activity
whatsoever it's doing a defensive job uh
but the last move Rook F1 protecting
this Pawn on F2 I mean Knight E5 looks
very good there's already a tactic where
you can take this Pawn on H4 in some
positions because of fork and F3 but
just bring all your pieces to the party
White's pieces are passive not helping
out I mean this is a few moves away from
being one for black I imagine and we
have a result by the way uh Mustafa
yamas did in fact win that game against
Michael Bizzle so uh a win for the
Croatia Bulldogs they're off to a good
start nice nice for the Bulldogs here
and it's going to bounce right back if
blue bomb is able to uh to just clean
this up here and then uh you know beers
would be there as well let's see what
the chat says who you got chassis go
bears bears who do we have are you for
the Bears or are you for the Bulldogs
who are you pledging Your Allegiance to
put it in the chat put it in the chat
energy everywhere so yeah this is just
kind of over here obviously 95 but
what's the follow-up as you see he's
thinking 95 yeah like you said Queen C3
just take on H4 no but no that's a
hanging if I was hanging so
I actually I made the same blender I
just didn't say it out loud so I'm gonna
show it I'm gonna show it just because
I'm gonna be honest with James he went
H5 uh but if we can bring up analysis
board Knight E5 here if Queen G3 Queen
6h4 would be good if white takes the
queen because of the Knight Fork on F3
but unfortunately for black queen 65 is
check to this King so I was making the
same mistake I'm gonna be honest about
it but it said we see some quick moves
uh where white trying to push forward
against the black king but uh I think
black can even push this Pawn forward to
G5 there's no attack the king is
perfectly safe and white pawns are all
over the place and targeted so I do
think that this should be good for blue
Bauman I just want to point out while
this game uh is nearing its conclusion
uh Bogdan Daniel dayaj is just he's in
mop-up Duty uh over there in the bottom
right like he just played a great series
of moves to take the upper hand because
things didn't look so bad if we hop into
that one in this position things didn't
look so bad for white but bam Knight
takes Beats to happen and after the Kink
takes Queen takes T3 check and then
Queen B4 and that's the problem is black
took two pawns for his Knight and
Josephine she's losing her Knight on F4
so that's exactly what happened and the
queen it's not trapped it has one safe
Square on that five and that score is
good enough
wow and that is that was just a cleanup
right here make sure you're hitting your
tactinos Chad for breakfast lunch and
dinner oh my goodness that was some
puzzle Rush Knight B2 Queen C3 Queen B4
over to an Emmy I'm just completely
winning in any format this is definitely
just completely winning the bishop looks
terrible on B3 it's only a defensive
piece at this point Knight versus Bishop
we King I'm winning everywhere in this
game beautiful from Day Out yes and by
the way Matthias Bloom did win that game
for the Bears so the match is even at
the moment and for day out here the
Queen's under attack you can safely
slide to Asia it is running out of
squares uh but white doesn't have enough
pieces to go trap it like you need to
somehow bring a rook all the way over
there uh it takes way too long I mean
you know maybe if it's OTB chest you can
like try it and like get in a legal move
but this is uh and you when you drag the
piece it does not go there so it's just
not going to work here try again right
all right that's actually really funny
right you know someone leaves the board
OTP and then you have to try to be slick
with it but I think I think you know he
might even play this move Rook takes
Bishop dragging the queen away and then
taking this Pawn on F3 and saying I have
three pawns and a wonderful knight uh
against your Rook plus Black's King is
very safe and White's King Isn't So Rook
takes C2 feels like that super GM move I
definitely felt Rook C2 as well and then
take on F3 and then put I mean I could
plant a knight of F5 how do you even
break through on the king side like you
never can do that right and he goes
forever look at that just picking up
more material the Knight is so strong on
F5 I pick up H4 I have a pass H Pawn G5
can hang everything five is gonna hang
and then you know it's just gonna be a
problem and I have so many pawns for
this exchange it's insane yeah three
Pawns in a night is already more than a
rook and then all the control is in
Black's favor so a great position for
books on Daniel day out but Josephine
heinemann she was losing against ikar
Nakamura before turning that game around
so maybe she can have magic happen a
second week in a row all right that's
true in fact yeah Hikaru was just
winning and then we looked up and he
lost he was like what happened and
Hikaru is only half human as you see
here wow that's crazy right so half
human came out in that game and
Josephine was able to to uh close it in
this one this one's gonna be hard it's
definitely difficult but it means it's
possible yeah it does have a minute and
30 here I'm around a minute or 30. I do
have an exchange it's not a lot of good
prospects but hey there is hope so yeah
there was a draw between Dimitri colors
and uh bardia de nesvar no surprises
there that game had looked level ever
since uh after the opening so Queen G3
by bogdon Dental I feel like four
Josephine the only way she can survive
this game is if somehow her Rooks just
start attacking some of these black
pawns because Black's job is simple like
Knight F5 Rook CH improve your pieces
one by one and these pawns are going to
fall so I feel like Justin somehow needs
to attack something I just don't know
what it is yeah the problem is even I
mean like how do I even get you know
works like open files we go okay cool
you got the file like oh but then it
gets blocked right and you want to get
the queen F6 ideally what you want is a
rook on C7 like you mentioned and the
other one on D7 or B7 and then get the
queen over to F6 and we actually have
some real good play problem is black
gets a lot of moves too so if we cannot
get the Rooks to the seventh and the
queen of F6 we just really don't have
anything there now there is there is
hope though we could try Rook C1 try to
get this Rook to C7 just one step up at
a time but then what do we do with the D
Rook how long is that going to take and
if you play rookie before that's going
to take forever like to get this Rook to
the B file and she's going for it though
and then V6 B6 Rook C1 and like maybe
Rook C7 trying and hoping for the best
yeah and it might cost her another Pawn
maybe it's the H Pawn but at this point
three extra pawns for black with the
Knight versus The Rook so another fourth
Pawn that's not really gonna be the
Difference Maker I think white
desperately needs some activity and you
see bugged on Daniel day out he's one of
these players he wants to be correct
also what's in his background Jane what
am I looking at behind him over there
you know it looks like everything's
tilted like everything's like on a slant
like it looks like his book show he got
so many books on it that it start
weighing down to the left a little bit
so he just didn't get it fixed because
he's been reading so many chess books
back there Chad that's what it looked
like there yep I think he's also got
like a plush pillow or something like
that behind him on the other side so you
know what wow look at that right oh man
that's a
Bulldogs I'm like yeah and then the
check
yeah he is repping well for the Bulldogs
and he's like wanting to give the
Bulldogs a lead after round one Rook C8
bring another piece into the the game
that's Rook on before tied down to this
Pawn if you play Rook C1 you think oh I
have a rook compared to a knight I
should be better no we just trade bring
this Knight to C6 take this Pawn on E5
four pawns and the Knight is too much
for a rook so uh yeah he's just in
charge right now yeah there's nothing we
can really do even if you go Rook B3 and
then the queen takes H4 Rick C1 we trade
and play Queen C3 dropping The Rook here
everything's losing you don't even have
a real good move here real D3 I mean you
could try that one yeah there it is
working through yeah so the only thing
we can try maybe D1 now let's go back
you want to draw bro awesome
I'm gonna show that real quick because
this queen only had the C5 Square so
there was uh there's nowhere to go in
this one besides G3 and C5 but if you go
back to G3 uh instead then you go Rook
D3 and again only safe square is G1 so
it's really no choice for Deus he goes
to C5 and now he's bringing his Knight
in and this is a nightmare for white a
nightmare chat as you get that as you
catch that one right that's with a K by
the way nightmare yep and this is
definitely a nightmare for for white
here a very very tough game to start but
you are playing you know another 2700
here it's always a pleasure to be able
to do that but it definitely was a
tactical blunder early on in the game to
get this position the ox just went he's
spinning soon
he was a flag bro hold on he is an
extremely good Blitz and bullet player
so I'm not too concerned but it is a
little bit strange to see him dip that
low on the clock when so many moves look
good for black well you know what when
the time gets low here this is what
happened last time now it wasn't a time
thing for ikaro I think it was just like
just literally a blunder but you blunder
in time pressure and there is time
pressure and there can be some type of
blunder here we go look at that she
doesn't work what's happening
unfortunately she's dropping E5 with
Check Yes and then yeah you can push
that h-pawn if you want just don't allow
this Rook somehow to get up here and
help for a Checkmate right I mean
imagine that happening maybe uh
all over the Internet chat yeah this is
over no tricks not even one no and it's
not even a Scale Matrix geez I mean 94
then you could take this Pawn too leave
no pawns on the board that's bully chess
no pawns Left Behind Chad leave no pawns
behind this is really insane I mean look
at
look at that like I'm up so many pawns
you don't see this every day they sure
have this many pawns just domination
is he gonna take this one how many extra
deposites five come on man why are you
doing this man six extra pawns and
there's a night okay this also does the
trick I would say a night Fork but
Checkmate is better than winning a rook
with Queen D2 mate so good game there by
Bogue Don Daniel for Josephine heinemann
you know ever since that Knight takes B2
shot way back when she didn't really
have the best chance so a good game
between those two and it's a lead for
the Bulldogs so James the Bulldogs win
on board for their boards one and two
down the bottom there with the black
pieces and the Berlin Bears could only
get one and a half out of two from their
top boards you know usually a bear
versus a bulldog right that's just not a
question the bear would just eat up that
dog in any way but these are the
strongest Bulldogs I ever seen in my
life it's like a hundred of them against
one bear so that's what's going on right
now and the Bulldogs definitely came out
with the early lead right now we gotta
get that X-ray done because they got
that dog in them they are up two and a
half one and a half the Croatia Bulldogs
lead the Berlin Bears round two of this
match will be here in just a few minutes
so James and I are gonna step aside take
a short break and then return to the
action don't go anywhere you don't want
to miss any action from the protest
League
I do like positional styled games I may
try to keep it positional but I I I can
also uh change gears and I think that's
very important in terms of uh you know
anyone trying to develop their chess
game
um if you do find you know style of play
that you enjoy that's good but you could
also try to sharpen it by implementing
you know on another form of uh into your
bag as we would call it right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
on screen in front of us yawning a bit
but not tired of winning chess games he
is the board one for the Berlin Bears he
won in that first round of action and
James he's one of the best Grandmasters
in Germany has been a star for them
playing on their Olympia team and he's
also the reigning European chess
champion that's a huge accomplishment
absolutely I mean number two German
female rated player there's a lot of
strong Germans uh Robert you know okay
there's a lot of them he's number two
right reigning European individual chess
champion and look at the accules there
2022 Fisher random right that's chess
960 Championship qualifier right making
the 2023 PCL debut the man is very very
strongly
yes he is and he was one of this quartet
of young German players who was called
The Prince of Chess and then all four of
them became Grand Masters and now
they're known as the Kings so uh it's
great to see that camaraderie on the
German Squad the Berlin Bears will need
him because currently they are down by a
point so he got the job done in round
one the rest of the squad not quite uh
upholding his standards here at Dimitri
kolars he had a draw with the black
pieces can't really blame him against
bardia dineshvar who's 2500 and Rising
but James those top two boards for the
Bulldogs they're hungry and they're
biting yeah so they're hungry and
they're biting and they're very very
strong correspond just with ease of
course has showed some class there exact
in exchange of every Pawn on the board I
mean it was really a nasty dude
I always do that to him Mustafa is so
strong of course as you know even the
name you can mix it up and the man is
very very dangerous right but he plays
very good chess he's also very attacking
good attacking player King's Indian and
Etc things like that I think the Bears
definitely uh have the word cut out for
them they have a lot of work to do here
and this is a very strong team here but
anything is doable and again it's about
who's uh really good at that moment for
sure and it's a new round which means
there are new pairings and we will see
different matchups and that actually is
good news usually for the board fours
because they already played the toughest
opponent on the other team and as we
look at these matchups blue Baum and
kolars for the Berlin Bears they get the
white pieces against bardia dineshvar
and Aline robers respectively and then
we see that for the Bulldogs they get
their top two boards with the white
pieces both on Daniel Day Arch and
Mustafa take on Michael bezold and
Josephine heinemann so James
right now the crochet Bulldogs up a
point but who do you give the edge to in
round two when you look at these
matchups oh definitely the Bears of
course as you see uh the uh we have blue
bomb and collars there with white pieces
against the lower rated boards there I
mean you just have to give the advantage
there they have the first move Advantage
they're very strong Grand Masters here
it looks like now obviously that's on
paper it looks like well the Bears have
a slight Advantage here
okay you heard from James he thinks the
Bears can't strike back and maybe even
up this match uh we'll have to let the
players chest do the talking because we
are going to start with the top board
the games are staggered uh Blue Bell he
will get the white pieces in this round
he's coming off a victory so the Bears
they'll need him to succeed once again
and help lead them to an overall match
Victory but first they got to tie these
this thing up and bardia dineshfar with
the black pieces he's not gonna go down
without a fight he's not somebody who's
just going to be a pushover he played
for the Iranian team in the Olympiad he
has some very good results and I think
James we often think of youngsters as
being tactical Wizards he is good in
tactics when they arise but he's also
like a very positional player those are
very tough those are very tough to face
here especially for a tactical Wizards
that love tactics and you're like ah I'm
gonna play very positional you don't you
don't understand what's going on yet
right just a little small
um positional against you see that in
carp off here and stuff like that right
very small positional gains and then
I'll beat you later but that the tactics
arise I'll see them and it's hard to
play those kind of players like that as
we see right here this is sort of a
double thin Kettle where you can just
like be very flexible lots of options
you haven't really told your hand yet I
like the choice
yeah it's one of these openings where
black kind of is bobbing and weaving you
know at first the bishop opened up to
this diagonal and then when the a-pawn
took away this Advanced squares ah just
kidding let me go to G7 so I feel like
for black you often want to strike with
E5 but James we kind of have a London
system but it's a more advanced London
with upon a C4 rather than C3 and the
Knight on C3 rather than on D2 uh so for
black we'll likely see Knight D7 Queen
E7 E5 kind of stuff but white is very
active and solid here as well absolutely
a very yeah very very solid so far 94
that definitely is a nice choice there
you see this in the Queen's Indian type
setups here but a queen's Indian now
with a bishop on G7 so lots of
flexibility sort of not Hedgehog like
but almost and you can play moves like
C5 or F5 D5 E5 like lots of Pawn breaks
and lots of flexibility which gives
black so many options here to to kind of
just uh you know react off of what light
does here which is going to put a
definitely a matiz blue bomb in a very
very um difficult position if he's
looking for winning chances here yeah I
think black has some kind of obvious
moves like a five in addition to those
four Pawn pushes you mentioned just to
try to stop B4 and if these Knights get
swapped then A4 is often a very useful
move for black to play so I actually
would already take this Knight on C3 and
if Queen takes I probably play A5 and
then maybe C5 I don't know which Pawn to
push James you were right all of them
look like good options yeah everything
uh A5 B5 everything five C5 D5 E5 all of
these fives all of these pawns can go to
the fifth right talk about options right
but of course it is Black's move and you
do need to make an option I actually
like the F5 move no F5 then there's
Knight takes
Bishop takes
I mean I like F5 though
yeah you're saying I don't you don't
want to release the tension until you
feel like it benefits you so F5 keeps
the knights secondary one I like knight
uh takes C3 I like F5
um those are and well he chooses your
line so James you know you're flexing on
them yeah of course it's a sometimes I
can't help I'm a Jedi so it's just most
times it just happens to the way of the
Jedi but after F5 there it's a very good
move I like it of course we just give
space and we can maybe open the f file
maybe open file it's a big maybe of
course because Bishop's gonna be bad but
it's possible it's just flexibility
again the option I think this F5 move is
nice and definitely questions who uh
blue ball and set up here yeah well
while uh blue bump tries to figure out
what to do let's go to our bird's eye
view because I think we're about to see
something very strange look at the top
right that's a black king on d8 Elaine
robbers has her King where the queen
started and
all these pawns are gone so let's dive
right into that game because I'm
confused I don't even know exactly what
opening came from looks like a sicilian
of some sort where now black has a
second C Pawn so wow James I think we
have to start from the beginning here
just show everybody yeah how kolars and
Rovers enter this position so we'll take
a look so it was a sicilian okay and we
see
Knight F6 aha one of these you know
white plays E5 and there's no Queen A5
check so this allows white to push this
pawn and this is like very popular these
days James and I just find these too
crazy for me yeah this is in fact yeah
I'm a big fan of crazy here and but
black actually is very nice in these
games is what I've seen now white is too
but these games just become very very
Wicked you don't know what's going on is
black okay yes he is okay but then you
know white actually has good prospects
due to the open position and The
Bishop's already being out but black has
a very nice Center I mean he got all the
Pawns in the center it looks like when
we don't really have any but it's King
is unsafe like there's like yeah but he
has this yeah but I got this but I got
this but like it's literally going back
and forth right and as you see as the
engine just gives only a slight
Advantage uh to White here which is a
lot of lot to say a lot about this
position
but for Aline her prep better be really
good because I feel like well yes she
has these good Pawns in the center and
we've got three pawns here and a fourth
I mean it's all just like helping the
king uh be shielded I just feel like you
know you make a careless move like a
king C7 too quick and then maybe this
queen drops into F7 and Bishop B7 was
played you see the eval bar saying oh
not a fan of that and you got to watch
out you could lose your queen at any
moment because the queen on H5 also
protects this Square so I feel like
white should very quickly try to Castle
queenside who cares with this B2 Pawn I
want you to take that pawn just like
Aline wanted that in game one open up
this file later in the game actually
absolutely I was definitely thinking
that Bishop D2 the bishop A5 idea I mean
again it's the tempo we talked about
this before we asked exactly was played
Bishop D2 so you go Bishop A5 and then
you deal with Bishop A5 then the castle
Queen side put a rook on the open D file
then move the Bishops next and literally
your king is right there Bishop C3
another Tempo hits F6 I'm also hitting
h8 there right it's gonna be problematic
opens up the bishop then I can go Bishop
F5 and then Bishop takes E6 it's just
too many things here there's a lot of
stuff going on even F5 there is that the
right point if you try to play D5 or
something like that so there's lots of
things that can happen white it's
definitely looking good here
I think white already might be winning
like I look at this position I see the
eval bar saying all right plus nearly
two I don't care I just don't think that
black really has a chance in a rapid
game it just feels like you have no
development C5 played okay cut off the
queen so Bishop A5 no longer available
but Castle's Queen side and all of
James's ideas Bishop C3 Queen F7 F5 you
name it it's available and I just feel
like black is just no play of her own
absolutely this is a very very tough
position for her to play here I mean of
course you are about facing Dimitri
kolars here and you're giving him a good
position I mean Bishops here is is
difficult there it is yeah the castle
Queen side is just playing very accurate
and very good here for for the Bears
and you said it you said you felt that
the Bears would have a good round and
they're off to a great start so let's
zoom out of this one as we see Dimitri
colors with the upper hand uh we'll look
across the four boards I would say the
top left well not much has changed we
started off there seems like a solid
start for bardeen as far with the black
pieces in the bottom left not a single
Pawn has been traded between both and
Michael bezold's early uh for in that
one and in the bottom right mustafael
Maz going right after Josephine
heinemann's D6 Pawn so James I feel like
that bottom right position that's one of
those that could be very dangerous for
the Bears yeah of course as fast oh D5
too just play D5 that's not that's about
to get spicy over there in fact
yeah spicy that one certainly is going
to get spicy and the top left C5 was
just played by Matthias bluebound so
that one is spicing up as well so let's
uh maybe go to our uh board one for the
Bears we'll go back to that game uh just
because I see this situation stabilized
for Josephine at the moment but James
what do you make of this last move C5
for blue bombs
and after Pawn takes takes back the B
Pawn of course can't capture it the
bishop is loose behind it I have the
queen captures he's just trying to take
this E6 Pawn with check all right oh
wait that's some sharp stuff that's
definitely going to be annoying you also
have even some Rook C1 Rook C7 in there
like but there's a man there's all kinds
of stuff yeah Queen E6 first so then
Rooks you want C7 oh wait there here
come the tactics here and that F5
definitely looked like it worked out but
then now you start seeing these King
weaknesses but I do have a strong
business I got two strong Bishops so I
think it's still Level yeah engine says
level yeah I can understand it being
still Level it's dynamically equal right
yeah my King's weak but I got the
Bishops pointing and maybe if I can even
play G5 G4 like we have almost some
Kings indian-esque type positions here
King h a put the Rook on the G file
Bishop F6 G5 G4 and try to go for me
even myself
um for for black here because that
Bishop on B7 is an absolute monster we
may have to neutralize it with Bishop F3
or something
yeah I think white at some point will
look to trade off those pieces just
because it is staring down towards the
white king and I think that for now
bardia should play Knight to D7 we can
we see the pawn and you can't capture it
bring your knight out develop and then
threaten the pawn and you should want to
get your knight to C5 it's a nice active
Square kick that Queen out here we can
play G5 later I don't think we're in a
rush to do that so I really like the
look of Knight D7 a calm move a
developing move uh for black and
actually moves haven't played King H7
Rook C1 and E5 so striking in the center
and then now bring the Knight out to A6
rather than to D7 but James as the
bishop is kicked back here a pawn and
trenched on C6 do you like this
development for white or for black oh
that's a good question here in fact
after this you know what oh man this is
tough let me think about this
strangely enough I like black a little
bit more because I know the plan of this
F4 I just feel like we can get something
going with F4 and G5 G4 but then again I
don't like this 90 A6 so kind of level
okay now but he brought the Knight back
so yeah I'm definitely liking black here
a little bit 96 to G5
mm-hmm
I see James I I know your style you're
looking for the attack and I'm with you
and black at some point can lash out
with A5 if you play B5 you may drop this
Pawn on A3 so you have to be careful
about that and so it's not like this
black Bishop on C8 it's not gonna stay
there forever The Rook N8 won't be here
forever but Knight G5 does look like
it's next maybe there's an F4 F3 things
like that and black can go in the attack
yeah this is definitely looking attack
like you can see I mean the bishop on A2
this is like if the pawn wasn't on C6
then I probably would take white but
like the pawn on C6 actually
I don't have anything I mean okay it's a
good Pawn it's a great Pawn in fact it's
passed right I mean it could be passed
C7 could be we can put something on D7
but that is not possible right now that
is not possible we're trying though he's
doing a nice C4 and maybe we move the
Knight again to G5
because he is attacking this Pawn now
right the E5 Pawn is under attack and
yeah it does seem like white is the one
who is getting the initiative all of a
sudden so allowing this Pawn up to C6 it
did Force the bishop back and now black
feels a little bit more passive and well
I mean this one is about balance maybe
slightly better for Matthias bluebound
but other games have bigger swings so
let's go back to our four board scene
because look at this in the top right
it's still all Dimitri colors not too
much has changed there uh the Bears bore
two is in charge and playing good moves
but the bottom right that's where I
think the biggest swing has happened and
I think we can understand why because
Josephine heinemann she is trying to
defend this position against Mustafa IL
Maz but his the last couple moves if we
just scroll back
this C7 square has been the problem so
in H6 we saw a swap and after Queen
takes I believe she was likely thinking
okay we'll trade and then the Knight
will protect D5 but said Knight C7 first
double my pawns have fun with that
because at the end of the day you see
Knight takes D5 Pawn takes and a pawn is
hanging but don't take it that is a
trick if you take the pawn nope she
already uh he already moved but you take
the pawn she would have had Bishop takes
F2 check ideas uh in these positions
yeah it's very strong time make sure you
do your tactics daily because even these
small tactics like here will come up in
your own games especially as the time
you slower too as well and you just oh
and you lose right immediately it's not
not good you don't have any fun there
problematic so but I like this uh this
idea of what he played uh with Bishop H3
and now Rook the ace so now that we just
snapped upon
just snap the pawn now and then take and
well
no you can't take the file so let's play
E3 and then the very nice uh Pawn flanks
with only the F2 Pawn being weak in that
structure that's usually how you deal
with it when you have the double Pawn so
a very nice stable I'm up a pot
yeah I do think that this is a great
moment for Mustafa yamas who won the
first game and so the board two for the
Croatia Bulldogs I mean he is showing
that he is a good addition to this
lineup and I think you can just trade as
you were saying The Rook takes back and
the push upon to E3 and there's no
infiltration because the Knight covers
this very important D2 Square so white
up a pawn opposite doesn't necessarily
mean it's going to be a draw and okay
musawa does not want to give up this
open file so brings The Rook back D1 and
keeps the advantage I think that this is
uh was a nice tactical uh sequence for
Mustafa absolutely he's just looking to
convert the extra Pawn I'm up an extra
Pawn yes it's double but it's still an
extra pawn and we can use it for of
course a reserve 10 piece with
devareskis calls it and you can use the
reserve Tempe later on due to having
this extra Pawn even though it's double
yeah and I think what black really needs
to accomplish is to trade the knights if
these Knights come off the board drawing
chances increase the reason why is pure
opposite colored Bishops but let's say
this Knight gets to E5 and then I put
this bishop on B3 with a knight the
opposite colored Bishops it's actually
gives attacking chances because harder
to defend certain squares like F7 so
black really really really wants to
trade off the knights that's what I'd be
aiming for if I were Josephine just I
don't see how you accomplish that yeah
and that night is very strong at F3 you
can also go to E5 at some point I have a
rock solid structure I can go E3 King F1
King E2 almost on pre-move
um of course don't pre-move but it
definitely this is just an easy plan to
pre-move here put the king closer to the
center put the nut on E5 swap the Rooks
and then maybe reroute the bishop again
over to uh to the a2ga diagonal
okay she goes Knight D5 going after the
pawn E3 automatic as you were suggesting
uh there are some Knight takes E3
tactics maybe that's what she's going
for oh this is probably why he should
have traded that boy Rook d8 right E3
hold on big fella yeah
you really have to calculate this I'll
bring analysis board very quickly just
to show how you can go wrong for white
E3 is still a good move and was played
but after Knight takes E3 you may think
let me swap Rooks and then I'm gonna get
two pieces for a rook I'm gonna take
this bishop on C5 uh but black isn't
going to take back because you take back
you'll see the advantage for white after
Pawn takes Knight but you have to watch
out for your own King Rook D1 is not
just check it's mate because that Knight
covers G2 so instead after this sequence
I believe white throws new bam B4 gets
your Bishop out of here so that when
your Bishop moves it has to react to
this capture I take your knight and now
you don't have Bishop takes E3 winning
my Rook on C1 so uh Mustafa has worked
this all out Josephine says yep I
acknowledge it you got this under
control and the Knight does come to B4
and all right James still chances for uh
for black but it's not looking good so
let's uh head on out of here and go to
the bird's eye view because oh gosh look
at the top right there it looks
he's just cruising wow I mean it looks
like the yeah the eval bar is like part
is like a that's like decoration there
on the side it's just all white up there
so that the eval bar is literally
completely winning 100 and then who's
moving here is actually his move so
what's the move okay what do we have um
single move is necessary James like
what's Black's next move let's ask that
question what would you do next if you
had a free move for black
[Laughter]
your king because your Bishop is loose
your Bishop has nowhere good to go
Bishop D6 doesn't
exactly look appealing and
oh F5
yeah F5 and then E5
yes look at the P look at that Bishop is
it a bishop that's the ultimate question
here it doesn't look like much of a
bishop and can white just throw this
Pawn off the board let's make a new
Queen I was just thinking that H4 and
just run it up I mean like you said
there's no moves like so you just run
the H Pawn wow what a positional
domination right E5 and H4 and then you
just stare into the zoom camera like you
know
what you gonna do next like literally
what do you do next oh my goodness I
really see nothing in G4 oh man this is
disrespectful bro G4 and lean back
the second lean back uh reference in a
row James if the last time we were
talking about it we had we were hitting
the Rockaway so that's right that's
right
[Laughter]
and rocking away so and that's exactly
what's going on right here this G4 move
is just Total Domination black has to
make moves like A5 Rook C8 right Queen
C7 all of these movies don't do anything
at all there's no plan to it in fact wow
I mean there's so many people the reason
why it's such a fascinating position is
there's so many pieces on the board for
this to be domination like this queen G7
and just chill
The Rook would love to slide up but you
lose your Bishop on G8 so after Queen G7
you still can't bring your king out the
bishop is loose here there's just no
moves in this position for black it's
one of the uh sadder positions to see so
I I do think that Elaine Rober is you
know a tough
start to this match she is playing the
top two boards for the Berlin bears but
the Berlin Bears need all of these games
they enter the round down by a full
point and as we look across their four
boards uh look at the bottom left for
the Berlin Bears we haven't even looked
at this game but Michael bezold he is up
nearly five minutes on the clock and
James I don't think I've seen Knights
this good in a while though these
Knights having a good time Casey Karu
calls him D's nice look at those Knights
on C5 and B4 for the score looking great
I mean locking down the queen side B3 is
weak wife's pieces are conjunct I mean
they're actually like nicely uh
chemistry is is just the word for all
the pieces are nicely arranged for white
but they're not really doing a lot I
definitely like Black's position here of
course for those nights like a nice ones
C5 and B4 white nice nights too I mean I
do have the F5 Square I can go Knight H2
Bishop G4 trade off the light score
Bishop Knight g493 at some point take
over to F5 Square on completely so I
mean there's some stuff for me but black
has no problems
and Rook B2 is a sad move to play
especially in time travel the B3 Pawn is
one you keep an eye on and it's H5 Pawn
James if we get to an end game then that
pawn is maybe a gunner so you have to be
very very careful if you are bugged on
Daniel Daya let's think about improving
moves here I like Queen d8 uh there may
be an exchange sack at the right moment
if there's a Checkmate on the horizon
your knight one of them can get to D3 I
just feel like it's hard for white to
make any plan Knight H2 I like your
choice try to go over Bishop G4 but I'm
worried that a rook will slam down on D3
as soon as the bishop moves that's
exactly right yeah that's the only only
problem that's why uh well Queen day was
so nice there I mean he definitely just
covered that whole idea is like not
there anymore I wanted to go Knight H2
Bishop G4 but I mean as soon as the D3
Square opens up he's gonna put a piece
there so we have to shuffle around make
some other moves and try to figure out
how we can actually do something I mean
worst place pieces with Jacob Agar says
in his positional Playbook the queen on
E3 is gross like what do we do with this
queen I mean where do you put it that is
just not in in something it's just not
looking good for that Queen so we gotta
figure out what we want to do with that
I mean practically speaking black
definitely has some very good chances
every piece is good maybe the bishop and
see it could be improved but don't
blunder with Bishop G4 because Knight
takes G5 is check and the Bishops would
have a stare down so that's the one move
you really really would like to avoid is
that kind of mistake because that turns
the game completely so I'm looking at
this position maybe Knight C2 but I
don't really want to trade Knights
necessarily when I have more space I
like keeping more peace on the board
because white pieces as you said they're
looking like they're in good squares but
they're not really doing all that much
so I kind of I think if I'm black I want
to pass the turn just making all that
Bishop E6 and say your move what you
gonna do about it that's right Bishop V6
and he put nice C2 maybe he's going for
this Knight D4 idea which again like you
mentioned I mean I'd be happy to trade
those nights like man it's just one of
those nice gotta go one of them gotta go
I don't care which one you want but
one's got to go but he did not take it I
guess because he didn't want to pass on
coming through taking it's gonna be
Tempo and D3 so 210p back to back not
looking good there so he chose Queen E3
totally understandable 16 seconds too if
he rocked that clock boy like you gotta
watch the clock brother yeah that's the
thing right if I'm Michael bazo I'm
trying to play uh to get my opponent to
flag make a move like Bishop E6 don't
give him any clear plans and I think
that he has a good chance but let's go
back to our bird's eye view just because
some of the other games are nearing
their conclusion we see in the top right
James it went from bad to worst to maybe
the worst position you could possibly
see for black uh none of her pieces are
active so Dimitri colors in control but
the top left we see bardia dineshwar in
time trouble
um against Matthias bluebound and that
one is actually quite crazy like that
Eva bar is still in the center but it's
anyone's game wow whoa bar in the center
yeah this is why you know you take that
with a grain of salt boy look at this
position right now first off King safety
and non-existent for both sides it look
like I mean okay okay black it
definitely has the pieces around the
king white has some around there but
there's no pieces around white king so
there are not a lot of pieces uh you
know not a lot of uh shelter for white
skin to say the least here but there's
no open lines for the Bishops 18 seconds
about that per side like Queen comes
back to E7 you're talking about the
shelter let's keep that King safe but
what's going on now the bar is dropping
what happened shoot distribution five it
wasn't it but I wonder what it was maybe
just bring this queen out like black
suddenly is on the offensive
oh especially in this time control here
Chad this is now a like 30 second game
under 30 seconds under 30 seconds Bishop
8-2 the queen is under attack Queen's
gotta go four seconds for black you
gotta move where you going come on we
made it with two seconds Queenie four
hits to Bishop Bishop B3 oh wait Bishop
B3 is there some kind of like take on D1
because
the Knight is loose oh what do you do
you got to take on d8 then all right I
don't know he's got three seconds Gotta
Move he's got to take on d8 he does it
mean three oh man so quick three two
queen Z4 he's out of the way uh-huh oh
but watch out the E3 Pawn is loose James
so he goes back to E4
oh my goodness give me yeah
take this one take that one take ever
take this one it protects the Knight as
well Queen takes H5 will he spotted four
seconds Knight to D6
that's a good movie that was a good move
yeah and he's gonna take this Pawn I
think unless there's no checks
and bloop out he's like us he couldn't
even see that coming oh oh man
it's not there's not a single check and
he resigns that was sick by bardia
dineshfar wow look he just got up and
walked away he dropped the mic drop oh
my God
some water oh man
and blue bomb is beside himself and for
the Croatia Bulldogs that was an
important win for bardia dinesha's game
still going the top right game is over
Dimitri kolars want it uh we see in the
bottom left Michael bazold is now in
trouble he had a big Advantage he had
all the control now he's in trouble but
Josephine heinemann in the bottom right
she still is trying to survive that end
game so let's go back to Bezos and
bogdon Daniel they are somehow a pass
b-pawn appeared for the 2700 super GM
but black has a past one of his own yeah
of course this is just he just got 2 700
you know even though that's uh we made
that that uh that just now but he I mean
definitely black was doing great his
timing the time like he had no time they
uh I mean literally you know a bezel was
up five minutes on the clock you know
what I mean so he just got 2700 here and
it happens it's like stuff but okay we
still got some some play here though
it's not over
yeah he can win his beat Pawn but he's
gonna lose the C4 pawn and the king is
in some trouble right once this white
Rook lands on C7 the king is forced to
the last rank so he's going in with this
Rook to C7 he can pick up this a pawn if
he wants he can bring his Bishop out to
B5 but maybe this isn't the cleanest
game it's not that easy to win though
Black's pawns are probably going to fall
yeah Box Pawn is definitely looking to
fall there that was a beautiful move
this should be five just trying to like
hey limit your Rook activity there maybe
Rook to D6 Rook H7 and then what do we
do like we gotta get our Knight in the
game somehow I understand but like where
are we going next nice C3 oh Knight C3
this is nasty
oh James I wasn't even looking in that
direction okay let me go over here and
all that stuff with Knight C3 just get
this it is there it is and and now we
have ourselves Rick before wait that's
Tempo whatever is that rig B4
we also could almost get Anastasia's
mate if you look out for it but oh watch
out for this H Pawn though you gotta be
careful Rook G6
you are right about that how do we still
got to go like Rook of B7 there oh it's
two people losing oh he can't go rookie
six
well I know he can he can I mean not a
rookie six sorry uh Rick B7 we're gonna
be sunny oh yeah that's over hey check
here I'll check first okay King up
what's the deal Chief oh is there gonna
be some mating that you move this rook
and Bishop G8 and Rook H7 mate
look at the time he's doing it in too I
mean he had no time for like so many
moves here Bishop G8 oh my goodness this
is a family channel bro get this off the
Screen Man
get this off the screen bro he's made
with that man
it's white who wins on time in this game
that's great for the Croatia bulldogs
and worst news for the Berlin Bears is
it was a tough end game no matter what
but for Josephine heinemann it's just
over now because the Knight hits this
Pawn if you save your Pawn you lose the
bishop Knights are tricky pieces you
can't take it if you're losing King
opponent in the game so James it looks
like the Berlin Bears they got off to a
good start with Dimitri kolars but the
rest of the team looks like they're
about to lose yeah man I mean it's just
it's pretty tough those Bulldogs are
very very strong I'd bite I mean you
thought a bear was stronger than a
bulldog but not today they definitely
showing you that right now the Bulldogs
are still up in the match and it's not
looking that good for the Bears no I
mean this Knight can just go from the
light squares the dark squares uh maybe
Knight D4 try to Fork on C6 hit
everything in Black positions two extra
pawns for white so as long as he doesn't
flag he's got this under control yes I'm
an easy easy game here and reroute the
Knight over to C6 King D6 King C4 I mean
really anything you can play E5 here E5
and Knight to C6 taking in and then
completely win the game
yeah no that's it worthy Pawn stock
right now you can't even take it because
Knight F3 is a fork so E5 was available
doesn't matter going for this A5 pawn
and that's too much
CJ
like C6 and yeah this is over
oh my goodness yeah okay
give it to me says Mustafa Hamas takes a
bishop and wins this end game so that's
a 3-1 round victory for the Bulldogs
James very surprising given how those
games were going and in particular I
would say Michael bezold losing that
game with the black pieces against
Pokemon Daniel statues up five minutes
on the clock Andy in a better position
yeah he did in fact I thought that was
definitely going Bezos way I mean
everything was going his way the
position looked great and he just you
know he got 2700 it happens there you
have to even even when the 2700s have
low time you they just never give up and
of course he was able to see that
Precision in the end and these three
wins and also that big game by partia
there taking out blue bomb oh man that's
that's tough with the white pieces too
he had whites man that's a big game
yeah that one swung in time trouble but
bardia is in the teenager from Iran he
is proving that he could punch well
above his current rating that 2500 is
there for now he's on his way up to 2600
so uh James I mean it has been all
Bulldogs in this round and the first
round they also won by a score of two
and a half to one and a half so when you
see this five and a half two and a half
you see the top boards for Croatia with
two two and one and a half uh what can
the Berlin bears do to mount a comeback
oh yeah they just got to bring
everything that they have right now I
mean this is very tough you're in
elimination I mean we're obviously uh
you need another loss here but the
elimination is is close like it's
getting closer for for the Bears they
kind of feel that pressure but a lot of
times you can make things happen in
pressure we have seen a 3-1 right back I
mean you never know so there is still
chances left that you have to bring a
best game right now hopefully the
match-ups or hopefully whatever the
pairings are in this next round here um
we'll you know surface well for the
Bears so I have to just see them
yeah they're going to need to get
together fast because this match could
conclude in the next round and these
team events they're super fun we love
them and well if you love team action
there's more in store for you uh because
don't miss round five of the Collegiate
chess League which is tomorrow Saturday
February 25th this season is shaping out
to be incredibly exciting with the best
players in college chess and future
Global Superstars competing for an
oppressive thirty thousand dollar prize
fund head over to twitch.tv Collegiate
chest league for your weekend fix of
Team chess and use the command CCL in
chat to follow this season James I mean
we know how it is in college basketball
and college football don't you love to
see those Collegiate rivalries no
absolutely of course I'm a Collegiate at
College this is like I guess when they
say like oh in the NFL and NBA like
they're just soft right because all of
the calls and stuff like that but in the
college ball you don't hey a lot goes on
in there and a lot to prove right so of
course there's gonna be a lot to prove
here to Collegiate Chesley and in any
chest
start some Saturdays at 11AM just said
there's gonna be fire but I'm excited to
watch
yeah we'll see if we get this kind of
Michigan Ohio State Michigan Michigan
State rivalries uh that is always fun to
see but we have more action here in the
protesting that we will see after this
short break do not go anywhere the
matchup between the Berlin Bears and the
Croatia Bulldogs continues in just a few
minutes
hello and welcome to this video
my name is Christoph zileki I'm an
international master in chess from
Germany and I'm here to share with you
why the opening plays such an important
role in modern chess the opening in
chess is like coming prepared with a
battle plan you play a move but it's
part of a larger strategy you want to
have an idea what to do against every
possible response that your opponent may
play against you want to have a plan a
strategy laid out before the game even
starts this can be really deep on the
top level of 10 20 30. you don't need
that much but you want to be prepared to
get a game that you enjoy playing it's
more fun to play and give you more
chances to win more games I've always
loved studying the opening figuring out
new ideas how to beat my opponents and
set traps this is now my profession
writing courses on openings for
chessable I've created more than a dozen
the most popular ones being of the keep
it Sim simple series I have received an
award this year the author of the year
what I invite you to do is go to
chessable.com and check out how to play
the opening better get fun positions and
win more games
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders it's easy to feel
alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
Katrina luck knows super strong player
but way Yi is Unstoppable in the protest
League welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives oh my gosh that was another
sick tactic by our generic icy he sees
everything
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion wait a second uh-oh is
super unhappy my friends it's the 2023
Pro chess League which team can Rise
Above the Rest they won't be able to do
it alone
and we see Matthias bluebound pondering
what could have been he lost that
critical game against bardia dinestro in
mutual time trouble and that is bad news
for the Berlin Bears because they Trail
by three points it is five and a half
two and a half in favor of the Bulldogs
James this match could be over after the
next round eight and a half points wins
The Crush Bulldogs only need three to
secure match Victory it is very possible
we just gotta see what that lineup looks
like when that lineup comes up and we
see and they like oh I got this color we
got that we don't see this could be over
it definitely could be over here unless
we see these Bears you know come with
way more bite than we've seen in these
first two rounds
for sure and well the Bears they've had
some good performances namely Dimitri
kolars but they have zeros on the bottom
two boards but in this round uh this
stars for their team boards one and two
get the black pieces against the
opposing boards two and one so James the
Berlin Bears need to score at least at
you know a point and a half here to stay
in it but they need more to have a
realistic chance to win the match where
are they gonna get those points yeah the
points may be at the oh man it might be
at the bottom boards there because the
top two it could happen obviously
especially blue bomb wanting to bounce
back he might just be you know all out
you know I'm about to play my best chess
you've ever seen right now because even
though he has to buy pieces here but he
just lost and of course you have to get
over those losses very quickly short
term and re-laws easier said than done
this for the team we know we have to do
this he's the number one guy for their
squad so black pieces I am playing a
lower rated GM but he is still very
strong GM talking about low rated I mean
really what 26 what what 20 how much
Lord really lower right but of course
maybe some low or uh um but bezel may be
looking to win quickly obviously with
the white pieces against Elaine there
who's not having the greatest
um time and then uh WGME Josephine there
is going to try to be bardel Guardia is
very strong after being blue Bombardier
he's like yo I mean I'll just be the top
guy like what else you got for me right
so it's uh it's just gonna be it's a
really really uphill battle for the
Bears
it is indeed and the Matthias bluebound
he still is not over that loss against
bartender that's far you see him shaking
his head off and he just can't believe
what happened to him and his bears but
he will need a good game here because if
he can take down Mustafa ilmaz with the
black pieces suddenly the Bears have a
new lease on life in this match and here
we go the game is starting and Mustafa
he gets the white pieces he's a very
solid and strong player very principal
player he goes for D4 he goes for D4
hits he'll be blue bomb is going to go
with here he likes the French setups but
also E6 and he plays D5 like classical
see what we have C4 doesn't go anywhere
out here yeah you know French Queen's
gamble decline very similar yeah you
called to James you know he likes this
Pawn on E6 he likes his Pawn chain
towards D5 he brings the bishop out
early so Queen A4 check Knight C6 will
see a ragozen a structure but Mustafa
he's playing slowly he's not blitzing
out the opening so I wonder if he's a
little bit surprised or if he's just
thinking about the match score trying to
figure out a game plan absolutely and of
course as we as you mentioned it where
it goes in here I was just looking at
these files from the black side actually
today Knight of six yeah so let's see
which one he goes for uh so these are
fun these are fun I mean sometimes you
see why get wiped off the board I was
like I don't ever want to play with
girls and when I saw uh who was it
Jeffrey Zhang crushing uh who was it
that was it Darius or somebody like that
but it was you just wiped him off the
board with the with the regos in there I
mean with white I was like oh man I
don't ever want that G4 Pawn was rolling
down oh no it was big fish for the safe
yeah he played feathers very very scary
game to say the least so but you know
Fabi is a fan of this too as well as a
cgc when you're cgc talking with Fabi
and like Fabi was like oh yeah we're
ghosts and I'm like oh we're goes and
Okay and like so this is a nice nice way
from both sides to see what they do
queen E8 I'm not too familiar with so
that's a definitely a different move
but you could tell what he's cooking
because let's bring up an analysis board
and make a careless move uh for white
and maybe it's actually not that bad but
I was going to make a movie like Rook C1
because I think Bishop takes C3 Bishop
takes back I'm looking already at Knight
takes D4 is this available the queen on
A4 is loose and that means you take the
queen I'm not just gonna take back
Intermezzo time with Knight takes F3
check to your king and after you take
back I get your queen and blacks of a
pawn in between move there and we're up
upon here absolutely feeling good there
are tactics everywhere Queen E8 is a
very creative move I think Queen to B3
in response taking on C4 now make the
queen move around a little bit or Bishop
C4
Bishop C4 uses the queen of E7 now
Bishop D6 and we're gonna play E5 yeah
standard stuff you see here and also
Knight F5 oh
wow look at that dual Threat by a blue
bomb here he has a lead on the clock
that's great news for the bears but
Mustafa says let's go forward Knight A5
no more the bishop on D2 covers it you
could play E5 but maybe I'll take your
Bishop on D6 and you're also opening up
this battery towards the black king so
I'm interested in this start but other
games have begun as well so let's zoom
out we'll come back to this one of
course it is the top board for the Bears
taking on board two for the Bulldogs
James I see in the top right very quiet
position thus far from boges on Daniel
dayas and Dimitri kolars and in the
bottom left Michael bazold I mean this
guy has been playing everything under
the sun and he's got this king's Indian
attack set up against Elian Rovers that
one might get spicy soon let's see that
one yeah hopefully come on Castle Queen
side well that's the Zoid come on bro
Castle queen size you just got you have
to but I mean just looks like capsule
Queen side and then I go G4 next I don't
even think about the next Castle G4 Rook
G1 maiden maiden 11.
uh we are talking about the game in the
bottom left between Michael bazold and
ellene Rovers it's funny James like let
me just throw all my pieces up the board
uh in the bottom right between Josephine
heinemann and bardia dinesha they just
have an early Sicilian not too much
happened yet so let's go to board uh
three for the Bears against board four
for the Bulldogs uh Michael bazold he's
playing creative openings and James he's
again up time he has more time than he
started with he may be like the quickest
player I've ever seen in the protest
League that's crazy what do you mean hey
man we gotta figure out what this man
eating how do you do that that's 10-7
right you didn't think about anything in
this position nothing like how did this
start let's how do we get here like he
just blissed out everything King's
Indian attack and then B3 Bishop oh he
went B in first oh my God yeah he was he
went for the Phoenix he's just you know
playing like a B3 Cowboy ADI Bond
somewhere like in this and then he plays
A3 to meet A4 with B4 this is standard
fare uh you do not want to allow black
to crack open the queen side for this
Rook on A8 so I like the way that bazel
does played I think that it's also
unfamiliar territory to most players
they don't see it in classical games
very often and as James has been
shouting for Castle Queen said let's go
we'll try to use this H6 Pawn as a hook
and push the g-pawn forward I will be a
little bit disappointed but I also will
understand if he castles King side and
is a little bit more solid but James I'm
with you I really want the queenside
Castle come on my guy Castle Queen side
G4 and just Knight takes G4 Rook G1 I
mean that's something like it's just
it's calling for that and if this
Bishop's very strong now of course C5
might be a little annoying but he plays
A4 yeah so he's just you know playing it
bro he's insta-moving hey we're gonna
have to move that fast Mike hey Mike
slow down
we all want to play like Mike come on we
know we know we want to be like Mike and
uh here we see him moving instantly and
he went to move A4 because he didn't
want black to play that move now rookie
eight you know she's trying to compete
for the center oh my gosh is he playing
bullet chess bro he's playing bull you
know we need to check his time you know
task manager right to make sure we don't
have any bot or any assistance here he
moving too fast Mike he's moving way too
fast I don't understand no of course but
he's really trying to blow her off the
board I'm not gonna lie he's just moving
quickly no mistakes he moves are very
easy to make this is really nice like
really like these type positions you can
also learn from this I mean like you can
play this setup really probably against
anything here it starts sort of a king's
Indian with a bishop on B2 which is a
very uh interesting one to say the least
but I mean look how much time he's up
Chad this is crazy I mean he's eating up
all the time thinking on her clock
that's all he's doing
hey it seems like he just you know knows
everything and he had the advantage
against booked on Daniel dayas against
the 2700 on the opposing team we know
he's capable of getting great positions
but he needs to close better that's been
his struggle today uh where he let that
one slip while up so many minutes with
the better position I guess maybe he
needs to slow down at critical moments
or just find those finishing touches
better but he is in good shape right now
he's up like nearly double her time soon
look at his face still just like no way
motion or anything all right is he gonna
instant move here finally under 10
minutes I mean that's like a goal you
know like can I get him under 10 minutes
bro can I make him think once now I
think she feels a little bit better it's
like at least he thought for a little
bit yeah he's used seven seconds and you
know while this game continues we are
gonna bring in a special guest here uh
we have Vieques love nemets joining us
from chess Essentials and leading the
Croatia bulldogs so uh how's it going
how are you enjoying your uh Bulldogs
lead right now
thank you
better than the last week at this stage
so can't complain at all
that's awesome man that's great what
goes into uh you know team preparation
for masses like this what did you uh how
did you prep the team
actually once you are at this stage it's
not so much work I think uh I guess you
know as well as I that up to the season
there's much more preparation here it's
more basic communication uh deciding who
will play making sure that everybody
knows the time the day it has the link
has read the regulations because many
chess players don't like to read long
documents that they have to sign and
stuff like that so technical stuff and
yeah but it's going actually pretty
smoothly and I have to con condemn the
organization of the league is actually a
pretty tall spot on and it's going like
a Clockwork
yeah well I mean for your team the
Croatia Bulldogs you're made up of many
International Players so how did that go
about what was that process like to
secure players from all over the globe
yeah it's uh we are today we are not
very Croatian I have to say and I think
this is the first time ever that we
don't have a single Croatian players uh
mainly because uh most of them are
playing actually in the uh German
Bundesliga so today they are traveling
there uh which Qureshi is very
relatively close but otherwise it's I
mean it's not so difficult to to you
know find people online to contact them
and say hey guys are you interested do
you want to play uh we have especially
after last week's match when I realized
that we are walking some players every
time we reached out over the weekend to
uh Grandmaster mustafaumas who is
showing his word and showing that it has
been a very good decision today so far
and also to a couple of other
Grandmasters and they usually replied
very quickly and yeah I signed three
players very very
fast so it is not that challenging it
requires some digging and some emailing
and writing on various online platforms
but
not a problem at all very nice does uh
does their team does the team have to is
it a requirement to go through to have a
your adjustable courses
and no but the requirement is to play
more than in at least one game so only
they are blocked and fulfill this
requirements so far so I'm waiting for
the rest yeah
right of course
and and pay homage to Mr Hess here but
the twist
and some Modern too definitely got to
see some water right from the course
well we have seen some you know high
level play this far let's zoom out to
get all four boards on screen for
everybody because this is a critical
round you know your Bulldogs they don't
want to allow the Bears back in the
match so when you look in the top left
here uh Mustafa ilmaz he loves his
Knight against the bishop it seems like
he just won uh the previous end game uh
when he had uh his night against
Josephine heinemann's Bishop so when you
look at that game the top left of the
echoslov what are you thinking you like
in mustafa's position
yeah yeah I mean uh I guess it's a good
position to have a new renoid uh I mean
I love it upon night against the bishop
I'm not that worst in my Classics but I
would say that the right doesn't have
too much risk there which I think is a
you know draw is a good result at this
point so I guess we should take it
stable position and and
nothing to complain about I think what
do you think
I agree with you I just I'm going to let
you do the talking because everything
you said and we see a queen trade being
offered uh because the pawn structure is
healthier for white here and well you
he's your pickup right you just got him
Mustafa UMass coming off the top of
Steel Challengers event where he
performed second place he was really
strong in that so what does this do for
your your confidence as a manager you're
looking at him he won the first couple
games now in game three no issues
whatsoever against the board one for the
opposing team are we gonna see more
Mustafa yamas
yeah I hope so although not in the next
round because he already told me that he
is also playing uh Somewhere over the
board I think in Norwegian League or
something so yeah that's why that's why
I realized uh basically it hit me after
the last week's match I was like okay
because I didn't want to Stack Up the
team with like 15 people and then nobody
can play but then I realized why some
other teams have a little bit more deep
depth in their rosters so yeah I mean I
mean I guess it's a good thing that that
these professionals have opportunities
and uh as far as I know these leagues
are usually what what the major brings
in the majority of the income so we are
happy to see that and we do have some
some Replacements we have signed the
Grand Master vasive durability and also
uh Grandmaster Alexander engic so yeah
I'm still pondering on how the team will
look like and but I have some rough
sketches and ideas but as far as I
understand if I understood the format
correctly we will be playing more than
one week so hopefully we will see
Mustafa in action
in some other round as well
very good yeah and wow look at this move
from Mustang I mean F4 he hits the queen
I think we're gonna see F5 next that
Bishop on G6 not a happy camper you were
talking about the isolated pawn and the
classics I mean this seems like a very
nice way of dealing with it the Knight
on D4 Aaron nimsovich would be very
proud
yeah I don't know like these positions
they're over like I usbots have said the
club level we look at this and we say oh
it's an isolated Pawn it's almost one
one one way street and such it turns out
that sometimes this positions are more
resilient and I often find myself I
don't know not not realizing that
there's not much Advantage even though
it's it's a queer weakness but uh yeah I
I mean I guess at this level it's very
pleasant position provide and more
importantly it's easier to play in this
relatively fast-paced uh tempo right
for sure I mean this looks really nice
for Amazon I actually want to draw our
attention to another game while Matthias
Blue Mountain thinks because if we bring
back our four board view you're gonna be
happy about this look in the bottom
right bardia dineshfar yeah you know
he's coming in and I am entitled but a
GM in strength and you know that we just
see him with the upper hand with a
skewer of the queen and the Rook so
biancus love here what are you what are
you making of this this looks great for
him what are you feeding him yeah yeah
just a small correction I think he's
actually made his GM a title recently uh
in like last month or last week or
something I think he made his final Norm
which I I guess when you consider how
he's playing uh you could assume that
it's just a matter of time anyway like
I don't know I it has been super
impressive like I I thought he might be
a little bit underrated online
specialist but so far what he's doing in
in this league it's beyond depressive in
my opinion like yeah another strong I am
that I managed to pick up and and it
turned out to be a bullseye so far
oh man wow all right man you guys what's
the lottery next week then that's what
you think wow you got the lottery
numbers too man that's crazy that's a
nice pig from bardia today definitely
playing great chat
yeah well I have uh also just fantasy or
something that would be nice just fancy
right yeah this this round is a chess
fantasy for your squad because before we
let you go all four boards for your team
look like they might win their games
like the evaluations are through the
roof for the Croatia Bulldogs in the top
left the Evo bar is all the way up
because that Bishop on H5 is about to be
trapped it looks like in the top right
uh bogdon Daniel Deutsch with a clear
edge better pawns more activity in the
bottom left it looks like a leaned
Rovers I mean that is a great signing
for you as well she's playing her uh
first match she had tough pairings in
the first two but with the black pieces
she looks extremely stable and in charge
so avocaust love here I mean you know I
think you need to tell us the lottery
numbers like what goes into making a
successful team could couldn't get more
successful than your squad this week
yeah yeah I hope I hope it continues
after last week I don't know if you
remember but there was this break the
heartbreaking blunder in the game
between dayak and Spirits this I don't
know if it was mouth sweep or or
something so yeah it's it's nice to
bounce back in in such a convincing
fashion I don't want to jinx it yet but
as it looks like it's the match will be
in the back so yeah maybe I should
indeed put some watery this week you'll
see
well we've uh really had a lot of fun
with you here everybody if you want to
you should follow flag Master Nimitz uh
that's uh the twitch channel that you're
current is currently streaming on so of
Yakuza we'll let you back to it but we
hope to send many viewers your way some
followers influxing and we loved your
Croatia Bulldogs it seems like you are
gonna well on your way to match Victory
so we'll be seeing more of great success
from your team so thanks so much for
joining us
okay thank you guys for having me and
keep up the the good work and yeah hope
to see this commentary Duo next week you
bring me Good Luck apparently so
nice nice
oh thank you so much that is your
manager of the Croatia Bulldogs James I
mean it's so much fun to hear his
thoughts you know he clearly is such a
chess Lover he has some really
instructive uh content out there for all
growing chess players so uh you know
it's nice to see him join us and his
team having success absolutely team
having success here right we playing the
lottery I mean everybody about to be
paid over here man with flag master and
they make there right so very strong
player obviously so
um yeah strong stuff here from his team
too I mean this is this is looking good
three boards out of four are all winning
for the Bulldogs
yeah they're really just cruising right
now because uh we see in the board in
front of us the one between uh and
Dimitri calls I mean look at this Knight
on H7 kick backwards this A7 Pawn can be
captured if poked on Daniel wants it he
does he says give me that and watch out
for E6 that's what I'm looking for James
don't play that at the first like I
didn't even care about the A7 Pawn but
he just like he got that on tap man
he says all right I'll trade a pair of
Rooks if your Rook comes over here then
I'll play E6 or King is wide open G6
will be loose if G6 Falls H5 is likely
next and what's that Bishop doing that's
a big Pawn over there so this is looking
like a one-sided game yeah this is
looking definitely one side of here I
mean uh he used his time very well you
have so many aspirations so many things
you can do E6 is super strong here let
me just open up the whole position G6 is
going to be very weak as well I mean we
have a nice places placement for the
pieces the 9087 is doing what again
right and the bishop on A8 oh my
goodness two bad pieces versus you know
two good pieces I mean it's very clear
who's in charge here
yeah and you mentioned good pieces and I
think we should go to a bird's eye view
because in a specific game uh there is a
piece that is not very good look at the
top left that Bishop on G4 is trapped in
its place yeah Mustafa ilmas is in
charge while on the bottom right bartier
National is up I don't know how much an
exchange so he's got a rook for Justin
heinemann's Knight that's just crushing
as he brought his Rook down to D1 in the
bottom right the bottom left the leaned
Rover she's just taking all the squares
in the center of the board against
Michael bezold but let's go to board one
because it might be the last time we
stop here James this bishop on G4 it is
trapped has nowhere to go and I'm not
even sure if you need to take it right
away it can't move anywhere like yeah
yeah he's like yeah you're right Robert
yeah you're right you're right bro
appreciate you bro thank you
oh gosh it's just trapped nowhere for it
to go Blue bump down to 20 seconds and
change James this is a blowout the
Bulldogs are killing them you know never
would have thought that I would choose a
dog over a bear you know and never until
today will change your mind okay the
Bulldogs are very very strong it's a lot
of them right a lot of Bulldogs is
different than one Bulldog so it's a
they teamed up today and they definitely
you know have a very impressive Victory
as it looks like they're closing in on
the match right now I'm gonna end it
eight and a half to you know whatever
maybe three they draw that game whatever
the fourth happens there but very strong
stuff here from from the Bulldogs and as
we see in the birds of E6 played in the
top right boged on Daniel she's going
for it but let's go to Elaine rober's
game in the bottom left because she's in
some time trouble we know we know
Michael bazov moves instantly his
position is quite bad it's dangerous but
look at the clock she's down to 20
seconds James now what's funny is I'm
laughing because like he did this every
game you know Mike just like he was
winning you know he crushing and then we
came back it's like Mike come on man he
was moving too fast he really blitzed
him and then like you know I mean the
time obviously is there but 19 seconds
so he's getting up on time but it's not
accurate James you ever seen this a
queen on G1 King on H2 that doesn't look
right yeah something went wrong there
something like some 960 went wrong
or you know started at 960 here well
check King back well he but she bought
the oh okay never mind I had to go there
I was about to cook him work at forward
oh wait well I think you're right though
that rook's coming up and let's go for
that King and great decision by Eileen
right there a lot of people in time
trouble they freak out I'm up upon let's
trade Queens she said what do you mean
I'm a part and I have the attack my king
is safe and sound let's bring the
artillery and here comes Rook F5 Rook H5
oh my goodness yeah this is this is a
crush here what happened look at them
Ponzi gonna sound like what happened to
your Center pawns he had DNE now he does
not have D or E you're both gone here
and uh time travel is there for her but
she's just closing in wait Bishop D6
okay
takes you can still fight here yes he's
just like let me trade open up that f
file you know get that Bishop out of
here
yeah definitely
trade them boys off
well she has 15 seconds which uh oh
correct D5 Rook H5 we know what's up is
that Queen trapped
oh
yeah it's gonna go back here
like G1 just go oh Rook C5 she's like
surprising me I don't know where her
Rooks are going what's what's going on
here but she is the center all protected
by her Queen and her Knight so oh just
bring bring these pieces over like at
some point you just gotta play E3 like
both on Daniel dayage right yeah and
play ether open it up just like that
whoa whoa whoa whoa oh hit him splitting
that was not asked you I was not
expecting I was confused by Rook C5 but
she says I'll show you why and by the
way bardia dineshr did win with the
black pieces a huge win for the Bulldogs
Knight F3 check is incoming and if you
play King to F1 E3 bam gonna hit you
where it hurts with Knight G4 so let's
see the rookie two Knight F3 check King
F1 probably and then E3 anyway E3 open
up shop hello who's home
she's going for this Pawn but apparently
that was an inaccuracy of so I don't
know why it looks really strong yeah it
does it's very strong I don't know wow
wow what do you do queen H5 but what's
the next move
so oh my gosh what defense it is yeah
that's a strong move that came out of
nowhere like it looked completely
winning for for black but now Michael
Bizzle he might keep the Bears in this
match but I still like the attack James
I don't trust the defense with his King
being wide open I mean it's he's moving
very quickly too as well dang wait
that's the trade
oh and now it's better for white all of
a sudden somehow things have gone out of
hand for Elaine Roberts she was cruising
she sacked that exchange and suddenly
Michael bezold his lead on the clock is
paying off
yeah chest is a chest is hard here you
know she definitely in time travel to
time trouble got to her as you can see
here man what a brave move like Pawn
takes E3 maybe you guess you take twice
then since you really feeling like that
no good night discovers maybe there's
Knight D4 it takes C2 just grab a few
pawns but the Rooks of course are better
the app in exchange for white but give
me this Pawn but let's uh zoom out of
here go to the birds because so many
games are coming to their conclusion in
the top left wait what Mustafa um was up
a piece now he's losing which is blue
bomb let's turn this game around oh my
goodness
oh my gosh winning Matthias bluebound is
just gonna take on F2 even if the queen
protects it it's a winning King and pawn
end game for the Berlin bears oh my
goodness bro this whole match is turning
around
and blue bomb one
wow I know he can't believe it we got to
see what happened there how did that
even happen how did how did that even
happen there bardee is the only and now
she's what happened it was like it was
going to be three oh yeah and no
something like that and now suddenly the
Bears are in charge in this round
because Michael bezeld in the bottom
left I mean look at that game it's an
end game where black has chances you
have a knight and one Pawn versus a rook
but unfortunately there are pawns on the
queen side if those pawns disappeared
we'd say no problem we could almost
certainly make a draw but with those
pawns that knight ever gets kicked the
Rooks are gonna team up and go after it
yeah that pawn is definitely loose here
and we also have the outside a that we
can use ourselves here you're in time
trouble two seconds there is that what
that was oh you got 3.5
very be very careful because you could
walk into checkmates of sorts like this
Rook coming down to C3 uh thankfully The
Rook protects but 3.5 seconds for a lean
Rovers she needs to hold this game
that'd be huge for the Bulldogs
yeah Knight G6 check okay we're looking
good
looking good for white still check King
D3 wrong
okay so many checks like this king is
running all the way
and be very careful if you're white
Knights are such tricky pieces yeah this
don't get forked right just try not to
get more easier said than done maybe
centralized to move over one rookie four
okay that's a nice check Rick oh don't
play Rook G6 don't play
oh yeah
and then you hang them for it yeah you
better watch out there's a fork on D4 if
this Rook moves off the D file uh so a
minute left for Michael bazold and Alene
took very well in the clock all of a
sudden she uh you know has had about a
minute for a while she makes sure to
step out of any pins if she wants her
Knight to get back to E5 so she's doing
this pretty decently I would say oh
definitely of course making uh the best
of what she has even in the time
situation with the tricky Knight too as
well
yeah and the the Bears will get another
game and oh oh my gosh if suddenly uh
she takes this Pawn she could win with
these outside passers you know we don't
even know what's happening anymore you
might as well just turn the engine off
it don't even matter it doesn't matter
nobody's following anything nobody knows
what's really going on in fact we
thought this match was over but it is
nowhere near that now
yes he's defending right yeah but no
James you're right I mean it looked like
the Bulldogs were just gonna Clean Sweep
this round and suddenly the Bears you
know if they win this game seven to five
they have a legitimate chance going into
the final round think about that think
about you know you know shoot the
momentum swing could be huge there I
mean going from oh we closing the match
out to like oh we might lose the match
that's huge that's absolutely a huge
momentum swing psychology right as well
there how do you feel and if you feel
good you can play good but also you can
be scared and mess things up and it's
fine around especially based off of
whatever those pairings look like
wow I mean this is still a defensive
task for alien Roberts but she's
fighting perfectly no progress yet but
you know you have to watch out because
at some point this Pawn is going to be
an easy target and he brings the king up
and the Knight comes out yeah I think
King A4 was nice check and now we can
take I think we just too fast to Queenie
oh
that's tricky
and she's trying her best but the king
just steps back and now the pawn is is
his uh yeah you just have to uh yeah
well I can take
okay going after this Pawn I guess but
it should not be enough just take this
one here Knight C5 is a fork but a rook
can give a check on the sixth rank oh
wait wait take I took the pawn I'm no
social wrong oh yeah yeah she missed she
could have grabbed it what's going on
here oh man oh okay let's bring up an
analysis board a couple things Knight
takes Rook takes get rid of that pass
Pawn this should be a draw as the night
gets back in the game and then in this
position instead of 94 Rook a one check
the king had to slide back Rook takes A5
protects the Knight she could have
stolen the pawn she's in time travel can
hardly blame her I mean both sides will
make mistakes and oh speaking of
mistakes there's a fork oh but it's not
yeah ah look at him no it wasn't he is
too tricky before yeah man yeah
what is happening in this game Rook
takes Pawn
look at the time though
wait she could hold this she could hold
this if he is not careful
check check
yeah that was well that's it yeah nice
hanging that's it that's it boom and he
got it and he got it wow what a game bro
this game was long and like lots of
moves I mean how many moves was this
we're at 100 okay 100 or something like
that okay yeah too many moves man
honestly the ups and downs
I'm gonna need to take a breather this
is just crazy stuff but Michael bazo
gets a win for the Berlin Bears it's now
seven to five so they have a legitimate
chance I really thought they were done I
counted them out I thought this was
match over but somehow Michael bezold
wins I mean somehow Matthias bluebound
I'm gonna quickly pull up that game I
mean I don't understand when that Bishop
was trapped like
where'd that
where'd it go like it was somewhere back
here is up a piece up a whole piece
you're up a night on D4 a clean extra
but you can go for an attack try to
deliver a Checkmate but it looks like
there was a blunder around here James
like right around here the pieces got
tied up and after the swap Rook E4
happens and queen check
life happens fast
get that off the screen bro Rook H1
that's crazy man that's disgusting oh my
goodness her case one is mating you got
to get a piece back
yeah and then black went out to win this
wow oh my gosh so the Berlin Bears they
could have been knocked out Eileen
robbers is winning uh Matthias bluebound
I mean he was dead lost but he wins and
Michael bazold wins and suddenly two and
a half one and a half in favor of the
Bears in that round James I still cannot
wrap my mind around what just happened I
mean actually I mean I feel like if I'm
playing for the Bulldogs I'm still I'm
I'm the same way I'm shocked I'm
literally legitimately shocked right now
that this happened and I think Bears
need to really ride this momentum wave
and this could be you know this could be
a real match it is right now guys I mean
five to seven that's very close it's all
about this last round now they are in
Striking Distance and I don't know who's
gonna make it
and we see the overall scores uh Bogdan
Dental Dutch with two and a half points
out of three bardia dineshwar also with
two and a half and three and for Mustafa
yamas it could have been three out of
three but he blundered in a piece up
position to the Bears their top two
boards are doing well at least on the
scoreboard the games have been shaky
somewhat uh but they need all four
boards to perform here James uh even
Josephine Hyman she gets to play against
the lean robbers and that match could
help the bears survive here that is
correct in fact yeah I mean she's
playing uh yeah that's right they're
playing each other now I mean that's
where they matched up even on the
scorecard too as well so this is the
mask that she probably was looking the
most forward to isn't like okay you know
I have a really fighting good chance
here to try to win I mean every match
was much harder than the other ones but
this one she's like yeah okay if I can
if I need to strike right now is the
time because every Point really counts
in the first to eight and a half takes
this thing and it could be either team
right now
the team manager for Croatia might be a
little bit upset all of a sudden
commentators curse but we'll see if the
Croatian Bulldogs can finish what they
started if they could take down the
Berlin Bears we'll find that out as
round four of this protest League match
continues in just a few minutes do not
go anywhere
I don't think about during the games but
I certainly like do think about how like
few African-Americans there are like the
top level
so I try to do my best to
to motivate more people like us to
give it a try and hopefully succeed
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we have boged on Daniel dayat on screen
he is the board one for the Croatia
bulldogs and he will be looking to put
this match away in favor of his Squad it
looked like it was a foregone conclusion
that the Bulldogs would take it in three
rounds but that did not happen so as we
see he is the top scorer for his team
along with bardia dineshfar uh who is
board three for the Bulldogs James it
still feels like anyone's match because
the momentum has somewhat shifted to the
Berlin Bears yeah momentum is huge here
if you can ride the momentum wave there
I mean anybody anything can happen right
you feeling good like yo we won that
match we won wow we oh we have a shot
and then everything sting start clicking
things start turning right where they
actually feel like they have a real
legit shot at this and they actually do
here so it is now you know the Bulldogs
trying to put it away one and a half
come on they're like come on we can do
this we got four games we need one and a
half but also the Bears are going to do
everything in her power to try to stop
them from Quincy they will indeed and
we'll look at the board by board
matchups here in the fourth round it's
one versus one all the way down to four
versus four so for the Bears they get
white on the top two uh kolars and
bluebound they get the white pieces
bizzled and heinemann get black so James
they need to score three points minimum
do the Berlin Bears who do you think
needs to do the heavy lifting
you know it looks like I think the
bottom boards need to do more of the
heavy lifting there if the if the
Josephine could get a win and basil get
a win there I mean it's like oh it's not
we we tied and then it's gonna be up
there at the top whatever happens up
there is a shake-up that could go either
way one and a half one and a half
whatever punches that's it that is it
right so the bottom I think the bottom
half this time gotta get the ball
rolling and quickly maybe not quickly
but you do want to strike now strike
fast good win the game that's it we just
got to get a dub on the board
well sometimes it feels like the only
way to get a dub against Bolton Daniel
dayach is to steal his files so I think
if you're the Berlin Bears you need to
grab those notes behind him I think
that's you know that old school chess
method handwritten notes uh positions uh
you know in diagrams so that is the
board one for the bulldoze chat get
involved let us know do you think the
Berlin Bears can actually come back and
take this match they look like they were
out of it but now they do have a little
bit legitimate chance so let us know now
let James and I know what you think and
the action has taken off who you got
chat put it in the chat right now who do
you got this is your time now this is it
it's the final round here is it the
Bulldogs or the Bears for you yeah
and look at this quiet start to this
game the bishop slides out to F4 after
black played H6 it's become increasingly
popular thanks to Magnus Carlson he
likes to make These Quiet Moves Like H6
not developing his pieces yet and white
does seem to have a lead in terms of
development uh but black is ultra solid
no weaknesses no squares to Target and
James must win territory I know you're a
fan should we see move on G4 here
absolutely I mean you just play G4 and
don't even think twice about it right
now of course he think he thought twice
about it and played 92 which is totally
understandable but definitely you want
to create some things here create some
chances and create some imbalances in
some areas now there is an imbalance in
the pawn structure here obviously we
have a very classical uh carlsbaden wave
in Reverse type thing but we have a b4p5
as our usual stuff is what you want to
do with white but I mean I like the
aggression right like go for it Rook G1
G4 H3 G4 right something I'm going to G4
you also have Knight Z3 are for taking
you really just don't want to go like
probably the classical routes of a
regular chess you that you would go in a
classical game because we need to win
and he does trade Bishops go Knight G3 I
think we might see Bishop D3 and a swap
and maybe eventually F3 and E4 just a
slow push in the center and if you look
at the board in the pawn structure a
white does have an extra paw in the
center black has one white has two and
oh Harry the H Fawn James I was not
liking that I like it I like it all day
baby okay it's 45 and we live grab that
space and then Bishop D3 now we got
stuff like Rook h4s very strange but I'm
definitely gonna Rook lift up there and
I'm probably casting Queen side here I
like to be very creative I'm a very
creative player myself so I love
creativity and also having active pieces
and going for attacks especially when
you have you know uh trumps to say so
like I have space space on the king side
I'm probably not trying to Castle that
way I do want to attack you this is for
the team you know and it's a little bit
of risk involved obviously too as well
but I am a big fan of this H4 H5
decision from Blue Box yeah well this
game is looking like both Kings made
Castle in either direction we don't know
they may trick us and go the opposite
way of what what we expect but let's
actually zoom out of this one for a
moment just because other games have
begun and both teams they desperately
want to win this match they do not want
to play the St Louis archbishops the
loser of this match has that fate but
look in the top right gawaine Jones may
play for the Norway gnomes but he has
been one of the biggest proponents of
this opening and Dimitri kolars strikes
in the center I think we should Dive
Right into that board by the way Michael
bazold hasn't moved it's the only time
we've seen him under 10 minutes he must
just not be at the board in the bottom
left he finally does move but let's go
to the top right because that game is
looking fascinating and gawaine Jones
he's he essays the Grand Prix attack
against the Sicilian all day and James
is already tactics involving Bishop
takes F7 check and pawn to E6 oh we love
this strong so yeah that's very strong
actually I saw you guys mentioned that
uh there's another I don't know whose
game that was but it was definitely a
game I think it was yesterday maybe
maybe it was yesterday it was just a
game you guys you and uh Daniel was
commentating on that had this this
tactic in it I don't remember what game
that was but yeah this is nasty wicked
stuff here Grand Prix is definitely a
scary one guys for Sicilian players the
Grand Prix is not one that you're happy
to see right it's one of those
anti-sicilians in a way that you're just
like ah you know I play the Sicilian to
play the Sicilian I don't want to be
anti-sicilian and this is a very strong
one especially in fast time controls
when you don't have as much time to
think here I suppose it's E5 the Knight
goes to H5 here I definitely like
White's prospects
yeah I mean Knight takes F4 not even
sure you want to take that pawn because
white could Castle take that pawn open
the f file thank you very much so it
feels like with Knight G5 on tap Bishop
takes F7 being available uh you could
just play a solid move like D3 and say
Knights on the rim are looking
particularly dim here so I feel like
this is going to be a combative game but
Dimitri colors he's the one spending
time you know he's looking at these
tactics on f70s think about Knight G5
he does he goes for it
I'm curious how quickly you know Moz
plays James because that will dictate or
at least show to us you know how ready
he is if he expects this at all yeah he
actually I can see he's still thinking
he's still he wasn't expecting maybe he
expected it but he was like yeah okay he
went for it so with King G8 seems right
we take and now E6 is just a weak Square
with the Rook locked in the corner on h8
right now so
such a weird position to see and well
these players they're finally going to
spend a bit of time because it's hectic
here let's go to the bird's eye view
once more because look at the bottom
left that may look unfamiliar that type
of position to most people but not to me
it's actually one of my favorite
openings from the black Sun that's a G
oh James come on man you studied too
much you know what's up you know that's
a Genji Indian so let's go right in
there it's also known as the pterodactyl
beef eater variation but calmly referred
to as the jinji Indian wow yeah the
Genji Indian yeah I haven't seen much of
that
wow and you can't yeah and then you put
everything on dark yeah this is a very
fun opening
yeah and it looks like white knew
exactly what to do H4 you want to play
H5 open up this line for Knight F6 and
after H5 do not take it because if you
take white just goes bam you can take on
H5 and after Pawn takes play E4 Queen
takes H5 and your king is never going to
be happy Advantage one so instead you
play Rook to G8 and then after swap swap
this is a very important move I
shouldn't teach people how to play
against it but black often wants to put
the queen on A5 to keep white tied down
to the C3 Pawn so Queen A4 stops Queen
A5 and pins the D6 Pawn all at once
wow yeah this is these these are very
strange positions like it's a lot of
lots of things happen here the king runs
to C7 and stuff like that like it's but
wait a second oh no this is right yeah I
remember this I remember some of this
Theory 95. it just looks man it's very
deceptive this is a very strange opening
I have to say a fantastic choice against
a young opponent because
the Genji Indian went out of style uh
you know in 20 years ago maybe more and
so for Michael bazold somebody who's
been around a veteran of the game he's
like let's just play something that my
opponent is less familiar with and he's
just capturing quickly watch out though
this B7 Pawn this G2 Bishop for the long
term that means the Knight can't really
move very easily but Queen A6 protects
and attacks James I'm loving the opening
Choice from black and he got a good
position too I mean queen H6 to C4 is
definitely you see this all the time in
the Nim zone now and they definitely
like white a lot but I mean practical
chances yeah I'm definitely I love it
let me this reminds me a lot of uh nimso
India of course the A3 variation
um or whatever they call elements or
something but A3 where um A3 after
Bishop before you take on C3 and you
play C5 an ac6 b695 Bishop A6 Rook C8
take on D4 bully to C4 Pawn right so you
can do the same thing here even uh um
Roman xinji has really recommend
sometimes Queen C8 B7 over to C6 and in
this case it's like Queen A6 to hit C4
we can take C4 to be able to take this
Pawn over here and it's just the fact
that the double pawns are here we trade
pieces off and black has a nice game but
those Bishops can be very menacing
yeah Queen X6 right now go right for the
pawn I'm not sure Bishop Some Kind of
Night jump uh but it white does have
Rook H4 as a rook lift to defend but
then black can slide The Rook to h8 and
say get that Rook out of here I want to
win this Pawn on C4 so this is a big
moment here for Michael bisold and the
Bears if he can take down Borgia Dinesh
Ford with black that would give them
some legitimate hopes in this match I'm
expecting Queen A6 looks like the very
natural move uh but let's leave him to
it because every single game uh is
important here the Bulldogs need just
one and a half and as I look across the
boards here
looking level in the top left looking
quite level despite a weird position in
the top right and then in the bottom
right that one's looking like it's going
to be a real battle between a lean
robers and Josephine heinemann so James
I'll let you choose which game is most
interesting to you let's actually go
through the ladies game there they
actually always uh you know women's
games are very very a lot of times I see
tactical aggressive they just want to
fight each other they always want to
like play for attacking chances or at
least to win the game right there's not
a mini quick draws in the women games
and stuff like that definitely gonna be
a fight in this one so I believe so this
looks like it's some type of Sicilian
one yes maybe a position one yeah
and I've never heard of this the Knight
of Amsterdam variation and only and
Roberts you know she's Dutch playing
into the Amsterdam variation uh I I
don't know of these opening names but
all I know is when I see this position
it's like about the dark squares of
black and trade off the dark Square
Bishops and leave white saddle with this
one that can be good and G6 clearly
played against the slight Square Bishop
absolutely of course and they're both
0-3 here so being with that score you
know they they are like I need to fight
I'm here you know you're losing game
after game you get annoyed absolutely I
gotta win right so this is definitely a
big game I think for these two a lot of
tension here they both want to win and I
think they're both going to go for a
sicilian combative opening the r squares
are weak around there I mean why don't I
just the F5 is just screaming but I mean
of course you gotta you gotta be careful
F5 is just screaming what if what if
yeah because she could play at five so
I'm just gonna play it yeah it's one of
those big moves where you know F5 gives
away even more of the dark squares but
if you take make the night hops in you
don't really want that and B4 is loose
but so is D5 like both players have
loose Pawns in this position I would not
take on B4 if I were playing with the
white pieces here I feel like D5 is the
more valuable pawn and The Rook hits the
queen and the Knight behind it so James
I don't really know what to make of this
I feel like both sides have their
chances and F5 is looking reasonable uh
I I don't I really don't want to take
this point I'm gonna be honest I I'm
looking at it I see it's there but I
really really don't want to capture it
yeah we're not touching that pawn
definitely not especially if we were
Castle Queen side that's a little bit
different you even seen that I think uh
yawn beat um and the candidates farouzia
with that Queen takes before night or so
it is like you can take it when your
Castle Queen side in many cases and then
if you're aggressively attacking but in
this way you know you're just obviously
opening up The Rook uh on B8 the G2 Bish
or on the bishop is going to be able to
hit G2 after taking on D5 so we just
don't even worry about this out of the
board exactly you just push it and think
about everything else later F5 and we
live but of course Bishop D5 right now
maybe we take on G6 twice is that the
idea you take on B3 which is interesting
yeah it might get real spicy in these
positions because there's a rook staring
down the bishop there might be tactics
available and perhaps Josephine says I
don't want any part of this text let's
bring my knight to F6 go after this D5
Pawn with the second piece and I really
don't feel like white can actually keep
that pawn so there's going to be
compensation Bishop H6 open the f file
take on G6 oh really exciting stuff yeah
definitely a white is playing with
initiative here black is trying to do
the opposite or actually trying to
neutralize the initiative maybe a bishop
G5 that isn't an idea you see this a lot
because The Bishop's so bad you want to
trade it off and neutralize of course my
dark squares are weak I can cover them
and d5's again weak as possible yeah so
yeah it's one of those big decisions and
if the queen were ever to leave the AP
move this Knight A5 to look out for so
this is about squares at the moment so
both sides are trying to figure out
where to put their piece in James you
called it it's been played uh if this
queen lands on G5 and the bishop takes
here you get to watch out for checkmate
as well so this is a really fun game but
you know the Bears they need three
points minimum across the four boards so
Josephine and Elaine that's uh kind of a
toss-up at the moment both sides are
playing enterprising chess but I'm
looking across the boards top left looks
very solid nothing uh no dents in the
position for either side the top right
has normalized right that like was a
weird opening with a bishop sack but
like looks like a standard game and the
bottom left that one still looks weird
to me uh James but the evil bar is
saying that bardia dineshfar has the
better position from that jinji Indian
yeah it's very difficult that one is
like all the structure all the pieces
like double pawns on on half double
pawns on C open B file Bishop versus
knight who is better there there is a
lot of play in that game that's a lot
now they traded Okay so
um Knight versus Bishop is weak though I
mean I think that's like black here
yeah it's one of these positions where
as we kind of look closer the pawn on E6
it's a great pass Pawn the bishop can
slide to D5 the bishop can serve like a
pawn protecting another passer but this
Knight can also slide in front and
knights are the best block haters
against past pawns the issue for bezeld
is well how can he actually play for a
win the team yeah will need three total
points he brings his King to block he
did protect this Pawn with his Rook uh
but what if this bishop sits on D5 James
I don't see any way to kick it out yeah
that's the problem here I mean E6 is
very weak but after Bishop T5 I mean
it's just kind of chilling and white
maybe we could just you know play this
for two results which really we are
playing for that anyway right here it
feels like it's white here I think it's
easier to play as white but black does
have you know in a closed position you
would like the Knight and we do have the
Knight here sort of closed white can
play Black and play I mean I think white
has a slider Advantage so it's just it
looks better looks better and it feels a
little bit better after we do a little
evaluation of the position yeah A6 right
Bishop D5 rookie rookie D1 King C7
yeah we couldn't go to E7 because the B7
Pawn would have been lost so back to C7
and ah it just feels like black should
be able to go after this Pawn there's
just no way the Knight on B6 James
that's a bad piece because if Rook comes
to E7 your knight goes to C8 was it
going to A7 and C6 and that takes way
too long
way too many pieces way too many moves
but of course it is possible of course
because of the fact that um it's a close
position E3 yeah it's kind of a waiting
move
yeah you got you got to move this around
like maybe go to E7 and G5 at some point
potentially I I feel like black doesn't
have to sit and do nothing and let's not
forget what
oh ancient and just Rook A1
um oh but he has A4 is that his idea oh
it takes
no but he can play his Knight to A5 how
is this wrong interesting yeah I was
going to it's funny because later I was
gonna say that you can play A5 and try
to get an outside pass Pawn but I wasn't
expecting it right now and Rook B1 so he
trusted his opponent and played let's
bring up an analysis for it because Rook
A1 would have won this Pawn so the pawn
says okay here you have it let me take
on C4 and if Rook B1 uh James was saying
there's moves like B6 and Knight A5 but
I guess whiteheads with A5 and you're
trying to break open the position for
your Rook oh yeah that's engine all day
that's engine right for it boy that is
man that's sick that's a sick idea you
you have to see A5 to go for this whole
line yeah and he wasn't able to see a
five which I mean we could blame him A5
A6 that's tough to understand that no
yeah it's it's very far away because the
national move Rook B1 there is B6 and
now black has closed down that side of
the board I agree with you James uh that
was kind of a easy thing for a computer
to spout out but hard for a human to see
but he may eventually play for K1 like
right now because C4 is protected and
that should uh decide this game but
let's go uh away from this one I do
think that bardia has the upper hand the
top left poked on Daniel Day Arch the
board one for the Croatia Bulldogs he
wants to land a one-two punch alongside
uh his teammate bardia dineshfar because
if they both win or if they just scored
one in that points the match is in fact
one for the Bulldogs and James this is
looking really bad for bluebound as the
position opens up and the white king
looks like like it's like eight
different tactics right now I can take
on B3 C3 hanging E4 or some problems and
of course my D3 Knight is the problem
here but I mean you obviously know there
is something going on right now even
eval bar tells you but the question is
what is it and where right now this
Knight takes before a move Knight takes
Knight takes there I don't see a way to
increase the PIN
but there is something here what could
it be because Knight C5 goes after this
E4 upon another time but I just realized
these Knights are staring at each other
so maybe you can just take this Knight
here and take this Pawn so yeah
one minute by the way for bugs on Daniel
I don't know his Knight B5 a thing
what do you do here oh wow his camera
just dropped it's so crazy oh man what
is going on everybody
it's Panic at the Disco for bugs on
Daniel dayas and he's he's trying to fix
his camera while he's 40 seconds on the
clock oh my gosh
oh my goodness oh my gosh I've seen
losses by disconnect I've seen losses on
time I don't think I've ever seen a loss
by trying to fix your camera lost by the
camera wait that was actually impressive
he got that up
and then said he had a frame but he
definitely yeah he played Knight B5
right I knew this was coming that'd be
fine to look good but I don't know what
because that wasn't an engine didn't
like it I mean I feel for him there
that's a tough one and you know the
multiple camera angles anyway so uh the
chess.com team can't see behind the
scenes uh what's going on not really
worried but it just makes sure that fair
play is upheld so we have uh this Pawn
structure upheld B5 up to C4 that means
the 93 is entrenched in there hard to
kick out I still like Black's position
even if the eval Bar says some of the
edge is gone watch out Rook takes D5 a
threat with the queen I need two loose
behind the pawn tactics everywhere right
now you also have uh of course um oh he
just smack that boy Whoa We just said
give it give it up I mean I guess that's
a good practical decision
yeah although what if I queen E5 go
rookie one there's Rook takes D5 so I
feel like this is a problem for white
yeah yeah definitely and pawns are very
weak now but okay rookie yeah he just
takes that boys jeez and I didn't even
defend it you defended by trading Queens
which is not a good idea wow that's
actually pretty clever because maybe
white has enough Pawn so uh this one
it's anyone's game as poked on Daniel
Dash is down to just 10 seconds he did
swap Queens in the top left he has the
edge there and the top right Dimitri
colors with the advantage against
Mustafa ilmas but bardia dinesfar in the
bottom left that's huge for Croatia
Croatia needs one win and one draw and
bardia denester is going to get that win
he has a pass Pawn on E6 so uh the Bears
they're fighting on board four it looks
like Josephine heinemann has a good shot
there in the top right let's go into
Dimitri kolars and uh his opponent
Mustafa ilmaz because it looks like
kolars is in control
oh yeah this is a very very appealing
position for white here it feels like we
have the space queen centralized Knight
is still in the room over there this was
a great grand prix shout out to the
Grand Prix players of the Sicilian I
used to like that myself in fact
Grand Prix is a very fun stuff very fun
very aggressive chess there obviously
and
um
Knight G5 is gonna happen I'm worried
about a smothered Checkmate James like
we might see that a knight G5 Knight G5
95. yeah Rook takes E2 there's this
mother Checkmate there it is there it is
so let's go Rook F6 and then just give
it up
yeah let's show the smother Checkmate
Rook takes E2 Knight F7 check King goes
here only move Knight H6 is a double
check so you can't take this Knight the
king is in check from the queen nope
escape to f8 The Bishop's here King goes
here bam take my queen fill the square
Knight F7 is smother Checkmate why would
you be down a queen and a minor piece
but deliver the good so Knight F6 played
by Mustafa omaz the thing the queen can
just safely slide back to C4 and hey
your rook's under attack and Knight F7
check would still lead a smothered mate
even with the Knight being able to
capture on G8 wow that's some cool stuff
here yeah Queen to C4 do we have any
extra moves they say when you finally
gonna look for a better one so I was
looking to get Knight F4 off but
unfortunately Rook takes E1 is check so
we cannot allow that
yeah just safe and sound chess here let
me just bam this rope this is square up
a pawn already so Dimitri colors he's
Landing The Knockout and uh oh there's a
problem though uh for the Croatia
Bulldogs is that on board four Josephine
heinemann she is on her way to winning
this game against Elaine Rovers I mean
this is a vicious attack yeah she's just
cruising on the king side over here
yikes
left work right hook my goodness oh wait
this just allows to Checkmate oh yes
it's me yeah it's just me wait no work
F1 Bishop F1 oh but Knight F2 look at
some other chicken I have to give the
queen oh yikes take them all
yeah beautiful
wow this is a nice game from Josephine
heinemann but unfortunately it's looking
like it might be a little bit too little
too late because the other Bulldogs are
getting it done the Bears need three
wins out of the four games and we look
top right win for the Bears in the works
bottom right win for the Bears wow left
side it's all Bulldogs yeah I saw a
Bulldogs dang that's so close it is
literally so close for the Bears I mean
it was definitely looking like it was
going to be a ball match and the bear
says think again
I think again you're making it very
close uh closer than what we thought it
was going to be and what it looked like
in round two and Michael bezel loses
that game on time but also on the board
let's go to our top left quickly because
this is the game that needs to go the
bears away if they actually have a shot
to tie the match I think the other two
boards will be won by the bears but look
at bugs on Daniel dayoch's clock he has
five seconds remaining he's completely
winning but Knights are tricky pieces so
if he blenders a night Fork suddenly
there's a chance for Bluebell this is
crazy this is this is what we were
talking about right here you could go
down to the wire and then you'd be like
wait who's actually about to take this
who's gonna win Bulldogs only need half
a point that's it yeah eight points
super smart play by by deuts by the way
he is just repeating moves gaining some
time brings his King up Knight F5 your
Rook covers this Pawn uh watch out for
the d-pawn and that could be a runner if
you're not careful right there it is
wait a second Brooks hit there it wasn't
December there's Knight E7 idea so the
King goes back to stop the pawn too
strong is daage yeah he's very strong
especially with no time to as well like
wow
and by the way Dimitri Collins has one
for the Berlin bears and Josephine
heinemann she is about to score Victory
it seems so this game uh will decide the
match and I feel like both on Dash with
his King blockade in the pawn James just
mop up now take all the pawns yeah okay
now he's good to go yeah and this should
do it here man this was tough for blue
bomb being uh the tough the higher
highest rated or number uh the number
one board and is having he just had a
tough a tough tough day in PCL today
yeah he won that game three somehow but
he was uh down a piece against him and
he just take here oh
bring the king back
The Rook blocks the last chance that's
it and that is it
okay so it looks like Bogue Don Daniel
up a full Rook a Matisse Blum nose if he
resigns the match is over so he might as
well lose on the board how many pieces
is he down
coupons
absolutely yeah I'm all of them
and Josephine Hyman won her game so if
there's some kind of accidental
Checkmate and the Mercedes blue one wins
then the Bears tied the match but come
on now let's be real that was that crazy
Mouse slip in the Spanish Maniac shrimps
game so but of course that's not
happening here black winds wow they
haven't won every game I think did he is
he 4-0 today no he hasn't hit one draw
did bugged on Daniel day out but he goes
three and a half out of four and I
quickly want to show that Josephine
heinemann I mean look at the final
position she brought her Queen down to
C1 you take this queen a new one appears
on C1 too much extra material so that
tactical shot that she found over here
would bring her her Knight into the F2
square with the mate that was uh only
way to get out of it was a sacrifice so
great job by her in the fourth round
unfortunately the Bears they got a the
two slow of a start so as we see a 2-2
tie in that final round James great wins
by kolars and heinemann but for the
Bulldogs nice wins for
absolutely the Bulldogs were able to
pull it out here I mean they just had to
keep the composure there because it was
definitely getting close it was getting
scary we didn't know what was going to
happen and the momentum was swinging
into the bear's favor for sure and right
here I mean this could have been very
close to two I mean one extra point the
other way and look this is a different
game right so this is a you know great
job from the Bulldogs impressive just
holding the composure and was able to
clinch the match today yes and we'll
let's look at the overall match score
because it was a close one but when all
of a sudden done it was a win for the
Croatia Bulldogs MVP has to be bardia
the national
also had three and a half points but
that's more expected from a super GM the
youngster from Iran three and a half out
of four James he's got that dog in him
yeah I mean that's like two you know it
feels right now I mean based off the
scores they're like who who Who's 2700
right is it is it uh ardia or is it
bogged in or is it both of them right so
it's scary to have that type of lineup
right there three and a half three and a
half yeah they're gonna be doing big
numbers there they're gonna keep him in
the lineup every week Guardians take it
there for sure shout out to Dimitri
colors for getting three out of four
that's a good performance for him and
just the rest of the team could not get
high on the scoreboard so where does
that leave us after two weeks well some
teams they've found themselves up at the
top and we see from this match it was
Croatia going to wanted one but it's the
yogis the Wizards the tigers with
perfect scores and we have an upcoming
match between the unicorns and the
Knights that will determine the fourth
and final team to reach 2-0
James with that up next man like what do
you see coming
you know it's gonna be very strong chess
here very cool I mean this is more of
the the uh the chest that everybody
knows or you've seen the faces that
you've seen right we got Hikaru coming
up we're about to face uh you know
Hikaru I still have Ray Robinson coming
up as well Sam Shanklin are you familiar
with these players so a lot of you play
a lot of you're going to have some fun
seeing these you know what happens when
your karma gets down and play and then
you've got a big Ray and have a nice day
Mr puzzle Rush himself right so that's
gonna be nice to see I'm excited to cast
this next uh this next match as well
yeah it's gonna be a lot of fun and well
these are the teams that are towards the
top of the standings there are eight who
have struggled somewhat and that
includes the Berlin Bears they lost to
the Croatia Bulldogs the Bulldogs go to
one and one the Bears fall to oh and two
and James their reward and I put that in
their quotes for losing is to play the
St Louis archbishops next week are we
seeing the last of the Berlin bears you
know what we we can't call it here it's
tough to call it because I mean we I
didn't think the St Louis archbishops
was going to do like it's oh two that's
crazy that's great I mean even you know
Charlotte Cobra's strong team everybody
on the team beat is an absolute Beast
right led by Daniel naroditski Daniel
himself right so you know you don't know
what's gonna happen here we can't call
anything anymore we thought we could but
we just got to wait and see
you're right we can't call uh the shots
but the players they let their moves do
the talking and up next is a very
popular matchup between the Gotham
Knights that's led by Levy Gotham chess
Rosman and their first board is Hikaru
Nakamura so they're the biggest chess
YouTuber the biggest chess streamer on a
squad and then they're taking on the
California unicorns and don't count them
out don't overlook the Unicorn Sam
Shanklin Ray Robson Christopher you uh
speaking another puzzle Rush wizard uh
this matchup up ahead James we'll talk
more about it you know after this break
but I can't tell you how excited I am
I'm very excited for of course I forgot
a little Christopher you what to do the
kid oh man he was doing puzzle Russ chat
think about this right you do puzzle
Russ on your computer he does puzzle
Rush 50s right e back to back on an iPad
okay so this is very very very strong
chest you're gonna see today lots of
puzzles lots of fun and a very highly
anticipated matchup coming up next well
I think we have to leave the fans
anticipating it for a few minutes longer
James and I are going to take a break
we'll reset because there is a whole
nother match in the protesting ahead do
not go anywhere congratulations to the
Croatia bulldogs and their 9-7 win over
the Berlin bears but up next all of our
attention is going to be on the Gotham
Knights and the California unicorns we
will be right back for the start of the
second match do not leave your seats
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
chess the weight of a win draw or loss
is all on one's shoulders it's easy to
feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
Catalina luck no super strong player but
way Yi is Unstoppable in the protest
League welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives oh my gosh that was another
sick tactic by our generic icy he sees
everything
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion wait a second oh grishook
is super unhappy my friends it's the
2023 Pro chess League which team can
Rise Above the Rest they won't be able
to do it alone
and we see Hikaru Nakamura he is talking
because he is streaming chatting with
his viewers he is the number one chess
streamer on Twitch and today he is the
board one for the Gotham Knights we'll
see if he can give him the Boost that
they need and Hello everybody welcome
back it hasn't been very long I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me is
feed a master James Canty III James we
had fun in match one but now it's Hikaru
Nakamura and Gotham Knight's time to
shine against the California unicorns
what do you make of this matchup this is
a highly anticipated matchup a lot of
energy a lot of Vibes a lot of streamer
Energy Right YouTube you gotta uh the
twitch guys right you got the superstars
we got the prodigies we got the kids you
got people you heard of honestly this is
a very big fun matchup and I'm excited
to see what chess we get today
and we'll see which of these teams can
leave the week undefeated of both teams
the California unicorns and the Gotham
Knights they won in week one so as we
look at the standings we'll see will the
unicorns or will the knights join the
yogis the Wizards and the tigers that is
the big question as three wins secure
the playoff spots and earlier today we
did see a match between the Berlin Bears
and the St Louis Arch not the St Louis
Arch excuse me and the Croatia Bulldogs
uh the Berlin Bears they dropped to O
out of two the Bulldogs went up to one
out of one one and one and the Bears
will face the St Louis archbishops next
week never a fun reward James yeah never
from a war fight never from reward when
you take a loss especially when it's a
strong team too because you have to face
another strong team these guys are not
slouches it's the pro chess league so
they're going to bring the best lineups
or at least for that day and again it's
about who is good right then today in
this 10 minute two second time control
that we have who's the best right now we
got to see that
well when it comes to fast chess who's
the best it often is Hikaru Nakamura and
well the uh lineup for the Gotham
Knights it's a powerful Squad from top
to bottom uh they're manager and uh Alex
ostrowsky their Captain Gotham chess
Levy Rosman and James ikaru he leads the
way of course but look at how strong
everyone on their team is Bro Look at
that they got the other I mean all the
way down because you got Hikaru you got
Liam lay absolute Beast 227 Hunters on
the same team that's cheating they
cheating bro you have Vladimir you know
feather say that's big fish he really is
a big fish there uh oh vokido I've seen
him online a lot just rampaging through
things Alina's absolutely strong you got
the Bortnick brother we got the other
brother with so I understand they come
in pairs the boarding Squad is just
absolutely crazy Andy Woodward who's a
12 years old International master I
don't even got to say nothing else right
and then the rest of the squad is lit is
Beefy look at the ratings there so this
is a very very very strong team that's
why they already you know are winning
when they won the first match already
yeah
he was not smiling after that first game
uh but then he won three in a row to
lead the team to match Victory and oh
for the California unicorns they also
have an extremely strong team they have
gukesh waiting in the wings he might
play a week when he's not in an
over-the-board tournament but Sam
Shanklin the former U.S champion and
it's Ray Robson right after him so James
when you look at this lineup I mean this
is super strong and well balanced nah
you know what's funny I actually thought
uh you know Gotham nice was cheating I'm
like I got Hikaru like how y'all do this
right but then no they're cheating
California that's a unicorn for real
unicorn it's not real right unicorns
aren't real well this team isn't real
right it's three 2700s on the same team
that's a very beefy lineup they're
trying to make statements in the PCO
this year of course the eoy is there
very strong should be close to 20. I
mean I think he was 27 before if not
he's very close obviously Darius
Schwartz here York Meyer oh my goodness
right you'll hear Sebastian Christensen
he would be with her with Magnus used to
work with Magnus Christopher you the
kids being a foyer that's a women's
champion there and he got Zoe Zoe
Italian there very strong as well so
nice lineup here I mean it's it's again
it's going to come down to who is good
today and then good form that's all it
is yeah Christopher you hiding in the
roster he's the third to last name there
as the team is managed and captained by
the chess Dojo led by David Pruis
coaster kavutski and Jesse cry but for
today's matchup you have to pick a
roster somehow who do you pick when you
have this stacked of a lineup well we
know with the 25 50 average rating cap
per team these are their rosters uh for
ferrosevokidov and nurmanova or the
knights they're new to this week the car
played last and for the Unicorn Sam
Shanklin stepping in Ray Robinson played
last week Christopher you being that
tactical whiz kid and Zoe Tang it's a
teenager on teenager board for battle
between the knights and unicorn
yeah it's just funny it's actually like
you know they brought out two 2700s
today you can do that every week imagine
that every week I'm just gonna place two
big 2700s on the team and that's what
California uniform coins is bringing
today they're like yeah we're gonna
bring out Sam 27 ray27 right Chris okay
it's trying to be 27 basically like you
know strength 27 okay now the kid's
really strong obviously but and then you
have a the the Gotham Knights here of
course Hikaru the only difference you
see here too is in the rating is like a
few points roughly like 20 points or so
besides Hikaru and Shanklin there so you
know it really comes down again to a who
is who is nice right now can I get some
advantages out of the opening there's a
it's it's top heavy three GM's on three
GMS here man there's about to be a lot
of Chess here I'm excited to see what
happens because this is a fire lineup by
both sides yeah we're seeing some love
for the unicorns and for the knights in
the chat let us know who you're rooting
for that's chess sweep saying go
unicorns not sure why the corns are
capitalized maybe that's a twitch
reference I don't understand but here we
see people rooting for the Gotham Knight
but let's remind everybody of what's
about to go down in this brawl between
two of the best teams in the league it
is all play all that means that the
fourth or the teenage they're teenagers
for both sides they will get the face
off against Hikaru Nakamura on Sam
shankman in this 10 minute plus two
second increment rapid time control up
to four rounds we say it every time why
up to four rounds some teams may go on a
tear get to eight and a half points
after only three in which case the match
stops and a winner is proclaimed so with
tie breaks it's eight to eight we will
see a replay of round four but that is
for a later discussion because James we
start with round one and we see the most
lopsided pairings Hikaru Nakamura
outrage Zoe Tang by nearly 600 eBay
classical points and Sam Shanklin down
there for the California unicorns he
outrags his opponent by 550 points so
very lopsided matchups on the top boards
but those middle two James those are
where the X factors we'll see what kind
of form Christopher you Vladimir
ferroseedov and Ray Robson are in yeah
we just got it's all about that form
what you're in right now now of course
even the lower boards there is uh you
know you can't put anything past
anything like Hikaru lost that first one
couldn't even believe it I was like what
you mean he lost how did he was he lost
like how right so if that if that just
happens tends to happen you know again
somewhere that can not of course not are
losing but obviously the lower board is
just stepping up and you see that in
every match in PCL so far we've seen
that the lower matches or even the lower
boards can and are capable of stepping
up against their high rated opposition
so we see a lot of that this could
definitely shake up things in today's
match yeah I just have so many questions
for the chat right will Hikaru be able
to go 4-0 this week I think that's a
question many of his fans I want him to
answer and then will the knights or will
the unicorns win that is a toss-up I
feel like this is a pretty uh balanced
roster for both sides Hikaru Nakamura
being the biggest name on either team
but Zoe Tang she's a teenager playing
for the unicorns uh she is nearly at
2200 feet a player and hey she starts
with D4 so will she be afraid of Hikaru
she has nothing to lose James of course
the car was the favorite but just play
your best chess do not be scared wait
it's not don't be scared at all
especially you know he car would just be
throwing stuff at you and literally
that's what he just did now D4 C5 and E5
so this is uh stuff check baloney type
of stuff it's just like it's just chess
this is what this is like what do you
even call this right now G6 right it's
some type of benoni-ish type position
but you know he's good with these
flexibility moderns against lower rate
of players I remember he said on stream
too he was like why do you play like the
modern and stuff like that and he was
just saying that it's the imbalances
that it creates and like you have like
there's there's going to be a decisive
result most times this is what he was
saying so he goes for another one of
these in the faster time controls here
where it doesn't really call the setup
yet just making pawn moves a lot of pawn
moves so far
and she's recently won the Oregon state
championship thank you chess latte for
that information and right now Zoe's got
to face a bishop H6 maneuver by Hikaru
in the king's Indian the bishop on G7
often stares into its own Pawn so he
wants Bishop H6 get these Bishops off
the board and that frees up the
remaining squares for the other black
pieces so I think this is a perfectly
reasonable start for Zoe you could tell
she's not familiar that's what happens
when you're a teenager you play older
opponents they're more experienced than
you are when you play a car with
Nakamura well he's as experienced as it
gets so it's still completely normal for
her she should just develop that way
when the bishop comes to H6 she could
take it in one turn rather than first
playing Bishop E3 and then taking on H6
just develop the other pieces and I
think that she has a nice looking
position at the opening absolutely nice
position here of course but it is a I
think uh the problem where it really is
just being familiar and comfortable with
the position that she's in I was a fan
of this oh yeah we on the same page
young lady F4 was definitely a month
like just go F4 and like you know F1 and
try to open some lines up and maybe end
up casting but she definitely went for
this but it does weaken the dark squares
drastically as he's trying to highlight
Bishop H6 right E5 now and the D4 Square
could be week two as well but I mean F4
did open the file for us so if we can
eventually give me maybe bishop D3 maybe
a knight to F4 or F3 we cast we'll put
the Rook on the app file actually cast
and queen side doubling on the f file we
have some really good chances actually
um with the F4 move yes showing no fear
of Zoe tang with uh F4 move there and
we'll see what she plays next because
she is spending some time the other
games are beginning let's zoom out for a
moment we of course will come back to
this game but we do have other games
going on as she did swap Bishops on H6
in the top left in the top right we're
getting some kind of sharp Sicilian
between Christopher you and Vladimir
ferrosev and the bottom left I already
can feel James sleeping because we have
a symmetrical structure between volkidov
and Ray Robson not not an exciting game
in the bottom left so let's instead go
to the top right because I feel like
that one is just uh really a fun one
rather than a heat plan is he playing on
the iPad again yeah we need to get Chris
some some hey you know what chess com
Cindy yeah we need to we need to we need
to send some stuff over there Chris I
think he's playing on the iPad again
really he loves to do that he does he
doesn't in fact maybe it's just a fact
of maybe his personal preference right
because I think he's playing on the pad
again which is uh do you know why he
does that James no I do not
he does it because uh it's smaller so he
can play more quickly we need to drag a
mouse across a huge screen when you're
playing bullet chess or in a Time
scramble you're moving more slowly but
an iPad you can make moves much more
quickly the smaller the board is this
guy has figured it out he almost figured
out chess here guys yeah iPad for the
win you know wow so there was an iPad
like that but the kid is very strong at
what is this position how did we even
get here this was a sicilian you said
it uh was assistant let's go back in
time let's bring an analysis board to
show everybody how we got this weird
looking position uh because
it was a sicilian where
uh Knight F6
Acer I love it okay A3 though you don't
see that every day right like that's one
of those moves you're like what you
doing over here Magnus Carlson does it
does that mean that we should do it I
usually say uh let Magnus be Magnus but
E5 playing in the center the Knight
comes to F5 and there are tricks in this
position you may think give me that pawn
on e4 because I'll take your knight next
the Knight says whoop Knight takes G7
after Bishop takes then you take back on
e4 and Black's King will not find true
shelter believe it or not I had a game
on cbr1 like this and I was actually
losing it was like plus six but I ended
up winning because of tactic this is
night or if it's like that but in this
position I played D5 and then but uh if
white goes Bishop G5 which is what I did
F6 and I'm like I'm winning a piece but
I'm not Queen H5
when it's five and they have the king
queen H5 King E7 and then Bishop E3 my
guy
Bishop oh oh my goodness yeah yeah yeah
this is some sick stuff very sick so you
keep you need to be very careful in fact
the line is I think what they went for
it which was D5 instead of Knight takes
B4 so Knight takes E4 is what you is the
trick yeah D5 is the movie you're
supposed to play so we saw the D6 Pawn
go up to D4 and it's a very weird
situation where white has moved
backwards and black has just occupied
the center but if white could establish
a light Square blockade we could see
even the bishop or the Knight coming
into E4 uh that would be nice for white
Christopher you continues to play
quickly allowing a check on e4 and what
in the world are we seeing here you know
what the kid is a tactical wizard so he
definitely is seeing some tactics here
check and maybe you go King D1 he's just
not worried about it I guess in the one
you put the Knight on D2 and The Rook
wow I don't know what there's some
strange stuff oh but he's getting Tempo
I love it the kid is saying I want Tempo
King D1 Knight D2 and Bishop C4 if you
go back to D5 right so you have to go
Queen C6 but if you put the Knight on C6
and you have to move the F4 it's very
strange though this is definitely
strange but the bishop C4 idea I think
is what he wants here this is very
strong
yeah this is some good prep from
Christopher you and that's how you have
to play to take down someone like the
big fish Vladimir fellow save this would
be a huge win for the unicorns I think
the middle two boards are X factors uh
in these lineups because uh Christopher
you and Ray Robson Vladimir ferrosev and
shampid and volkidov it's like pretty
evenly rated between those two squads so
whichever middle two can score more
points because we do expect Sam Shanklin
and Hikaru Nakamura to score on the top
board I feel like those middle two
boards are gonna be what is D3 what is
that
wow what is this
he wants G2 but James you've been
sacking the Jeep on all day all day I'm
not even thinking twice about it Robert
Bishop takes and then think next
yeah it's a rookie one try to get the
Knight out to C3 and you have a D5 and
E4 great squares for the white pieces I
mean this is confusing and by the way
Federal saves out here looking like a
tennis player or something he's got like
that wristband on yeah he's holding his
head here he's looking Ultra athletic
even uh yeah I had to you know I got to
play the kid today so let me get out
make sure I uh exercise right getting
the exercise in the same playing against
Christopher you here is very strong here
but yeah we gotta take this Pawn though
Bishop D3 come on
yeah I think we do and well what I know
we have to do is bring in our special
guest we've got Gotham chess himself
Levy Russman Levy you know we had you on
last week your team ultimately found
success despite hikaru's uh opening game
so tell us man how are you feeling about
the early stages of we too
oh we got to bring that up again Robert
I feel like I feel like every season is
a disappointment and I gotta just go
back to it uh look this week he started
off with also an offbeat line like we
see board one playing board four there's
sometimes uh offbeat opening approaches
but it's looking like Smooth Sailing
he's got double the amount of time he's
got 700 more rating points and this is
kind of like the fun thing about the
protest League when you stack the three
boards uh board four becomes this kind
of funny lopsided matchup uh well he's
taking care of business but listen this
California team is
they're looking quite solid
they are Priceless Levy Levy and a Chevy
baby we got Levy here that guy Mr Levy
Ross what's up baby all right what's up
what's up hey uh by the way uh I was
inspired by the Canty Coe calculation
over everything merch line so we
actually dropped Gotham Knight's Merch
this morning so gothammerch.com we got
the Gotham Knights black and pink fire
uh little hoodie so once you're done
getting your Coe merch you can get the
uh you can get the Gotham Knights merch
too I didn't just come on here to
promote stuff let's talk uh let's talk
uh you know but Levy how come you're not
doing like James you gotta be dripped
out in your own merch right you got to
have a change so you gotta have the cash
so where's all that
so I have the samples coming but there's
a snowstorm in the state that the
warehouse is in so rather than sacrifice
human lives to get my merch I think I'll
get it you know at the same time as the
people I'm one with the people uh but
yeah I mean I would love to you know
have a chain and a notebook and all
sorts of other stuff you know laptop
stickers that's next yeah it's a lot of
stuff back there for you they treat us
well over there love you so glad to have
you on Fourth walk
well while we are you know to chat here
and Bishop takes D3 finally played we
will see Federal save take on G2 uh like
what do we zoom out for a second before
we dive into specifics on any one board
uh Levy as you look across the four
boards here uh what's your initial take
you know early on for your Gotham
Knights
yeah well just in case people are not
aware we did something really
interesting uh as a team we won last
week and then we proceeded to remove
three players from our team like not
permanently but for this week's matchup
we have Hikaru but we don't have Liam we
replace them with feta board three was
replaced with champ seeden and board
four was replaced by alua and I think we
just want to throw out different looks
and sort of see like do we go with the
big stack you know the big three and the
strong board four uh or do we go with
the balanced approach like 24 25 both on
board three and four we saw uh we've
seen Shanghai do that shanghai's team is
terrifying I thought the blitz looked
really good too but Shanghai just uh
just you know just crushed them so
um I'm really interested to see how our
board 4 does today and particularly this
you know her current matchup she seems
to be close on time uh alua and uh I
mean just visually her position looks
quite okay listen I take a 2280 drawing
a 2700 in the first round no problem I
don't know if we can pop over to that
game but I'm really curious to see what
happens there
wow okay so first of all tell us how did
you and Alex ostrowski the team manager
get alua for your squad because uh you
know she's a teenager an up-and-coming
player and with the white piece is love
you I'm liking our position extremely
solid
yeah yeah I mean of course you know
games against 2700s are never over uh
when they're equal when you're better
when they're better like you have to
beat them five times in the same game
um so while Sam is the favorite and just
like Hikaru is the favorite against Zoe
uh it's still curious to see like these
players might not get this kind of
experience to play 2700s ever protest
league is a very unique kind of thing
um we found a Lua
and Alex really found a Lua just by
scouting like which young players were
fitting our average in November of 2022
because that's what the protest league
is based on and a lot of them actually
gained rating like our board three was
40 points lower rated in November so
he's constantly improving too and the
crazy story about alua is I recognized
her name because in 2019 I was in Wei
Fung China for the world Cadet and I was
coaching Rue Yang Yan from the US and
alua got a medal in the girls under 12
and I recognized her name I was like
wait I re and actually my student beat
her but my student lost in the last
round and uh and alua got I think silver
medal so yeah I mean she's just making
improvements in her chess and here she
is you know Gotham Knights board four
playing Sam Shanklin
swinging too E5 is she's actually she's
trying to take it to him here at f file
open up you know like I can smell some
tactics here right you know there's
definitely yeah 94 Rook F1 right
she's a really aggressive player and one
of the major criteria to get a player on
our team was scanning if they've played
myself or if they've played uh Alex our
manager and she actually beat our
manager in title Tuesday so we were like
oh we gotta put her on the team yeah now
that logic does not apply to me because
I beat Hikaru once in my life and I beat
Liam once in my life but we still got
them on the team it was a fluke but I've
never beaten for the same so
funny
criteria and this is impressive by her
like she is not afraid in the slightest
she's just going for Sam's King like I
mean you know you and Alex have spoken
to her of course you said you prepared
against her in the past like I mean what
kind of like chess personality is she
because it seems from what we're seeing
here it doesn't matter what her
opponent's rating is she's just gonna be
playing that forward aggressive chess
yeah that's exactly right and I think I
think it's weird for 2700s to play 500
points down especially when they're
getting attacked like you'll notice
hikaru's game we don't have to pull it
up but his game was kind of like just a
positional grind and an offbeat opening
and his opponent didn't really
capitalize so he's just kind of smooth
sailing but this is very different like
she's just going to take Sam's head off
and if she doesn't make a tactical
blunder
worse comes to worse like these
Sicilians are I think this was a you
know maybe it wasn't but like these
positions just sort of fizzle out and
you know maybe she'll hold the draw but
right we'll see looking like that's what
it's definitely looking like yeah
because if the fact doesn't work here
this could just be okay draw right
because yeah keep playing I think she
playing for two results actually to be
honest here this is like you can't
really it's hard to lose this right you
know but it is still pieces on the board
here but you can lose it obviously but
she definitely has a very good position
and it's very impressive to see from
from a lawyer
system
now we'll see how her nervous system is
right well I I guess actually I mean
part of being a team manager and a
captain is like you don't just focus on
the results you see what's happening in
the game so uh you know have you noticed
that kind of resolve in any player okay
hikara we all know about but any of your
other players like you think sometimes
they're rating or their result is
misleading and you actually feel like
they are undervalued by the rest of the
chess community
yeah for sure like Liam is really
excellent again like you parely am
against anybody 2700 below like he's
he's going to be the favorite which is
not something you can always say some
people have up and down playing Styles
he's sort of very reliable uh you have
um I think Hikaru officially won his
game by the way you also have like
fedesev who is up and down in terms of
his rating but I think uh rapid over the
board he's like 27.50 right
these guys are just super good in this
short format and
um it's a huge asset I mean this entire
league is based on rapid chess and of
course Blitz too if you've got to go to
the tie break but
um
for sure but
that's why we watch because uh I think 2
700 and 2500 is a lot closer than we
think in this league and we've seen that
over and over
yeah you say that and I agree with you
but I'm gonna have a zoom out for a
second because as we look at our four
board scene for you say 2 700 2500 it's
sure they're closer but better save in
the top right that's good for your
Gotham Knights now he has the upper hand
he being the 2700 player to Christopher
who's nearly 2600 and the bottom left
Ray Robson the 2700 player for the
unicorns taking on your 2600 player it
seems advantage 2700s
yeah uh ferisev is looking looking nice
it's a very complex position I I pulled
up
um I I yeah I forgot I'm a little bit
behind you guys
uh yeah shamsidian
uh oh I see yeah I was a little bit
behind he ended up taking on C8 he had a
moment there he could have sacrificed
his Knight on G6 so you're right the
newly minted super GM 2700 get you know
putting in the work I said before the
match I'm I'm not I'm not uh worried
about uh anybody more than I am worried
about Ray Robson like seeing Ray
Robinson in the lineup That guy is like
a no lose machine I mean
yeah he's he's
I don't like seeing him in the lineup so
um
someone's gonna have to stop him by the
way I think a Lua did just blunder in
her game so uh yeah the 2700s uh will
will be shining I think we're C3 yeah
I'm pulling up the the Robson game
against well we have Federal save on
camera but it's against vote kid off
there uh but that Knight takes G6 check
possibility he overlooked it or just
didn't feel comfortable doing it so that
was a missed shot for him but uh looks
like Sam shank let's go actually to that
game because Shanklin now against Lua
she kind of missed a one move tactic and
it happens when you feel like you're
under pressure and her position it did
start to feel like Shanklin was the one
dictating the action
um and sadly or the Gotham Knights she
went Rook A4 and there's a queen in line
with the Rook after Rook takes off Rook
fell after so one little blunder yeah
and that sounds crazy sticking from her
but it's time time definitely got on her
and pressure you playing the 2700 and
like you know you're feeling like I'm
doing well I didn't lose yet then you
get in time trouble with Innocent
she was doing well bro she's doing very
good
that's uh that's exactly right and uh
yeah I mentioned like you can play 28
good moves and then you lose the game
you know it happens right right yeah
that's exactly what happened in this one
yeah that's
[Laughter]
yeah I mean listen boards one and two
for each team might hold it down the
feather save game is is the one that's I
think
uh the most up in the air but he does
have a nice position but it's still very
complicated in two minutes on the clock
yeah Christopher you we were talking
about this uh James and I uh he is just
such a beast in tactical positions uh
the problem for Christopher in the top
right is he's down one pawn and his King
is in the middle of the bull uh Federal
save he doesn't make mistakes and
decisions like this very often not that
I want to commentator's curse him here
real quick but there's a king on E2 and
Black's King is tucked away
I feel like it's crazy that black is
only up a pawn feels like he does
I was feeling the same way I'm saying
this did you say one Pawn
like oh yeah you're right
listen I I am more than capable of
losing this position with black uh you
can like uh Tunnel Vision on you know D3
and you don't ever win it and white
promotes the H Pawn but I I mean yeah E1
looks how do you even like Queen A1
Queen E1 I mean it just looks horrible
yeah Queen before yeah it's actually a
critical point because the last one were
played by ferrosev is actually super
slick he went Bishop A5 allowing this
move Knight C5 this Forks the king and
the rook and if white goes ahead and
grabs it this Queenie one check will be
of all importance in fact he just saw
this all the way through to the Finish
Line it would feel like because that's a
sick variation that's disgusting that's
some 27 that's man we can check this man
bro that's 2700 for real like bro I'm
still looking at it and I I don't fully
understand what the point is King F3
what queen D1 rookie two queen let's
analyze oh there's like Bishop B6 no
there is no
I'm so confused man look at that line
bro I think the King has to go to F3
Queen E1 check Rook comes to E2 take you
know like
I guess just Queen F1 and the king is
how is this oh oh yeah yeah Queen F4
wait what's happening like
a rook
oh my God it's nonsense oh man if I'm
Christopher you I'm just doing it like I
might lose the game but I'm just going
for it he said I'm telling you guys like
like you you can very easily lose this
game you hang mate on B7 you hang Knight
D7 it's uh I don't want to jinx it can I
can I let you guys analyze so I could I
go back and uh and talk with my co-host
back on my channel I'm terrified please
yeah we we can message you there Levy
all right man we'll let you do we don't
want to curse it so we'll let you go
love you we'll have you back later and
it's good to see your Knights back at
everyone loves the nights they're a fan
favorite so we'll see you soon Levy
thanks for joining us buddy later bro
cool guys take care
and that is their captain of the Gotham
Knights he doesn't want any part of this
stream uh James he's like uh oh uh
Christopher you is coming for better
saves King the B7 Pawn the D7 Square
it's messy I agree Christopher you was
coming for you okay he's definitely
coming guys the race will be very very
careful because yeah this is some
tactics here like there's some stuff
Brewing up you also obviously have to
watch out for B7 every time like you
said before but instead of getting very
close to under a minute here but also is
for you already under a minute and 30
second territory two second increment
this is a wild game guys work to Da yeah
and the thing about this from White's
perspective this and I don't see C5
actually protects this D3 Pawn that can
be really important so um Queen E1 check
kingy F3 there's not Rook takes Pawn
because the Knight covers so I feel like
for Christopher he just needs to somehow
make distracting moves tactical
opportunities there aren't too many of
them but maybe move like H4 some kind of
random move
oh yeah oh Knight D7 he wanted to go for
some whoa we have a trade a check here
we go and here we go oh
if you take with the pawn
you lose your queen if you take with the
King you lose your Rook you can't take
he's doing tactics
that was six seconds every day oh my man
gosh
right now everybody now oh free rook
that was sick
oh that was nasty
let's just show that again man we love
the instant replay oh my gosh he gives
up his Rook for the night the queen
takes he gives this check now The Rook
has to go to E2 because of a double
attack here and E4 you can take it with
a pawn but you lose your queen right bam
give me your queen you could take it
with your king but you lose your Rook
with check and you can't take it with
the Rook because that's against the
rules of Chess your king is an empty
that was sick and then with this check
D4 doesn't help because Queen D3 uh
would pick up everything including the
D4 pawn and then some so what a finish
to this game for Vladimir feloussev we
still do have one game in progress as
the Gotham Knights take a 2-1 lead it
will be down to Ray Robson in the bottom
left there was a tactical opportunity
early on in this game that was
overlooked by shamsiden vokidov or just
not chosen but right down to 10 seconds
James we know he's a glutton for time
travel but this is serious time trouble
whoa oh yeah this series here Bishop F1
here okay black completely winning here
yeah he's definitely just winning but I
mean you gotta watch out for the king
yeah A5 was beautiful
yeah that's nice go take this Pawn over
here there'll be Queen E3 and 94. we'll
see a smother Checkmate very likely
against this King
nice little smothered there
you know Ray he lost the game last week
I believe it was against bardia
dineshfar and now in this week he wants
to get off on the right foot and he's
two seconds man you gotta move
wow oh he made that one second on the
clock 1.9 he's he's scaring me yeah he
lives around his time trouble here now
he sees some tattoos Knight H2 is in the
air I mean 92 it's gonna be a queen in
game which that could be difficult here
King has not made it okay Knight H2 is
not playable anymore 93 gotta make a
move yeah now he wins Queen F1 is
pre-movable and that's why resignation
happens just to show you that if you
bring the queen somewhere to defend the
bishop actually no good squares but I
just swap everything off and when this
happens black is up two pawns and easily
when he can't actually stop this one
becoming a queen so good win for Ray
Robson he evens up the match score and
as Levy was telling us James it's wins
on the top two boards for both sides
two boards there I mean two and two look
at that wow it's really about those
other boys there to see what we can have
but uh man two and two even so far this
is what we kind of expected though you
can see it's kind of even match up 27
it's three twenty seven hundreds on one
team and it's 22700s on the other team
everything like the lineups
um so I mean we respected this but lots
of fun lots of tactics and it's still
more chest left I don't have a favorite
I don't know who's gonna win but of
course we gotta uh you know watch more
to see what's gonna happen so excited
for it these two teams are fan favorites
we know that Gotham chess Levy Rosen
leads the Gotham Knights and the chest
Dojo leads the California unicorns but
there is no lead right now it is two to
two so when we come back from this break
we'll see if either side can break away
from the other this is the protest
League this is the Gotham knights in the
California uniform don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you've got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
foreign
[Music]
okay
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
your screen is Sam Shanklin the former
U.S champion and well maybe he'll just
play his games from the other room I
hope he has a wireless mouse because Sam
was on camera but then he decided to pop
off screen yeah of course Mr shank land
himself uh yeah as you see his chair
there probably just as strong as he is
to hold up all that 2500 on him and as
you see this roster here is even
stronger who cats up there looking like
an absolute boss with a big rating of
course India whatever's in the water
over there we need some of that because
you know India is going crazy right so
2700 up there uh Squad is crazy you just
saw ropes into as well Ilya Darius um
York Meyer and everybody else I mean
it's a nasty team you see Chris few
playing today too as well Robert what is
what a team name unicorns are right yeah
the unicorns are fantastic and they're
currently tied two to two with one of
the favorites in the entire league
because the Gotham Knights they're LED
at the top by Hikaru Nakamura and the
big fish Vladimir Federal save I think
both those two are happy that they don't
have to face off against each other but
they will have to face very strong
opponents in the next round because oh
now that Ford Ford first board one is
out of the way you see Hikaru if the
white peace against Christopher you
Christopher you beat Wesley so at the
last U.S Championship he's proven that
he could take down the top dogs so James
as you look Ward 1 and board two gets
white for both sides is it Advantage
Nakamura Federal save is it Advanced
Shanklin Robson who do you like in this
round that's a good question this one
honestly that's tough that's tough Rey
it looks like rage Lewis gonna have some
problems there so you know I'm gonna say
raise a favorite there for sure
Sam's a favorite against him instead of
saying I don't know man that's tough I
think it's whoever wins faster like
that's what it's about here it's like
the top two boards I mean this might be
another two two four four like this
could go all the way to the wire right
now I mean this might be I can't give an
advantage to either one answer the
question I can't I don't know it's just
about who's gonna win faster yeah I
didn't mean to give you a trick question
I do think that these matches are that
even uh the lineups they are quite
similar in terms of Hikaru Nakamura
leading the way for the Gotham Knights
and Sam Shanklin Ray Robson Nakamura and
FEA that's a toss-up the bottom two
boards also pretty evenly matched Hikaru
he gets the white pieces now against
Christopher you and Christopher he may
have lost game one with white against
Vladimir ferrosev but he's a tough
customer James we know he's capable of
taking down a car if akara plays some of
these offbeat lines oh yeah in fact he's
about to play something that he always
plays he's gonna be Knight F3 B3 there's
gonna be some easy Queen's gamut you
know like hey Christopher you definitely
huge respect okay maybe E4 right
something something for real something
you said absolutely huge respect and
hikar is showing that respect by playing
E4 but then it goes back to B3 with
Bishop B2 oh my goodness somebody stop
this man
oh he couldn't help himself bro he
couldn't help himself I mean we like E4
yes hey Karo respect uh yeah he's gonna
play something and then B3 right now
like that was I was not expecting that
one I mean B3 usually goes with Knight
F3 is what he usually does so it's kind
of funny see that though and
Christopher's thinking here because the
nitrate is offered it it may seem to
hurt White's Pawn structure but it opens
up this bishop and this queen back here
so I feel like taking on C3 is not
really what Christopher wants to do he
can play E6 to try to reinforce the
Knight but that gets you into some
trouble with your own double pawns so he
doesn't know what to do James I don't
know what to do either I've never seen
himself the head and you know hikar was
very good at that he likes just playing
chess he gonna I want a position and try
and challenge you when I take you out
you would take you out of what you're
used to and Etc here and this is a great
example of that I mean it also still is
some type of Knight F3 B3 that he is
very very good at 60 win rate you know
um with this system um of the Knight F3
E3 B3 stuff that he likes to play Ninja
Larson or whatever so he plays very good
with this and this is some type of it
it's just he played the E4 upon now so I
think he can make moves quickly here you
can also see this type of uh I think
even Levy recommends this in his um in
his in his first E4 course for about out
the Gotham stuff or E4 New York style
for all the you know Levy fans out there
that actually have his stuff
of course shout out to Big Levy so right
um I think a lot of this looks like that
French has that too as well he has a
French E46 B3 E4 like he just play this
B3 system and you actually play Queen E2
in Castle Queen side it's a very
aggressive thing
I don't know what I'm looking at because
black has now you know but it's able to
capture the pawn D6
um I feel like White's pieces are
weirdly placed the Knight on e4 you like
to centralize your pieces but it's easy
to kick this Knight back with the move
D5 next maybe D4 just shut down this
bishop on B2 and oh I think that white
uh assuming black has these healthy
Knights on C7 C6 and yeah I'm not the
biggest fan of the opening but I think
we've said that so many times where what
is hikar playing what is this opening
and then he just makes it look easy so
yeah what do you think James are you
believing in a car's opening are you
believing in Christopher you he doesn't
seem to be phased at all I'm actually a
fan of uh of what lights doing here I
have myself I actually have I had a
crushing win in like 18 moves against
2400 uh recently actually with Knight F3
B3 so having these type of positions was
very very strong and it's like
flexibility I'm a big fan of options and
flexibility and taking you out of you
know what you're used to that's exactly
what we have here I mean I can go mini
routes I can still go c4d4 I can still
go Queen E2 Castle Queen side I can go
G3 Bishop G2 you know it depends on what
I want based off of what you play and I
I mean I I really like this for white of
course engine likes black here but that
comes with you know obviously Precision
every move has to be super precise to
take advantage of whatever black the
engine is saying here but practical
chances I definitely do like uh the
bishop on B2 it's just a preference of
mine I like do this by just a lot but
you know what do you think Robert
um that's a great question I feel like
uh I like Black's position I just think
that the pawn pushes in the center are
easy here or black so uh you know Hikaru
he has the white pieces his Knight hops
around the G3 I feel like he's just
moving the same piece one two three
times and I know Black's night I mean
right these nights that Knight went from
F6 the D5 to C7 so Black's doing some of
the same but the bishop on B2 the pride
and joy of your position not looking the
happiest yeah not looking unhappiest now
of course uh you can see a lot of this
from the ready too as well where the
bishop gets closed off so you have to
play A3 B4 in those positions but that's
not allowed here so this is like a very
symbiotic you know game of like four
different openings so it's kind of
Blended here into one but the ideas are
still you know the same you have to
develop your pieces we need to figure
out plans where do I put my King worth
by putting his I did like Bishop D3 here
was annoyed by night before four
slightly but we'll see what happens
okay we will indeed see what happens
here just one of four games that are
underway uh every single game matters in
this team format so Hikaru you see the
eval bar against him in the top left but
early on in the battle well it's going
back towards the center so yeah of
course funny yeah plenty of action left
in this and look at the bottom left by
the way a Sam Shanklin with the white
pieces it appears the engine not
approving of his position but I trust
Sam Shanklin over any engine any day
because he is one of the best prepared
players on the planet and the bottom
right that position looks close in the
king's Indian the top right it looks
like a sicilian so let's just dive in to
Sam Shanklin against Shem seeden
volkidov because
um do I believe Sam you you know trust
Sam I Am bought the engine at least at
first glance seems to be liking Black's
position by a little bit yeah this is
probably this looks like a Vienna or
something some type of Vienna maybe a
grenfail but uh yeah maybe grown oh
sorry not Garfield uh Catalan yeah some
type of Bishop G2 Catalan where he took
on C4 and and hailed the pond right
which which makes sense here I think I
have all of Sam's courses that went
through like basically just skimming
through to see what he what he
recommends and he's actually playing
stuff straight out of his he just
dropped the neocatalin course so he's
actually playing stuff right from it
right now so 97 was not that good
apparently so I wonder why what's wrong
with Knight D7 oh but look at this the
you know the engine as it gained its
depth here uh stockfish trying to figure
out what's going on nobody knows uh the
only person that knows seems to be Sam
Shanklin I mean he's moving quickly but
this this decision caused him to think
so either it was a move that's down the
line we'll find out it's bad or Sam's
preparation has ended and I actually can
completely get behind this move this
Knight on E5 has been annoying but I
also think that white can try to push
this Pawn to F5 for bringing up an
analysis board and just to quickly show
that F5 you can't just go ahead and take
this Knight on E5 I know you want to do
that but after Knight takes Pawn takes
your queen is under attack back on d8
and wherever you move your queen it
doesn't matter to me I'm gonna push this
Pawn to F6 and just go after your king
it's just going to be a quick Checkmate
yeah that's mainly I mean 11. easy 11
because you got to throw the engine
moves in there
yeah sacrifice all your pieces just by
the way exactly exactly I I'm guessing
the best move is like G6 you know like
give up this bishop on the Square so not
gonna get the job done and that's why uh
Sam can push forward with F5 black may
just take it though that's the downside
of F5 black has less space you want to
trade some pieces
yeah I didn't consider that I was like
just F5 but it could just take it and
then you'll be like oh wait why did you
take it because you put it there right
so F5 so maybe we go D5
yeah that's another interesting choice
because Knight takes pontics maybe we'll
get D6 in there uh this Pawn on D4 may
lead the charge and go to D6 so
James this is a complicated battle
between Sam Shanklin and shum scene
invokedov and volcanov is from
Uzbekistan uh that country if you don't
know about it you should because they
are the Olympiad gold medalist their
team took gold led by no dearbeck up to
sitarov he is at the upper echelons of
Chess these days but volkidov you see
it's raining at 2568 that was back in
November now he's 2600 plus so Levy was
highlighting him as one of the players
in the world that you look at you're
like okay he's an up-and-comer be very
careful very strong player very very
strong wow they hated that move what is
the move for this
I don't know it makes sense
you know James while we are trying to
figure this out we can bring somebody in
to help us because we do have David
Pruis the captain the unicorns joining
us David always great to see you buddy
welcome from the chess dojo and well how
are you feeling about the pro chess
league and in particular this week
against the knights
yeah likewise Robert's always great to
uh to see you and and hear you
um I think that uh this matchup this
week is going to be extremely close
um a toss-up
um a match that's going to give me a few
heart attacks most likely towards the
end uh in round five or maybe even in
Round in round four or maybe even in
round five so
that that's my general take
five when you say round fives is that is
that me hearing you predicting an 8-8
match tie breaks I I think it's possible
right I'm not I I wouldn't predict it
like it's not more likely than all other
results but it's very possible
yeah I believe the same dear David how
are you feeling today David good to have
you today
yeah uh last week I was I was offline so
I only caught a few snatches of my match
it was much better for my health
um to to miss a couple rounds of the
match
um you know but that match could have
finished eight eight I don't know if you
guys saw it but we we won nine seven but
there was one game where a 2700 could
Queen a pawn and instead he recaptured a
piece and it was like he played a
deflection sack I don't know if anyone
has heard or understood why that
happened I wasn't watching it live but
it makes no sense he could have queened
and the match would have been eight
eight
and vibrates right I was on the call for
that David and we were just in disbelief
um but I mean I'm also trying to figure
out this position it's a Catalan but
it's also a very David pruess like
position a couple pawns have been
sacrificed by Sam Shanklin and now a
piece has been sacrificed by vokito up
here but you'll have three pawns for it
so what do you make of this David
nice uh for volkidov unfortunately but
I'm still you know happily impressed
when he plays some good moves on my
first Allegiance is to chess even over
my team you know so when I see somebody
playing well you know I I got to be
happy for them
um I think Sam's Knight G4 move which I
saw your your engine bar didn't like I
think his intention was to push F5
himself next
um
but vokita of probably very clever
response to play F5 himself and ensure
that he had space to defend his uh his
King side activate the bishop on B7 and
you don't want white to have D4 E4 F4
like all flexible denying your pieces
any squares not only on the fifth rank
but basically anywhere you go on the
sixth rank white can always push and
kick you out so he tries to get some
purchase in the center there create some
squares and it looks like he quickly got
the upper hand that way
yeah and we as we return to the live
position Queen C2 was Sam's last move
and unfortunately for him the Eva bar
continues to sink and I mean this Pawn
can go to D4 and why not isn't that on
B3 maybe the unsung hero of this game it
just yeah that boy is stuck there I mean
right this was not the Catalan or
neocatalini just dropped a course on the
neocataline Sam that is this is not the
position we was looking for out of here
of course we were able to consolidate
the Palm we sack to piece we're getting
it back now I mean maybe not we do have
to move our Queen still but it is uh you
can also I mean there's Queen sacrifices
actually even available taking off C3
and B2 in some cases so this is really
nice for black but I mean it is possible
yeah I mean
the the Knight on B3 white ideally wants
to just play on the king side and play
around the Knight and leave it behind
right and now with vocative sacking a
piece getting this deep Pawn so strong
Sam can't play around that night and uh
so it does become a hero but if I vote
could have had to set that up
yeah he did well I mean this is looking
tough for Sam Shanklin but I want to
give you some better news David so we're
gonna go to our bird's eye view because
some of the games are looking quite
promising for your California unicorns I
see in the uh bottom right Ray Robson
against alua normanova he has an
advantage but I think maybe more
importantly in the top left Christopher
you his position seems to be
advantageous against Hikaru Nakamura so
with all respect to the other players I
think we should go back to our board one
for the knights against board three for
the unicorns and David first of all you
know you've been a Mainstay of the U.S
chess League the pro chess League
seasons pass it's very important to you
I know to have a team from California so
what does it mean to you to see
Christopher you who grew up through the
ranks playing in California and now is a
chance to maybe take down Hikaru
yeah I mean it's really it's really
important to me I I don't know how
everyone I think every manager in every
organization sees its role differently
but I see the role of the unicorns as
not just being like an assortment of
players trying to win a competition it's
also the goal is to you know showcase
California and West Coast talents and to
promote and give them opportunities
right
on
so Chris you I mean
he's somebody who we had on the team
when he was younger right when he wasn't
as good and when it wasn't necessarily
the not necessarily the best strategy
for the team to win to to put him in now
he's so good it's just he's an asset to
the team it's just great that we get to
play a player under 2600 with his skills
right so he's just like a fantastic
asset for us now but it is important for
us to to invest in in players from
around here and give them opportunities
so that they can get better and better
and for that you can generally turn to
our fourth board
um and you'll see what we're what we're
trying to do with giving people
opportunities if Chris you know knocks
off either one of their top dogs here
Nakamura or fedo say of today it'll be
fantastic but it won't even be
a shock to me
um
you know I I don't know how other people
would take it but you know it's not that
I predict he would win against their top
two boards but I think it's totally
plausible at this point
yeah he did beat Wesley so in the U.S
Championship his rating is near 2600 so
of course he has a chance no matter who
he's playing including hit car and
Magnus but David we talk specifics about
this game Christopher you yeah he's down
under two minutes ikaru has that four
and a half minute Mark approximately and
it's a messy position so uh what are
your thoughts about the dynamic we're
seeing on the board
yeah I think
um
I think the position on the board is
super complicated you would rather have
spent two minutes and have eight minutes
left at this point in the game
so I think one of the worst things about
this position is just Chris use clock I
think it's it's too early in the game to
be down under two minutes
um
you know to me it looks like there's
still everything to play for Pawn on H4
hanging
um at the moment
I don't know if Hikaru intends to take
back with the pawn in order to have time
to save his Pawn but it seems like
that's the Outpost for his night so he
gives the pawn
yeah you just give it up just get it
pull you up yeah so follow up Queen H5
or what like he's just I'm sure a
computer wants to take the pawn
as as a human there's all kinds of
things to be afraid of with Knight F5
and Knight C5
well he took away that Knight C5 jump
and I mean there's a knight of five that
looks great but Candace Bishop just yeah
slide back here and defend everything I
feel like Christopher you just yeah I
think like a clean extra Pawn you're
right yeah I think Chris Fields really
actually solid here with this bishop
trade on e4 simplifying the situation
giving up the bishop pair but it just
becomes so clear that he can solidly
defend the D4 Pawn if that D4 Pawn stays
well defended then White's position is
pretty pretty bad
whoa what a move G6 I understand I think
after Bishop F6 it might have been F4
and a g696 E5 and I mean there's
complications it's like strange things
here obviously but I mean I understand
he just wants to like kick some stuff
but F4 yeah he wants that Knight that
makes sense that makes sense that was
strong that was strong bro that was
really strong because F4 E5 was coming
but he just stopped that whole idea
four can't be taken at the end because
of back rank mate so it just seems to
Simply to sort of Peter out yeah
although maybe he'll go for Tech he's
like Queen B6 because the F2 Pawn is
hanging behind that Knight I'm getting
confused looking at this board and I saw
it before hikar was looking off to the
side trying to figure out what to do you
know he's thinking and calculating but I
don't know what to make it yeah is he
talking to is he streaming I hope he
streaming
because otherwise he's just talking to
himself yeah I believe he is streaming
yeah actually I mean he himself has said
that like you know you play worse when
you're streaming just because you're
talking and not fully focused but all
right we see Bishop F6 played instead of
any Queen B6 stuff and Chris we're down
under a minute and I was wait
oh no there's 90 seconds oh and look at
him laughing oh man
oh man
[Music]
yeah oh
David sorry to you know have to watch
that but it seems to just overlooked 97
check and then in a clean extra exchange
for white
yep that's gonna be probably the round
for New York
which
which can happen
um definitely happen
ing
bro he really did nothing you can do
about that
yeah no I just feel like this turned uh
into something sad because Sam Shanklin
also just lost his game against Trump's
he didn't invoke it off so David I I
feel awful like we brought you on we're
you know having a good conversation
you know I I you hate to be the bearer
of bad news
yeah there's nothing where you can
guarantee me that my team is going to do
well
um if you could I would I would come on
every round
[Laughter]
uh well David you know it is always a
pleasure to have you uh we want to give
another shout out to the chess Dojo live
community and for those of you who are
watching right now and don't already
follow the channel you so immediately
great educational and fun content so
Dave we'll let you go and we'll see if
your team can bounce back but thanks as
always for joining us you know everybody
here loves you
all right thanks Robert and James have a
good one
James nothing worse man than bringing on
the team captain or manager and then
seeing their squad just lose all the
games lose right there I mean man that's
tough bro and they have a great Squad I
mean like hey very I mean obviously
you're very proud of the squad I mean
you got three twenty seven hundreds on
the team like whoa there's only a few
2700s in the league like what do you
mean all three of them on one team right
so and two on another team so that's
like five right there 2700 so very
strong team here but right now just not
going their way
now what a nice move Rook B6 if Pawn
takes trade Rooks get an outside pass
pawn it should be a win for Hikaru
Nakamura right now simple stuff so
while he considers the next option is
Christopher you with 10 seconds
remaining on his clock we might just see
him resign
um yeah it's pretty tough game I mean he
played very well up into that point one
blunder that's what it takes
that's what it takes is uh you know
sometimes one move that's how chassis
okay nothing
yeah he's just losing this Pawn over
here the Rooks come to the seventh rank
down goes F7 and there's the game so
it's a win
Jorge garu the pineapple behind him
serving him well
and we see him talking to his community
so he's a happy camper he gets that win
it was a shaky position he was down a
pawn for what looked like minimal
compensation but he was able to get a
nightfork tactic to win so
let's go to our bird's eye view Sam
Shanklin in the bottom left he got
checkmated his King on H3 over there
that was a rough ending in the top right
Federal save
he beats Zoe Tang that's a huge rating
differential so we get it but Louis
normanova she's still fighting for the
Gotham Knights the California unicorns
absolutely require Ray Robinson to win
this game because they have lost all
three games thus far in the round Ray
needs to win yeah Ray needs to win here
and of course it is Big Ray and have a
nice day one of the strongest players on
the planet especially when it comes to
puzzles when you play them you already
just feel like you're gonna blunder
something because he sees more puzzles
than you so it's very scary uh playing
this guy here but you have to give it
ultimate credit for a Lua here who's
like yeah interest says why it's
crushing obviously but at the same time
I mean you know practically speaking
black definitely still has chances
especially having the bishop pair here
but I mean white does have the offside
pass over there so she's playing good
though against Rey because Ray that's
the position you got you're not getting
crushed yeah this is a good game for my
Lord and in the first game she had
really good chances against Sam Shanklin
so I feel like the play it does not
match the score like she has been
playing quite decently as you're saying
uh right now it's a tough position for
her because it's outside passed on uh
will let Rey run to Victory and yeah he
can just kick this queen out of there
saying what are you doing let me just
make a move like 93 because you do not
want to blunder a piece Bishop takes
drags the queen away from this bishop on
F1 so as long as raid does not make a
horrendous blunder he should take this
one it is difficult I mean it's kind of
strange like he doesn't miss many
tactics right unless obviously if time
is low then anyone can miss tatties but
here he has enough time to not make any
tactical blunders he does have the
outside a king can run the A2 for
shelter too as well white is just trying
um to convert you know the pawn
Advantage I have right now
and I feel like there's nowhere for
black to attack right this Pawn is well
defended by the Knight this Pawn on H3
for now defended by the bishop over here
and even if you win this Pawn I mean
that's just way too slow the a pawn is
sprinting to the other side it's just a
our mind is having tunnel vision because
that pawn is just going to the other
side
yeah this is a this is a clean clean one
very clean plan too as well Bishop said
I thought had to be played so now we
have to figure out how do we actually
I mean like we still want a queen but
Bishop C was a very nice way to stop it
practically maybe bishop no that doesn't
work I was gonna play Bishop E2 yeah
just push it anyway why not there should
be two Bishop G4 is the idea
just kind of play the game there
risk-free E3 okay H3 it's under attack
but you don't want to capture it because
that does allow the pawn to get all the
way up to A6 which black cannot afford
problem is this Knight is not in the
game maybe it's gonna come around this
way that could give some hope but Ray
look at him it's too strong yeah
the in-game is completely winning for
why I'm up the pawn here I mean you know
your pieces aren't the greatest here I
totally understand Queenie two is a
beautiful move we have four not trading
100 correct Knight B5 just attack things
right makes sense
going for this C7 pawn and it this
Knight G5 came off to E4 but C7 does
feel a little bit more important uh and
he doesn't give up E4 is Bishop G2
yeah I don't want to give you any kind
of counter play here you know seven
probably
F7 and then what is next
yeah it's getting defensive uh queen of
seven does protect that pawn over there
maybe there's Knight A7 at some moment
but Queen oh watch out I didn't even see
this Knight was hanging I was like what
is Queen G3 that Knight is loose over
here easy to blunder always ask what are
they doing right that's the problem if
you don't ask whether are you doing you
won't see it and he saw it King A2 take
on H3 but then wait she fighting
man come on a little out here fighting
yeah it's okay the engine's like yeah
this is over but like the way yeah that
this is over it's not that much right
it's not like oh oh crap
oh she's really fighting here
wait but James watch out because the H
Pawn for black could play a big role in
this game if this bishop gets out the
way and some of the H Pawn gets going
this could be a problem in the future
for Rey Who's down to about 30 seconds
that girl playing chess she playing
chess right now okay she's playing some
real chess
great play by her at the moment and what
does Rey even do here he doesn't see an
easy move you can bring your knight back
but going the wrong direction and how do
you kick this bishop out of here you
don't I was thinking the same thing I
was trying to try to get some type of
Knight C5 in but my queen needs to get
the F6 or like on the third rank on the
sixth rank which is difficult to do that
night A1 that's some super GM stuff
Knight A1 where's that going Knight C2
A3 it's going to A3 I think what or even
F5 Knight A1 what a move this was under
attacks the queen slid back I think that
for black you got to push this Pawn she
won Bishop G7 to Shield her King but I
think you need to push this part of the
board at some moment
this might be oh wow engine hated that
move I wonder why right Queen d8 oh I
don't understand
okay yeah
exactly now Knight A3 probably but you
can repeat oh he goes up here he wants
Checkmate yeah you're going for easy
whoa he don't care about none of that oh
man big Ray and have a nice day is it
gonna work
oh did you hang a pawn is that pawn in
Port Queen takes E4 it's A6 the Knight
on E3 defends D5 that's really important
here because you can't get the second
pawn and then the white Pawn promotes
sheesh yeah the problem with Rey is like
he got too many tactics like after like
you hit me and that's what that was so
good that was so good to be able to
convert or at least get to this position
now from where it is for right now now
the queen is the worst block hater when
it comes to the Past pawns here worst
black hater it's gonna have to sit there
as it's over now yeah very simple plan
to get the queen to be seven four white
and now a7s the queen went out the way
and it's going to be a win for Ray
Robson uh that was shaky at some moments
but I guess for Robson he never felt
like this is a problem is that I feel
like he's got peanut butter in the
background over there uh maybe some
crackers he'd be snacking they over
there eating okay look he got two you
see the peanut butter behind the peanut
butter you got the red the Red Cap and
the blue one you know I mean right
behind you so I I want the red now I
want the crunchy
and he got both of them back there and
the premium crackers I see them hey
James he wants it all and he wants it
now he has both creamy and crunchy
peanut butter he also just scored for
the California unicorns Ray Robson the
super Grandmaster from the United States
is the only person to win or the Unicorn
because look at the left side I see one
in the column for Nakamura that'll save
and fokitov that was a monster score for
the night
scary if they keep that up you know what
I mean like there's about to be another
mix up here if they keep that up this is
gonna be over in the next round now of
course we you know Ray has to strike
back Chris has to strike back Shanklin
had a bad game there but you know they
can heat up too as well but if they stay
in the right form as Gotham is right now
got some nice this is uh this could be
uh blowout in the next round which we
don't want to see
and we actually see the difference right
some seed and vokidov took down Shanklin
if that result had gone the other way it
would still be a tie so a vokita of
maybe one of the heroes for the knights
taking down the top board for the
unicorns uh but it's going to be an epic
match and speaking of Heroes speaking of
Epic Luca doncic four-time NBA All-Star
he has officially launched his meta
human Luke AI onto the chess scene for a
limited time you can challenge Lucas AI
sidekick and watch it grow stronger with
experience will be enough for Luke AI to
secure victory in the computer Chess
Championship that much is up to you use
the command Luca in chat to play now
James before we go to break should we
kind of hit that command type in Luca
and go play that bot real quick yeah we
could probably play that ball real quick
and then I'll hit him on Twitter pop bro
I beat you back come to the stream for
lessons right that's exactly what we're
going to do get him on stream chat of
course so make sure you put that button
you said man Luke I think it's in the
chat so yeah we're ready for it all
right well we'll see if the chat is
ready first to take on the Luca bot then
to come back and watch the Gotham
Knights and the California unicorns go
play go have a little bit of fun but in
a few minutes we will be back for the
third round of action here in the
protest League
[Music]
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click log in scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's gonna pull
positions from the games you've played
on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
catering the luck no super strong player
but way Yi is Unstoppable in the protest
League welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives oh my gosh that was another
sick tactic by Argent Eric icy he sees
everything
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion wait a second uh-oh is
super unhappy my friends it's the 2023
Pro chess League which team can Rise
Above the Rest they won't be able to do
it alone
it's a chair stream for Hikaru Nakamura
you recognize the pineapple and that
looks like Snoopy on the Shelf James he
has been leading the charge for the
Gotham Knights Levy rosin picked up the
feed rated world number seven the
five-time U.S chess champion the
reigning five-time speed chess champion
the reigning world Fisher random chess
champion oh my gosh how many times I
gotta say reigning James I mean uh a
little rainy you know I remember when we
was in cgc uh Jessica Championship I was
like hey so when you you fresh off this
world championship that you wanted
Fisher random do I have to refer to you
as Mr world champion when I talk to you
he's like no you're good I was like all
right cool because I was going to do it
but like I ain't going to though so like
but of course he's reigning right Rainey
is the accolades where I speak for
themselves the man is a monster right
you know he's a two out of two today
right and he's also one of the strongest
on the planet we all know him right and
what he does I mean man speaks for
himself right chess speaks for itself
that's right so it's say Carl man we
love him yeah his car is a beast and
he's leading the way right now for the
Gotham Knights he has two out of two but
so does Vladimir fedo save and
shamsidian vokidov chipping in with that
crucial victory over Sam Shanklin so as
we go into the third round of action
Hikaru and ferrosev they get the black
pieces this is super GM on super GM Ray
Robson White against a card Nakamura
what is this the U.S Chess Championship
and then Sam Shanklin White against
Vladimir fedosev so James let's break it
down would you rather have white with
the super GMS or white as the Gotham
Knights do on the bottom two boards in
these lopsided matchups you know what I
would actually take uh Gotham here again
with the bottom at the uh the white with
the bottom two boys but Christopher you
is like you know
Christopher's down here so you know what
we're gonna have to change that in fact
I'm gonna change that because I didn't
see Christopher you at the bottom there
that's scary when Christopher used at
the bottom so we have Ray Robson Ray
Robson and Sam Shanklin so I think I'm
actually going to go with uh the
California unicorns in this one because
they both have white
people have white here and against the
strong players so I think I'm gonna go
with that
okay Christopher you was playing a game
of Blitz during the break he didn't get
our memo that he was supposed to play
the Luca bot but instead he was just
playing Blitz against a grand master so
he has no rest he just wants to keep up
the chest and speaking of chess players
we have Ray Robson classical rating
above 2700 that was a recent recent
accomplishment for him taking on Hikaru
Nakamura the five-time U.S Champion the
world Fisher random champion and the
streaming sensation so James we have
liftoff we have C4 by Ray Knight of six
by icaro I don't think his car is going
to be playing sketchy openings this time
around not especially not against Ray
Ray is a tactician I mean even like he
beat he outscores Hikaru right in
Puzzles like literally he beats everyone
when it comes to tactics and positions
so if you have a position that is
tactically inclined and you have
problems there or you notice your worst
you can also count on rate on finding
the right things and here Hikaru he's
just on this strange kick like look at
the this opening look at this Robert
what is this I'm not sure because if you
want to play B5 can't white just play
Knight C3 develop naturally and stop
this move because two of your pieces
will attack it I
I don't know man this feels a little bit
too much against someone like Ray Robson
yeah he literally doesn't care that's
what uh he just he literally doesn't
care we're just starting to see that now
like Knight F6 and an A6 I mean I love
the flexibility aspect but then again
like bro what on Earth is this it's just
just moves he's just playing chat once
again can he turn this into King's
Indian somehow and he's going to do that
Bishop G7 castle and sometimes A6 is a
useful move other times you want to put
your knight on A6 and play C5 so Rey I
mean the guy has played at the top level
for a long time now he's not afraid of
Icarus offbeat opening just play normal
moves Don't Be Afraid right as we have a
king's Indian by transposition but with
A6 help us or hurt us it depends on what
we won what we're looking for out of
this position because usually we would
like to keep obviously Knight A6 idea
alive to play Knight C5 if we get C5 in
or E5 and that is he plays Bishop G4
here steel
um not showing all the cards yet usually
you have 97 E5 which is going to happen
after a trade on F3 eventually
interesting very interesting Play Just
Like play something strange but he
avoided a lot of different things that
could have happened in the king's Indian
if he would have went straight King's
India
yeah so Bishop G4 I think the tempting
move is H3 but black is already showing
that it might want to take on F3 so why
a force their hand uh Bishop E3 is
standard maybe Queen D2 to follow
especially at black castles we may get
his Bishop all the way out to the H6
square trade off this important you know
keto piece which does defend the king
side so uh while Rey continues to sit
and think he finally has made his move
his car will respond shortly let's look
at some of our other boards because
every single game every single round
equal of importance whether hecar wins
or not that's worth one point and
weather say Zoe Tang the board for the
California unicorns if she could upset
Grandmaster
that would be huge for their chances uh
but that's early stages in that game so
James I love myself a close Sicilian I
think we might have to uh pick that game
because uh Zoe she just plops her Knight
in the center and she is just saying
that I'm gonna develop normally jump
seeden's trying to create Chaos on the
board from an early stage but she is not
going to be deterred
yeah oh this is a queen of three this
looks like Goldman variation Carol Khan
but there's not at all I mean like
that's just the move that you have from
literally the same like the knights on
C3 Bishop C4 Queen F3 E4 and the
Goldman's Carol Khan is so crazy but
this is uh this is pretty sweet it's
pretty sweet I like what white and white
has going on here I mean you do you are
hitting F7 you could have 92 D3 and you
also play H3 G4 move the queen to G2
play F4 are you Castle Queen inside you
find a way to do it right and you'll see
this in all Sicilians here so it's
pretty fun I like it from one yeah it's
you see in the bottom left that black
can take a knight on C3 but they get
checkmated one turn because the queen on
F3 the bishop on C4 they're lined up
against this Pawn on F7 so this is a
known opening uh it's one that Zoe has
to be careful in because that's our
Knight H6 you defend this Checkmate
threat but oftentimes white makes move
D3 please just go ahead take my knight
you have Bishop takes H6 to follow so
just really really careful in these
variations from the black side and after
queen of three she is still thinking E6
is also not the best move because the
Knight hops the B5 and around to the D6
Square you're just creating too many
holes in the position absolutely in fact
uh Roman jinji has really has a very
good saying that you should not be
playing E6 and G6 depending on you know
the Sicilian you're playing but the
problem with that is because the bishop
has to choose a diagonal so as Robert
pointed out with Knight B5 to D6 the
bishop should be on f8 there but then it
should be on G7 because you play G6 so
it's a problem having this you have to
choose what to do with the bishop here
in certain cases you can't play E6 but
you need to immediately play D5
um afterwards to take care of the D6
Square which the queen does a good job
of that so it's very important to
understand E6 on the board though E6 and
G6 has been played generally that's bad
and iv5 played immediately wow
yeah that night on B5 May hop in the D6
square and if black plays the move D6
herself the queen on F3 often slides all
the way across the board to A3 so it's
scary Terror territory for the young Zoe
Tang that's what happens when you're
growing chess player or D6 Queen A3 oh
gosh we might see this here it comes
1983.3 you gotta go Bishop f8 which is
ridiculous right and this is what you
know a perfect example of not of why you
shouldn't be playing E6 and G6 or what
could go what could go wrong when you
play E6 G6 right not that you can't do
it it's just what goes wrong and this is
exactly what's going on right now Bishop
to f8 is like your only move in this
position maybe you try King E7 maybe
that's playable maybe I mean that's a
crazy move you can't Castle obviously
you're at the hand Castle but King seven
is is a huge concession
yeah King E7 just to show that C3 is the
move for whites open up the center of
the board there's a king that is stuck
in the center that's not good and Bishop
E5 would appear to be the way to keep
both d uh four and D6 protected with
Bishop E5 does not work out because when
white plays the move D3 the next move is
F4 and your Bishop is just caught here
it's gonna be Kickback no matter what
and of course the A6 doesn't actually
threaten the Knight because the Rook is
loose back here on A8 so it's uh F4
would be just over so let's uh maybe
step away from this one just because Zoe
she's in some trouble here she might
have to play bishop f8 and give up the
D4 upon but let's look at the other
games because all four are in session uh
Hikaru well what is that Knight doing on
B7 the top left
let me see whoa that's he think cattle
this night you're supposed to go with
the Bishops what do you put tonight he
think cuddling Knights
he said he don't care about none of that
yeah what's going on over there like why
is there a night back here on B7 it
looks like Rey's last one was B4 and
then I had to drop back to B7 but this
looks like a clear advantage to my eyes
for what you have so much more space you
have the pair of Bishops
James I like it for Robson yeah in in
the later years I mean or at least 2022
2023 King's Indian I mean and even
checking the database it's not been
scoring well it is not this going well
it's been a lot of time a member Kings
Indian player be my first GM over the
board with kid love it absolutely love
King's Indian everybody does right but
of course it's just not scoring well
these days it is just not you're not
getting the positions you want like
nobody plays Mario Plata and stuff like
that anymore so it's very difficult to
get to King's Indian stuff that we're
looking for here white just has a stable
Advantage with a thin kettled Knight on
B7 now you are playing Hikaru Nakamura
at the same time if you have an
advantage but you have to convert this
here and if anyone can do it it is Ray
yeah Rey is not afraid of a car they
played so many times I keep saying that
but it's true when you get that
experience playing against a car in the
U.S championships year after year uh
when hikar was playing them every single
year now he of course mainly is
streaming and then choosing his
tournaments as they fit his schedule but
you know Rey is just pushing his pawns
forward there look at these pawns here
yeah it's gonna be a rook to D1 maybe
there's been E5 maybe there's gonna be
an F5 a white can choose his path
forward and his Knight on B7 is a donkey
I mean he can't get out of there it's
just that's all it's doing right you
know what I mean that piece is really
bad and we have a very easy plan I mean
easy plans we have all kinds of uh
options we can double the Rooks on the D
file put one Rook on the D Paul Play
Bishop F3 and then play E5 highlighting
the fact that the Queen's on the D file
and you know we also have the bishop on
the strong diagonal that's why you play
Queen C7 I mean he prophylactic for real
all the way get the Queen off of there
and defend the B7 Knight at the same
time
and he might try something like Knight
d8 Knight C6 get the Knight to D4 and
Ray says what was that where was your
night going hey Robert yeah that's what
I thought that's what I thought yeah no
no C6 Square for you and if you take the
Knight will likely take back here and
then hit the queen put more pressure on
this pawn and protect a3c closes down
the queen side does Hikaru the side that
controls the pawn breaks is the side
with the advantage guess who it's Rey
who at some point can push these pawns
forward maybe Rook a D1 there's no risk
in this position I like it for the
California unicorn sport too absolutely
Ray Robinson is just doing his thing he
has to go in here he has to strike you
know he's one of the high rated players
here Along With Sam and he just got to
score my points I gotta do what I gotta
do I don't care who it is and I'm gonna
play great chess and play the pieces in
front of me right now and that's what
he's doing great spatial Advantage I
mean engine agrees two as well Black's
just kind of miserable especially again
with the Knight on B7 as a quote that
says one bad piece you know you can have
a very bad position now of course that
is a long shot you can have a great
position with a bad piece but that Beast
is very bad as you see he's trying to
reroute it to F7 you see this a lot like
night or Sicilians the positional ones
with Bishop on E2 you can end up
rerouting from A5 all the way around to
F7 and you play something like E5 or
even put the Knight on H6 and go to G4
so there are things that you can do here
but he he's trying to make the best of
this position him being Hikaru here and
Ray trying to close it
if I'm right I'm playing Connect Four
then G4 H4 and just throwing everything
forward yeah everything you know the
king is safe back on G1 but Ray he is
spending a lot of time but for the
California unicorns it's not just about
this game let's hop on over to our
bird's eye view because the other games
are equally interesting we see in the
bottom left for Zoe Tang she's down a
pawn and she's just going to be in big
trouble the D6 Pawn is targeted by all
of White's pieces so I think she's going
to suffer a third straight defeat but on
the right side Christopher you with the
black pieces bottom right he's doing
great against alua normanova and the top
right it looks like Advantage Sam
Shanklin on the clock and on the board
so we see in the top left by the way G4
played by Robson he continues to press
forward but let's go to Shanklin let's
go to Shanklin and fedosev because James
we know those players extremely well and
I think that Sam Shanklin his pieces are
enjoying great squares against his super
gym upon there's the F5 square there's
this bishop unbeat the Bishops whoa in
the Knight F5 I mean if I'm first glance
just so win already now of course engine
is like oh yeah it's equal of course you
find all the defensive moves but as a
human I mean I'm already looking at
Knight H6 but of course it doesn't work
because king of f8 but I mean I'm
already looking at it it's the fact that
the options are there is the problem
options yes that I have now look at this
a bishop just you know getting safe it's
not it almost works just to show a quick
line the Knight takes H6 check Pawn
takes Queen G4 check only doesn't work
because both of Black's pieces cover the
G7 square there's also queen of G5 which
I'm only now just noticing but my point
was going to be that black has enough
Defenders to safeguard the King on the
side of the board so Knight H6 sadly or
Shanklin not there just yet what's an
alternative James because D5 is
threatened all right
oh but then it's still that doesn't work
because he has Queen G5 yeah that whole
Queen G5 thing is so annoying I was
going to play D6 but in 96 Knight H6
take Queen G4 Queen G5 and GG and you
just lost a piece there hmm that's tough
that's tight that pawn is hanging out if
I say queen G4 is the only other move
like Queen G4 and then put the Rook on
D1 but he has Queen D5 there so you
gotta be careful first off let's see
what he does he gets crazy for maybe
King h8 no that's stupid not H6 right so
what do you do like Knight h86 on tap
right now maybe he takes on D5 anyway
Queen G5 that's also possible over here
again stupidly Queen G5 says
bro I feel like you know the queen trade
doesn't solve all the problems first of
all and second of all the queen could
have gone to evil
oh whoa you got him you have lost your
absolute on National Television like
this wow
um
wow can you get away with that I guess
you can because I guess how do I do it
uh it doesn't work it doesn't work geez
six is insane I'm gonna say I'm just
showing off here Sam went into the think
tank I would too wow G6 so can I not go
H4 here h40 between D5
now
wow
oh my goodness he is so strong better
say if you have to I mean look I'm not
even gonna lie you underestimate how
strong this guy is like that is a move
I see I see like five different moves
that look good for white I don't know
Rook D1 Rook E1 even Knight E3 a simple
Retreat to defend the pawn comes to mind
93 yeah I actually like D6 in a sack on
H6 and G6 or you're just going for it
all I'm just like don't care about life
right
D6 96 986 Bishop H6 Bishop G6 fg6 Queen
G6 I'm like it's a nasty line
check everything you know what I mean
but obviously he doesn't have to take
but me this is very Wicked but he has
Queen G5 once again Queen G5 is the move
of the day every time every time so he
drops back with 93 the Knight came up to
F6 uh that Orcs the queen and this Pawn
so is that the end of the world like if
black wins this Pawn uh extra material
or federal save but Sam has actually
been tricky he said please take and then
walk into this pin down here
okay he just walked into the bin here
takes takes Queen at wait a second oh
yeah Bishop for you right just Bishop
before immediately so he plays Bishop G7
man fantasy is so strong bro to be able
to play G6 and now both the Bishops are
fin Kettle here now we're able to deal
with the pawn on D5 that was impressive
that was very impressive because G6
looked like a move that you cannot play
and I guess you know lesson in here to
learn here Chad is like you can play you
know look at the moves that you think
you can't play right you know recheck
them recheck them G6 was a beautiful
move
G6 was awesome and it's such a scary
move to make but that was a good one and
now the question is can this Pawn D5 be
picked up I think I know the answer
because I see the evaluation bar at
minus one that'll save does not have
that luxury Knight takes D5 it looks
terrible uh because if you take on G7
and automatically play King takes then
Bishop E4 wins the game there are pins
left and right but that's the thing
about Chess you don't just have to take
back there's Knight takes E3 inter mezzo
if you take the bishop you'll lose the
Rook if you take the Knight just King
takes G7 black steals a pawn and with
Queen G5 the move of the day coming next
it should be a good opportunity
it's now down to two minutes for him man
he's looking good really struggling on
the clock considering how complicated
the position is I just want to point out
that uh Shem seed and vokidov did beat
Zoe tank so board three for the knights
did defeat board four for the unicorns
and we'll see how the other games go and
whoa now come more we I think we have to
go away from here even though we have a
wild game in this one Nakamura and
Robson things have changed in that one
and right down to a minute on his clock
right now to a minute let's see what we
have on the board and Hikaru with the
facial expressions D5 whoa captures
takes F4 whoa bro chill chill out chill
out relax okay
what happened
no move yet raise thinking but he's down
whoa relax
this is crazy Rick F4 is nuts here
uh what is white smoke King G2 is
definitely possible here
let's get out of the Knight D5
I think only six oh shoot and just
Knight D5 is very there might be like a
take and like a sack I'm too confused is
there like a rook oh my goodness there
was Rook G4 Bishop G4 Queen G3 I think
that's probably why he wasn't going for
it and you can take on E3 too like
there's so many things hanging after
that whole thing which is why I think 92
makes sense because it covers the G3
Square
yes you can't stack on G4 anymore that's
sick
yeah sorry just the queen to G3 was a
big threat in many different variations
so Knight E2 back it car up three
minutes on the clock right down to 33
seconds and the eval bar now isn't a
car's favor so this could get out of
hand for the unicorns I mean Ray needs
to survive this game if you can win it
that would be huge but he at least needs
to try to make a draw here because
otherwise the Gotham Knights are leaping
out to such a huge lead man this is
crazy bro if you have a lot of time you
can figure this out but I mean okay so
since we down this Rabbit Hole here
maybe it's Rook f395
and just keep going and just keep
attacking everything but I mean actually
yeah if 395 is definitely possible you
can also sack it back take the exchange
back there this is chaos and it's not
enough time three minutes is not enough
time to figure out what is going on
right now and what Hikaru should do
based off of obviously the engine saying
blacks better here now you know both
players are like what is going on who we
don't know who's winning white thinks
he's winning Black Friday okay
let's bring up and now support very
quickly because I understand the mistake
that a car made it wasn't the initial
sacrifice in F3 but I think after 95 the
rook and the pawn are under attack so
The Rook has to be protected and after
Knight takes Rook takes you think okay I
have to move my Bishop here Bishop takes
there Queen takes there's a pin here
this does not look good for black from a
distance with the Rook barreling towards
the black king but instead maybe there's
E5 and this position is still hard to
assess but black according to the
engines is better so the engines you
know they make it seem easy it is is not
but I think that in this position the
King on G8 the light square is being
vulnerable I'm worried for Ray Robson
the engine move was Rook F3 though it
was Rook F3 yes let's go let's go let's
go one for the Jedi come on chat one for
the Jedi that's right all the Jedi in
the chat forget three that was nice so
it gives people to move in the 95 for
the for the follow-up this one is a very
difficult to oh look at that Bishop on
A1 bro Queen B2 and what do you do right
like whoa I'm just gonna be there for a
long time constant pressure and all kind
of tactics
King H1 to the corner he goes Queen
takes A3 takes away the B2 and C3
squares from the queen D4 already off
limits and it threatened the bishop 103.
Dirty Dog you yeah he didn't take on A3
that was so annoying Queen takes A3 gets
rid of every whoa what is this
three seconds right he's gotta go two
seconds he takes the Knight and it takes
a knife uh he is really unhappy about
his decision there you can tell I mean
he knew he had a win somewhere in that
position instead we see liquidation and
James this should be a draw now with all
the pieces coming off the board this is
the problem
oh
chill everybody hold on Hikaru does it
again
oh my gosh James how does it do it every
single time it's a magician it's scary
looking at Ray's face he understands he
understands and he loses a piece and
Hikaru is just cheese it you know
laughing he just jeezing like you know I
did it again I did it again oh it's man
it's so bad right
oh man that's great it is me
I'm not in the head
and Ray can't believe it but Hikaru
Nakamura is like that's how it's done
I'm gonna lead the knights we go
jousting I'm the only Knight here and we
see hikar knock more explaining to his
community what just happened Rey cannot
believe it I mean he just had the upper
hand but he had no time so as we look to
the remaining boards it looks like Sam
Shanklin and Vladimir fetto savings are
going to opposite colored Bishop
position and then the bottom right
Christopher you is in charge he's up I
think two pawns against Lua nirmanova so
let's go to the game that still is
combative here better save down to just
20 seconds on this clock but James the
unicorns they need this game desperately
yeah I mean when you put desperate and
like need this game like in the same
sentence for the unicorns in this
position it's gonna be hard especially
looking at feather say it right
obviously called the Bishops here okay
we take take I mean you gonna need a
real fatal blunder for this one to be
done like free to win this one it's not
happening it doesn't look like it's
gonna happen if anything black could
even you know uh King isn't a little bit
active and we can also go to the uh the
second rank if possible
so this looks like a pretty standard
split of the point because opposite
colored Bishops you would need somehow
to get your bishop and your Rook very
active but as soon as the bishop slides
back The Rook will take care of the
square here
yeah this is a great chest I mean
obviously like it you know if this
wasn't for you know a team like you have
if this wasn't a must win then uh it's
fine with a draw I mean hey for to say
it was an absolute B look at his rating
bro in the draw by agreement right
it is what it is you can't get anything
out
oh and I mean after the Knight capture
on D5 it seemed like Federal save was
never in trouble from there so one game
is remaining it is the board three for
the unicorns against board four of the
Gotham Knights but that game just ended
it was a win for Christopher you on time
on the board so he gets it done here
rookie two final move kick the Knight
out of there down goes B2 so Christopher
you
I mean he is the only player for the
unicorns to score in this round and well
he could be happy about his game James
the team score is out of control in
favor of the Gotham Knights yeah I
figured it would have if I was like if
they don't bounce back if they can't
swing and like really just Strike Back
in the next round like we saw in the
previous match then you know this this
could be out this could get out of hand
and of course it is starting to look
like that now it's there like a half
point or a point of weight I'm actually
closing this thing out here now things
are still possible but they need to win
all four games in the next round is that
right
uh yeah they well then you get three and
a half out of four just to tie this
match but if California sweeps somehow
then they actually take the match but
look at this Hikaru three out of three
better save two and a half out of three
and vokito with two himself I mean
they're just a top heavy lineup right
now yeah definitely top heavy lineup and
of course as you see it's starting to
level out here Hikaru has some positions
where he was definitely worth seeing but
he was just able to not buckle and keep
the composure under the pressure and the
time pressure that he was putting on to
his opponents there it's very difficult
but you know we still got one uh round
left here and it looks like Gotham
Knights might be closing this one now
yeah they're well on their way to match
Victory we'll see if they can secure it
we'll have to find out in a few minutes
it is the Gotham Knights leading sevenf
four and a half over the California
unicorns but we have a former U.S
Champion Sam Shanklin trying to defeat
the former five-time U.S Champion nakara
Nakamura let's see what happens in just
a few stay tuned everybody we'll be
right back
I don't think about during the games but
I certainly like do think about how like
few African-Americans there are like the
top level so I try to do my best to
to motivate more people like us to
give it a try and hopefully succeed
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Knights make their way towards overall
match Victory against the California
unicorns we want to remind everybody
that this is an elimination Swiss three
victories for your team you make the
playoffs three losses you're out of
there and teams with the same record
will face each other a week after week
so James your captain your Garden State
pastors won this past week how important
is it for the Gotham Knights to put this
match away and get that much closer to
the playoffs I mean hey this win is very
close is here as soon as we win we work
on the next one and then try to make it
to the playoffs here which is huge I
mean three wins that's it and Gotham
Knights are very close to closing it
right now so they just need to stay
focused but also California unicorns
still have chances and shots to do it is
a long shot and the percentage is there
but it's very difficult to come back
here but if I am the Gotham Knights I'm
not celebrating yet I just need to
continue get the job done I got a job to
do let's get it done right now
they've been getting it done on the top
boards thus far the Gotham Knight's lead
seven out four and a half Hikaru with a
perfect score and better save invokido
they're also bolstering that Squad and
you look at the other side of things the
unicorns Ray Robson started two out of
two but just lost that Heartbreaker to
Nakamura Shanklin and Christopher you
you could just see how they compare to
the board 1 and board three for the
other Squad so as we get Ford versus
Ford final round action it's the award
one versus one two verse two three verse
3 and 4 verse four James have asked me
this every round
you like the match-up or the unicorns or
for the knights ignoring the fact that
the knights only need one point to win
it uh ignoring the fact I'm still
actually gonna go with uh the Gotham
Knights there
um I think that a Carl fresh board there
of course Shanklin is going to be in
some trouble there for the save Ray I
could go either way um I'm gonna take
avocado as a slight favorite in the
Chris U match and you know I think uh
the manova here will uh you know it's
gonna be I think that's even two as well
I think it's more of an even match but
at the end of the day all I need is what
a point here so that's that's enough
there like no there's no lopsidedness in
the unicorns there's gonna have to be
something special like we saw in the
last match where it was like oh they got
that right now in this round and it was
not that at all not even close in fact
and then we had to go into round four so
yeah definitely some difficult chess
here today but one more one more round
and I get the white pieces right here
against Shanklin I might even try to
force a draw not that hit car is you
know the least bit scared of anybody but
you know your team needs just one point
and he can get the job done himself but
if the opportunity arises where he can
play a forcing variation that ends the
game with the split point I think he
could go for it it just makes it the
rest of his teammates feel better but
you know hit car he always wants the
perfect score
and let's see what we have here in fact
uh I have all of Sam's courses on
Chesterville here so let's see which one
he goes with it was probably going to
see a classical Sicilian there
um that's what he has he knows other
stuff too as well here but I like this
and this is an annoying part of the
Sicilian right like you nothing Mainline
Bishop D3 Copic system type we go D4 and
these are nice positions for white but
also black hasco plates as well you're
just hoping to get a sicilian that you
wanted to play against and not one of
these anti-sicilians look at this
position look at D3 what is this
this slow play from a car he doesn't
want to allow a Sam to show off his
preparation and he's just playing this
like it's any other game just quiet
chess from Nakamura if the bishop ever
takes an F3 you get the pair of Bishops
the bishop slides back and watch out
because at some point G4 will force the
bishop back to G6 and then you can
either storm your Pawn of the board or
after G4 Bishop G6 but you're a knight
to H4 and get the pair of Bishops he's
doing it in a different way bringing his
Knight to G3 that's right looking good
yeah Knight to G3 maybe G4 first and ig3
first and then every castling probably
Queen side
what do you make of this change because
black Castle's Queen side why does
Castle kingside in must win territory
for Shanklin this probably is the kind
of position you want even though you're
playing the Beast that is akaro you do
want some aggressive positions and you
want to be able to push the pawns and
pieces forward here and he does he's
actually like he's doing that's why
Sicilian too as well for some
uncombative nature but you know uh
Hikaru chose to take it slow here but he
cannot for so long you know D5 is a move
is forcing some things you you're gonna
have to make some decisions even maybe
even Pawn C4 in there to loosen up some
stuff too as well is possible it is
possible for black book you know uh
black needs to just Advance his pieces I
think the king is a clear Target you
know whoever gets to the king first is
going to win in these opposite side
castles here the bishop is on G6 it
really is misplaced because you do want
to be able to play hng the ninth cover
that so it's kind of crazy how or
opposite side castles but I don't have
the attack I'm looking for yet
no not yet and uh well Sam thinks about
how to respond to nice for I want to
take our attention uh to the bird's eye
view because I feel like in the matchup
between the second boards uh better save
has not moved in a little while and you
know he finally does bring his Bishop
out to C4 Bobby Fischer style you know
sozen of variations but I thought for a
moment that perusev could try to make a
little cheeky three-time repetition that
is not what happened this game so in the
bottom left Christopher you with white
against shempstein and vocab that one is
spicy it opens Spanish so I like the way
the unicorns are playing and I'll I'll
say all four boards with the fourth were
only just started I think the unicorns
they just need to keep their chances
alive and at some point you have to go
all in yeah he has to go all in all
right and this is uh it's really opening
choice and of course uh how you feel
here are you sharp tactics everywhere
you got to take any advantage and if you
think it's risky hey if it is probably
is
maybe but obviously calculation will
help so you just have to take chances
and then take a few risks here
especially because this is for the team
hey it is what it is right I'd rather
you know die trying right that's what
it's about here so you have to uh try to
make it work because we need four wins
that's really tough
and I like what's happening on the
fourth board matchup between Zoe tang
and a Louis nermanova so you see that g
Pawn go up to G4 we got a king's Indian
going on over there uh James you should
be pretty happy with this because early
G4
go this way and go for an attack at some
point I love it I love it now of course
in the lines this is uh with the early
cheat wait it's black smooth right
because G4 is hanging oh it's white
black white and I C5 so here I used to
play you know and I'll play a lot of
Kings India myself I do love the Kings
Indian so this I forgot what is the move
is F3 Bishop F3 was a problem the show
three is a movie you don't want to play
so F3 was good H5 though right now I
think that's premature you're supposed
to play that at a certain point but it's
not now so H5 may be a slight error here
but okay you know I'm a fan of opening
up to the side so I'll take it maybe
take it and play H4 maybe just H4 right
now give you the plot takes Bishop G4 no
good
I just love your style of Chess James
you're always looking for that
checkmating attack let's open that thing
up and she's playing this well right she
decides to banish this Knight and if you
play Queen D2 I mean that Knight is not
getting out of here we'll just swap
pawns over here uh but the problem
oh wow yeah F5 was gonna get spicy over
there but this bishop maybe at the right
moment could take but it's interesting
she hasn't moved yet so she's not
thinking about taking one the bishop I
don't imagine that freeze the Knight up
the capture so she does play HG but I
feel like those moments there you could
preserve those 10 seconds there wasn't
really a need for her to calculate there
that is true yeah you could have oh oh
that's that's Theory that's Theory
that's Theory bro
that's real Rook F4 I'm not even
surprised I'm not even surprised that is
the actual King's Indian Theory right
and then you take and usually the bishop
can go to E7 you reroute it to E7 and
you take on G5 that way but the G5 Pawn
is hanging and this is what you just
open up the bishop line that's a very
cool sacrifice this play even Colin
Jones and his King's Indian course
recommends this as well
um also uh who else Camille plishka
recommends his Rook at four right you
know he this is a nice nice position of
sacrifice play quit by a loser she's
swinging right now chess lover says they
play this against the Canty bot so
that's chess level chest lovers in my
chat every day so that's who that is
what up door what's good chest level
right see you that's hilarious because I
mean let's just show everybody bring up
a Down Sport you put a broken F4 a
bishop can take it why not take some
material but the bishop takes Pawn takes
the bishop on G7 sees the length of
diagonal and if you keep taking stuff
sure you get a rook and a pawn for now
let's say I just take back on G5 with
the knight uh if you Castle Queen side
his Bishop comes out to E5 the queen is
now in trouble it slides back the queen
comes out to F6 with dual threats I'm
trying to pin and win the queen here I
mean this is just kind of beautiful
stuff in a king's Indian where now it's
White's night that can't move and
Black's pieces are free-flowing so no
move as a response to Rook to F4 I think
it's a bad sign for Zoe Tang she has not
seen this before I caught her off guard
yeah she's not seen this and this is the
type of uh Kings Indian that you want
like the king's Indian is that you hate
are the ones that are like like sword
glycoric or like you know the exchange
variation and Etc and things like that
that are very annoying to face this one
oh yeah we'll take this all day with the
black pieces because I'm able to
sacrifice things I'm able to play
dynamically G5 is straight up hanging
I'm getting this G Pawn whether you like
it or not so that's a huge threat right
now there's things going on right do I
take this exchange and go into what you
want me to do which is dark Square
Bishop it's a lot for her to think about
here and I think Lua is very comfortable
right
she is and she's barely spent any time
so while Zoe continues to think about
picking up that Rook on F4 let's see how
the teammates are doing because the
California unicorns uh the candy bot
didn't play out and you know what's
funny about I can't think about like
it's not even you know it's fine I was
like why doesn't the bot play I asked
him I'm like chess.com I played my bot
why don't they play exactly what I play
and it's like well we can't set it like
that and I was like well you need to set
it like that
they can't because it's like they have
to use a certain engine thing blah blah
blah
yourself I would never play so it's not
a real Jedi but it's like half a Jedi
ately
half a Jedi still seems like an absolute
Beast something that I'm would be afraid
of playing and look at this position
come on Jedi use your mind tricks here
what's going on in this game where Sam
Shanklin has a rook on the H file uh
it's even material I thought black was
up a pawn but there's that seventh Pawn
for white what's going on here oh you
know I actually like white in this
situation I'm just a weird Bishop on D1
but I'm definitely I feel like I can get
B4 in because I have this Pawn break as
you mentioned before right with Pawn
breaks how important those are I do feel
very nice with B4 and then after takes
A3 if takes on A3 Bishop E5 Bishop takes
and Rook takes you know A3 trying to
open up the file obviously G3 is hanging
but this is just an idea right to show
you what we're looking for and look at
this this is winning for white that's
crazy maybe it's C5 here oh oh my
goodness
and in 96 what is this gross oh man yeah
it's everyday chat oh my goodness this
is disgusting so I think it looks like
oh wow wow yeah yeah he tripping yeah he
went nice first that was wrong huh dang
hey you took on C4 because now if you
take the Knight on C4 you lose your
bishop and then we see a swap here and a
car says all right let me just get my
Bishops out there uh but James Black
currently is up a pawn at least but the
evil bar creeping up and up in a car's
favor
yeah definitely hear of the Bishops look
very nice of course as Hikaru loves his
Dynamic type of positions where you can
just do things with tactics obviously
but it is his move and the question is
what do we do
and excuse me engine's like this is over
like where is the kill shot what are you
talking about
maybe it's over what maybe it's just
something simple like this where you go
after all of Black's Pawns yeah that's a
very simple way to I mean you just take
and play yeah and you just it just
doesn't seem like that so crushing is
how the engine puts it but wow I guess
it really is it's a simple route too as
well it's very simple
I feel like that's not easy because you
have the pair of Bishops you want to
keep them right so moving this away but
Hikaru I mean he finds different things
all day yeah here it comes he definitely
goes forward
scooping up a pawn if he wants it I
could see him making other moves as well
like bringing a rook to the e-file
taking control of this one because the
Knight D6 is pinned but Hikaru is
playing really well right now uh for the
Gotham Knights uh it's looking nice for
him
and if he plays Queen E5 we saw that the
advantage is quite large
all he need is uh is a point here that's
it it's just one point and that's it got
the knights are winning this one and it
look it's looking like that if I'm Sam
I'm trying to hold off as long as I can
but then again well yeah like it you
would need like all three of them to win
and you would still lose like yeah you
can't lose like it's just
it's tough It's a very tough
yep and a car has not moved yet so
that's interesting to note that he is
thinking about how to continue after
taking the Knight on D5 so maybe his
intuition told him he had a part with
the pair of Bishops and have one versus
his Knight on D6 right the second move
will be very important because if black
is a couple turns we have to remember
that Sam is up a pawn and maybe these
pawns can start rolling up the queen
side yeah and there it is Queen E5 he
just played that boy he found it g7s
hanging 85 is hanging right and this can
be you could just take this to the house
very easy and also the Knight is still
open there which is problem problematic
you may have to play something like
Queen to C6 and just allow him to take
on G7 and try to play a orc to G8 but
that doesn't even do anything
and you can take on G5 that's tough man
yeah Shanklin needs to get these pawns
going but they're so far away you can't
even push the c-pawn without dropping
the d-pawn over here so for Sam it looks
like he is in a tough spot as you see a
car calculating with his oh he's giving
me the finger James
look at him right okay he's like oh yeah
now now and then I do this and this and
yes and uh yes and uh yes a classic
right triangle
well I mean Sam does not look very happy
and well you know he needs to win his
teammates need to win akara just won
this Pawn on G7 so he does have the
upper hand with the F7 Pawn the next
Target in the position so let's just see
how the teammates are doing because
every game will need to be won by
Unicorns to give them a chance here I've
seen the top right Ray Robinson he's
battling in a sicilian against Vladimir
fellow save where black is an active
Queen but not too much material
remaining I think that's pretty level in
the bottom left still pretty early going
uh for Christopher you and shamsiden
volkidov and the bottom right that
exchange sacrifice is paying off for
alua normanova so she might say I'll
take the smash into my own hands I know
it's been a struggle thus far but with
the black pieces on board four I feel
like James she's just dominating she may
have given up a rook but her minor
pieces are a lot alive and well and
white can hardly move what I like about
the king Indian is when it works oh it
works it's the best opening you ever
played but when it doesn't work it's the
worst Opening Ever it's like this is why
am I playing this opening is so bad oh
my goodness I hate this right but right
now everything's thriving for the king's
Indian player here so very cool stuff I
think this is uh pretty awesome for
blacks he has a very stable Advantage I
think practically engine doesn't think
as much but I think it's very practical
we got to get our bit we gotta get our
Rook off of the you know off of A8 as
well get our pieces in the game and try
to use these two pawns that we have on
the king side as well maybe even
something as crazy as moving the bishop
eventually you see Seven's hanging so
you have to maybe play A6 Bishop D7 and
then uh move uh King G7 move the Rook to
G8 and run the king all the way over
literally castling Queen side it's a
long long shot but you can you can do
this this is definitely something you
can do in this type of position
yeah the Trojan King march of that King
could get all the way to B8 and The Rook
this into the King of The Rook swap
places right that often is good for
black but what's also good for black is
a nearly five minute lead on the clock
pressure against the white king a white
kind of tied up and that's why Bishop D
through has played to free the E2 Square
for this Knight but if this bishop
slides back to E5 Knight E2 can be met
by a capture of the F3 Pawn so I feel
like it's still difficult for a white to
make any moves here and yes the time
difference is also massive in alua
normanova's favor so let's go away from
this because we have to Hikaru Nakamura
May clinch the match right now against
Sam Shanklin we see in the top left it
is a Sky High evaluation for Naka oh my
goodness what is going on bro Bishop D6
that boy can be taken twice two times oh
my gosh when you put a piece dive in on
a square that can be captured oh man
look at the tactics there you move the
Rook I take the Rook
you move the rook and go C8 I take on F5
you move the fa Rook I take the Knight
you move the Knight I take the Rook you
do Rook takes D6 I can take on D6 or
maybe maybe F5 or take step five but if
you actually could pick on D6 too though
like you can take off you can do
whatever you want right and then double
The Rook again and I got to pass G Pawn
like what do you want from me right what
do you want this is over everything is
is wrong here that was a sick move wait
man that's scary bro I mean he he
definitely definitely eating everything
all the Wheaties I mean half engine half
everything else like what the heck is
this
yeah he's playing a really nice game
here I think he saves his best for Less
because uh earlier games there were some
shaky moments against Christopher you
for example he was just down upon but
still managed to win and make it look
easy and now he could play trade Queen
takes D6 this G Pawn is scary this Rook
can join the party go for a back ranked
Checkmate uh I like G6 who cares about
this D3 Pawn keep it going that's true
G6 G7 looks great checking H1 and I'm
just kind of chilling you have to deal
with it everything comes Rook F1 queen
of fake queen z7 everything is game over
here beautiful game let me go over here
wow Rick F1 right he could have did
anything here
you know what kind of checkman he wants
this is pretty sick he wants if Queen D3
Rook f8 Queen E4 like ah protected Queen
d8 28 is mate background
background chat do your tactics
is that happening
he played A6 yeah oh man you can't stop
this Pawn now yeah I can't and it's too
many things
this potency five is hanging with check
as well he played D3 G7 D2 G8 white
Queens first and then there's a problem
on the back rank so yes this is a win in
the making for Hikaru Nakamura Shanklin
may just resign uh but that means
Nakamura goes to four out of four and
leads the knights to match victory yeah
I want to be the guy to lose and like
make my mask loose so I'm just gonna
just keep laying on and like let my time
run out
so you're saying that let you let
another teammate
so check back to
f8 over here
and then play G7 just this is promotion
I don't think you can stop it
is some stupid checks though Queen E5
check King G1 check it looks like some
stupidness there weirdly enough what the
heck is that about maybe I just go G3
check there check their King G2 check
their Queen E4 and then yeah queen king
H2 Queen G6 Queen f8
I'm going to translate what James was
just calculating for everybody so bring
up analysis board that at first it looks
like just a simple promotion but after
oh he goes Queen D6 instead which is so
nice no one checks for the black queen
but check here James and queen E5 check
and all of a sudden this King may have
some difficulty getting away like if you
play G3 we gotta check we got another
check if you block with your queen maybe
I take this Pawn I'm gonna go up here I
got all these checks then you made your
queen comes back over here and the black
is going this way like all of a sudden
it's hard to get this Pawn to promote
because the Queen's giving all these
checks there's so many there's so many
checks this is a problem so you just you
just said Queen D6 like deal with the
checks now but now we still yeah life's
still not over like it was too many
checks it's still not over but okay you
have to win this game many times that's
crazy and resignation he won it on the
spot and that means the match is over
the point was after Queen takes pawn
queen takes this one two extra pawns
Ricardo Nakamura he takes a sip of
whatever smoothie he's drinking and it
was a pretty smooth conversion for
Hikaru I hope it was a pineapple
smoothie otherwise it feels like a fraud
in the background on the wall for real
no matter what this player is not
fraudulent he is a champion a world
Fisher random Champion the board won for
the Gotham Knight and they have
officially won this match against the
California unicorns yeah and Hikaru
being the star player they're four out
of four right after losing and in the
last game or the last match the first
game uh but it's just 4-0 this time and
definitely a dominant performance here
eight and a half to four and a half
still some games left but at the same
time the knights are making it they are
making it to the next match
yeah and the board two matchup is like
the weirdest position ever I don't
really see what's happening there where
there's a bishop in front of the black
king that wasn't captured Ray Robson
down to 20 seconds and whoa squid
Sacrifice from ferrosev but his King is
the safer of the two watch out for a
Checkmate this Rook gets the h8 that's
game
yeah let me just uh uh okay Rook G one
a forest
I like it you can bring the bishop back
to C3 I said Rook C1 too
which two one check check check
H4 oh my goodness Rook C1 Queen D2 yeah
King H7 Rick h a king G6 H4 he has to
work F2 luckily but if Rook G2 is H5 is
mate
oh James is going for this H5 Checkmate
but as he's pointed out it looks really
strong but Rook F2 Saves the Day cutting
off the circulation between the rook and
this bishop because H5 no longer is made
as the king can take this bishop so
let's go back to the game that was a
sick variation Rook F3 speaking of sick
variations what's going on can you just
take this Pawn or is there a rook H3
Rook h a Checkmate whoa wait that's what
he was trying to get it off wait what
happens you got a Perpetual what's going
on here you gotta prepare H3 he must
have a repair
oh yes oh my gosh I don't understand you
know King here King here and The Rook
slides back oh
he like you got tactics
I got tactics did you forget I'm big Ray
and have a nice day you forgot you
forgot something tells me the tactics
are not done here in federal Sav he's
looking as rookie one he wants a
Checkmate oh glass completely oh my
goodness you see how fast he played that
you sound fast
you he's now an instant
it's like he knows he's gonna do that
he's picking up this rook and I don't
know where it's gonna go like anywhere
in this file leads a Checkmate or rookie
two will pick up this Rook if somehow
you can stop the mate but you can't see
three only here and then Queen A8 and
then he gonna stare at the camera real
hard
to the camera real hard just to let
y'all know ain't nothing you can do
about this one ain't nothing you can do
now you can try Rook C8
true distract the queen they only take
the Rook over here but Queen G4 check
happens you're gonna lose your Bishop oh
man F6 it's loose pieces drop off and
this is going to be a win for Ray Robson
no not enough for the unicorns but that
will be a confidence builder for Rey he
had a good chance against Nakamura that
slipped away but he's gonna take down
fedasev in the last round yeah that was
uh that was sick finally we got some
nice Ray tattoos here you know some nice
raid tactics
yeah he's feeling good about this one
nothing else to do this Rook slides back
it's gonna be Checkmate if this Rook
slides here you can sandwich
you're working between anywhere let's go
back there
game and over
and whoa Christopher you apparently
winning in his game in the bottom left
so like suddenly all of the unicorns are
winning but Hikaru already got the job
done so that's when they all woke up in
this round
the Unicorn was like all right let's
fight and then this is a little too late
yeah and it's good for the knights that
Hikaru is such a monster because look at
this position this Pawn is hanging if
this Pawn pushes C4s hang White's
already up one Pawn
30 seconds for Christopher you yeah
right that look trap I can go back here
okay F6
um
it's pretty good it's maybe F4 or
something yeah Queen D4 over 55 is
beautiful
just look at those Quiet Moves James I
was looking for tactics he's just like
no let me go win the D5 Pawn easy
work one trade him off bro
easy
so Christopher you can bring his Rook up
to D7 with check where is this King
going oh
whoa wait okay H4 E5 too that's
beautiful yeah you had to stop the check
or not at least neutralize when H5 is
mate
so he trades but two extra pawns or
Christopher you this is a clear win for
him and rokita makes a couple moves but
let's go after this pawn and you just
want to swap two extra pounds of the
king side
four F4
yeah all the moves are gonna be good and
yeah you're gonna see a trade and we
might even see a resignation at this
point because white is up yeah there it
is white is and so Christopher you takes
it down uh Shem scene and vokita that
leaves us with one game remaining
between Zoe tang and alua normanova and
I can't believe what I'm seeing there
because Black's position was dominant on
board four so let's bring that game up
it's the only one remaining and
yeah this is suddenly Zoe tang and this
just speed of confidence Builders if she
can take down her opponent here maybe as
she plays more protesting matches she'll
start be feeling really good definitely
yeah we have ourselves A Swindle here
something happened this was a king's
Indian game with the Rook sacrifice on
that four which just seemed very nice
and they're very cool and Etc but after
the dust settle and you do need a level
of precision and accuracy after you able
to sacrifice this exchange to be able to
keep up with uh what white can do so she
wasn't able to do that here and white
looks like it's just gonna come away
with it man unicorns crushed this round
hey bro they're crazy like they
literally snap this round it's just
tikaru because if Hikaru did not win
that game this would not be a match
victory for the knights but now with the
King on E6 this king is soon going to be
checkmated it would appear just bring
your Rook the last rank somehow I mean
it's like a one point game now I mean
literally yeah because the car won you
know having a heavy weight like that on
there just to get the job done he got it
done but wow I mean eight and a half
this might be and this was like eight
and a half seven and a half
that's what them yeah
which is crazy
this Rook is not gonna be able to Parry
off too and we're gonna have to see a
check back here the only move will be
Rook f8 you just take it and then you
win this Pawn over here so it doesn't
matter which Rook does it but Zoe tank
will pick up A6 or b-pawn will run and
she's gonna win this game just don't
trade them yes right exactly there we go
clean up shop here
well done I mean this is a teenager from
California David Bruce was on earlier
talking about how she's been in the
California chess scene and she's getting
an opportunity a unique opportunity to
play against super Grand Masters uh in
the protest league and she's winning her
final round game good for her
very good very good
so he's trying to Rook take C5
oh don't do it now yep has to be the
right moment
yes
this is a king cut off the king would
like to be somewhere on B7 and well no
pieces can move James
we need to ring these six yeah beautiful
move
and Queenie next resignation
game over game set match and she just
left to build it she said I don't want
to be a part of this anymore I lost all
four games but Zoe Tank scores for the
unicorns that's a nice win for her as
you know this is not enough for this
week's match but it is a 3-1 kind of
consolation prize for the unicorns yeah
you probably can frame that and be like
you know how's your match go and you
show him that like oh yeah look at this
you know like we crushing right we lost
the whole match okay but at the end of
the day but man this one right here if
we would have had another match like we
don't know what's gonna happen if seven
have eight and a half wow great job from
unicorns here because they were able to
really strike back you know in this
round but all we needed was one and
Hikaru got the job
the car did and as we see the overall
scores Hikaru Nakamura won a perfect
four out of four so Ray Robson led the
unicorns with three points he beat
Federal save in that final round but it
just wasn't enough as ikaru was too much
for unicorns that means James that with
Naka gone perfect and federal save and
broke it off chipping in with two and a
half and two uh for them that means the
Gotham Knights go to a perfect 2-0 thus
far in the season when you look at these
top four teams James are those the names
you'd more or less expect to see there
Gotham Knights and Indian yogis and I
was looking for the saint uh St Louis
the archbishops I'm this is so crazy you
do not see the archbishops they were
it's just been a legendary team they
still are but um right now they're all
in two so it's very very tough and to
see but I mean Gotham nice Definitely um
Tigers was not really expecting I did I
knew they were strong but I was like Wow
92 no the chest Wizards I think is a is
a surprise too as well but definitely
the Indian Yogi and some like any Indian
theme is going to be very close to 2-0
because it's in the water over there
right they got like three teams in the
PCL so something like that so it's
pretty nasty and James you're a team
captain so let me ask you about a team
like the Capybaras uh they were knocked
out in the first round I mean it was not
close at all and only lasted three
rounds but then in the second week they
destroyed their opponent and I mean it
wasn't close so when you make a free
agent signing like vladis love artemiev
so what do you make of the new look
Capybaras because I feel like what we
saw in week one is not representative
what's to come that's true especially
with artemiev I mean it was he was like
a like just kind of like how we picked
up Bortnick and we was like how is
Bortnick old and founder board Nick
wasn't even picked up are you kidding me
so we picked him up and then he enhanced
our team instantly same thing you see
with the Brazil capybara so you know
these are shake-ups these are people
that you don't even know what's going to
really happen and it really is about the
lineups too how is that lineup gonna
look going in there going in that day
against who did they have so it's really
about who has that best lineup that day
because these teams are like I mean if
you really put it together they're
virtually even slightly better than
another team you've got a lot of Heavy
Hitters on your team I do too as well
but in this match today who actually is
going to be the better lineup that we
have and I think those lineups are very
important so copy barriers you can count
them out especially with artemia
yeah I'm not counting them out for sure
but as we look to the second half of the
standings some teams well they may be
out after next week's action I see your
Garden State passers you're chilling
there one out of two that's good you won
week two but down towards the bottom we
saw the Berlin Bears lose today the St
Louis archbishops will play the Bears
and the maniac shrimps of the cobra
two of those teams James are about to be
eliminated
which two do you think are going to
survive and which two are going to be
sent home after next week I am a big fan
of archbishops I just believe in them of
course I do like those guys I mean I've
been a fan of them a long time and I'm
going to say Charlotte the second one
because that's a newer team and you know
I have a special uh spot in my heart for
Charlotte I love Charlotte in fact I
hate FM there and like I just have all
so many memories in Charlotte even
having one of my best tournaments ever
two of them actually I mean back in
Charlotte so Charlotte I want to see
Charlotte succeed absolutely but they're
gonna have to fight very hard to not
face elimination
this league is brutal there is no easy
opposition and we will resume the
protest League not tomorrow yet the
weekend off follow the Collegiate chess
league but on Tuesday we will have
another double header I love this format
where two matches happen every single
day from Tuesday to Friday and the
Brazil capybarros we were just talking
with them they take on the Norway gnomes
and then later in the day an elimination
match Charlotte cobras against the Spain
Spanish Maniac shrimp so James let's
start with a Cappy bars the Gnomes these
are two fun teams two teams with kind of
a diverse lineup of players from all
around the globe who do you think has
the edge in that one and then who has
the edge between the cobras and the
maniac shrimp I think sometimes when you
pick up a player that's like you know
like uh you know in basketball like the
trades that happen where like a team is
pretty good they okay and the trade
happens and they become Elite and I
think the Capybaras did that with our
temmiev so when he came in there oh boy
it's a problem now because now you know
we can move some people around so now we
can play a little bit differently and
the stats would be a little bit
different lineups would be different so
I think that's a strong one there I'm
going to take copy Bears there in
Charlotte whereas The Maniacs rims we
just played the maniac streams as the
Garden State passers we got a dub there
so what we want is we're going to uh we
won't go with Charlotte
okay you're going with Charlotte there
and I gotta ask you James you know
you're you know being unbiased as a
commentator right now but you're also
kind of your captain you're scouting out
the opposition are there any teams you
would like to see knocked out like when
you look at Brazil you look at Norway
you know as you try to make the playoffs
is there a team between the two of them
that you would rather not see if you
make the playoffs Charlotte for sure
Charlotte 100 Love Charlotte but if it
comes to us and the Garden State passes
peace is going to be the password for
football and you can pass up your
opportunity into the this match okay get
about it here right so but uh Charlotte
definitely and also I'm gonna have to go
with yeah copy Bears I mean artillery is
a a force he's played in many events
very very strong events even with Hikaru
I remember he beat Hikaru in a match I
was doing commentary on so I was like oh
yeah our Timmy have in the match yeah we
need to get him out of here so if they
can get eliminated cool you know do your
thing we don't uh we won't be mad at you
okay
yeah I feel you James vladislav our
Tamia is a beast to get takedown even
the best players in the world like a car
and Magnus the Cappy borrowers and many
other teams in the league have a new
look but the T the season will continue
next week we have two weeks of action
behind us we know who's thriving at the
moment with 2-0 records we know teams
that are on the brink of elimination and
we will see who survives come week three
which happens on Tuesday the 28th so for
now we say goodbye we thank you for
joining us we hope you have a great
weekend enjoy more chess the Collegiate
chess league is tomorrow you can play
the Luca Buck at any moment you can play
my butt and James's bot so go ahead have
some fun keep enjoying chess on
chess.com but for now we say goodbye and
see you on Tuesday
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you